[musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Vincent
Vincent Louveau, je suis sénateur
d'Indré Loir, agriculteur, éleveur de
vaches limousine en Indréeloir.
Fabien Bouglet, je suis expert en
politique énergétique. J'ai écrit trois
livres, un sur les éoliennes, le
nucléaire, le dernier guerre de
l'énergie au cœur du nouveau conflit
mondial, tous publiés aux éditions du
rocher. Et je suis directeur de
publication du magazine Transition et
énergie. Donc voici le dernier numéro
magazine que j'ai racheté avec le CRM
centre de recherche pour le mix
énergétique en juillet dernier.
Et moi Nicolas Mayant donc je suis
ingénieur de formation euh j'ai
travaillé dans le secteur de l'énergie
et du transport. J'étais 4 ans
conseiller scientifique avec France
Stratégie.
Sur ces sujets, je regarde aussi
l'industrie et euh je suis aussi
entrepreneur avec ma femme qui est
entrepreneuse dans le bien-être féminin
puisqu'il a une entreprise de culottes
menstruelles qui s'appelle Réjan et de
Sextoy qui s'appelle Goyave.
Mais France,
auparavant, on était méde France mais
malheureusement on a dû faire comme
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise pour
pouvoir survivre, c'est-à-dire avoir des
ateliers aussi en dehors de France.
Alors ce soir, on va parler énergie, on
va parler Europe, on va parler Mercour,
on va parler menace sur les intérêts de
notre pays, la France. On va commencer
par vous Nicolas, toi Nicolas parce que
le le départ de l'interview sur le fait
de la délocalisation pour des questions
énergétiques ou de coût de production ou
d'impôts. Pourquoi ?
C'est une bonne question. Alors, j'ai
passé un peu de temps pendant ses
vacances à me à me relaxer et quand j'ai
mon relaxe, j'ai du temps soit pour
lire, soit pour regarder des vidéos et
j'ai vu un documentaire très intéressant
qui a été fait par un quelqu'un qui
s'appelle Camille Adam, si je dis pas
btique, qui s'appelle au nom de
l'Europe. Comme moi je suis n en 1981,
en fait, il y a toute une période jusque
jusqu'à les années 2000 où je
m'intéressais moins à ces sujets-là. Et
en fait, je me suis rendu compte qu'on
avait un petit souci sur l'Europe et
notamment qu'en fait l'Europe du général
de Gaulle, la communauté
économique européenne, ça se passait
bien pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'on était pas nombreux, on était six
et qu'on avait quelqu'un qui défendait
nos intérêts comme le général de Gaulle
et que s'il était pas d'accord, il
faisait la politique de HSV.
Et puis ensuite, on a eu on a eu
François Milteran et et Rocard qui pour
quand le l'Allemagne s'est réunifié ont
eu peur d'une Allemagne trop puissante.
Ils sont dit "On va leur clouer la main
avec l'Union européenne et on va leur
mettre une monnaie commune dans les dans
les dans les pattes." Et en fait ça
c'est le début de nos problèmes. C'est
le début de problème juste pour finir
parce qu'en fait depuis 1985 pour
l'industrie, on est sur le dodchmark, on
est politique du francfort puis
eurofort. Et c'est ça qui fait qu'on on
s'est décimé notre industrie puisquon a
perdu la possibilité de dévaluer le
notre monnaie quand les Allemands eux à
la début de l'année 2000 ont fait de la
dévaluation salariale
compétitive
compétitive et ça ça nous a mis dedans.
les les Grecs, les Portugais, les
Espagnols on dû suivre et nous on est
les prochains sur la liste.
Donc on va passer la parole à monsieur
le sénateur Vincent qui fait partie
d'une commission ou d'un groupe du Sénat
sur la prospective. On a regardé,
c'était aussi intéressant qu'une porte
de prison avec la pertinence d'un filet
d'eau tiède. Euh qu'est-ce que vous
faites là-bas ?
Bonne question. La prospective,
c'est une commission un peu
un peu à part. On a des commissions
institutionnelles et la prospective a le
même traitement que la Commission
européenne dont je fais partie où on est
des on parle de choses qui ne seront pas
retranscrites dans la loi. C'est-à-dire
que toutes les autres commissions
travaillent la loi qui vient de
l'Assemblée nationale. la commission
prospective, une commission qui est
faite pour prendre de l'avance sur des
grandes thématiques euh et avec tout
l'inconvénient de ça en fait où euh
j'ai pas vu beaucoup d'avance hein, j'ai
j'ai plus vu une réunion tuperware un
peu améliorée euh façon je je chambre je
chambre. Non mais vous avez raison parce
que la difficulté au Sénat, c'est le
consensus en fait du Sénat qui fait qu'à
la fin c'est plus de l'eau tiède et euh
ça finit un peu en fait avec des
ambitions qui sont revues revues à la
baisse et que euh la prospective comme
la la Commission des affaires
européennes en fait
on déclare pas le tempo quoi. Le tempo
est pas au Sénat. Enfin, je veux dire
euh enfin ça serait
ça serait déjà euh après l'objectif de
ces commissions, c'est quand même
prendre du recul et une certaine avance
de phase sur des sujets dont on est
carrément à la ramasse.
Donc bah les grands sujets comme le
numérique, comme l'espace euh vous
imaginez la loi de l'espace alors que ça
sera une sera une ça dépasse
complètement le législateur que je suis.
Donc automatiquement euh la géopolitique
euh les grands les grands les grands
enjeux de société euh macroéconomique
euh dépasse complètement euh le les
parlementaires qui vivent au quotidien
sur des projets de loi, des propositions
de loi sur des choses qui sont le
quotidien et qui sont en fait le le fait
de de faire du vélo en regardant l'avant
de sa roue
et on ne on ne cherche pas à lever la
tête. fait et avoir une vraie stratégie
et ça c'est dommageable. Qui
c'est qui on c'est le Sénat ? C'est nos
politiques. C'est quoi
en fait ? C'est une habitude. C'est une
c'est pas le Sénat, c'est pas c'est une
habitude. Les gouvernements pour durer
ont des objectifs qui sont pas les mêmes
que ce que devrait être intérêts du
pays.
Les intérêts du pays par exemple.
Qu'est-ce qu'un sénateur peut répondre à
un entrepreneur ou à des chefs
d'entreprise qui peuvent nous regarder
là concernant la pérennité du business
français, la pérénité de l'industrie
française par rapport à la politique
énergétique qu'on nous a mis dans les
les mains.
J'étais dans le bureau du premier
ministre et je lui ai dit "Vous pouvez
lequel lequel ? que c'était Berou à
l'époque.
Et et je lui je lui disais
euh vous pouvez vous retourner et
commencer à à réfléchir pour que pour
couper les arbres et commencer à à faire
des planches pour les cercueils de nos
entreprises si on revoit pas la
trajectoire sur l'énergie par exemple.
Vous êtes au courant qu'il était au
commissariat au plan ?
Oui, je sais. Mais euh
enfin tout ça c'est bien gentil mais
tout ça on voit que c'est old school.
C'est-à-dire que on atterrit sur un
entre soi qui fait de la prospective qui
est tout sauf de la stratégie. En fait,
la stratégie doivent être définie par
des experts
avec un arbitrage à la fin politique
quand
et et financier.
Alors, le financier, c'est l'outil.
Après
non, quand je dis un arbitrage,
c'est-à-dire que quand je vois la
balance commerciale plongée, la balance
commerciale française, c'est forcément
qu'il y a une stratégie de perle pin,
c'est-à-dire que les prises de décision
n'ont pas été faites, c'est-à-dire que
la sanction, on la voit sur la balance
commerciale française.
Non, mais vous parlez un agriculteur, la
balance commerciale française de
l'agroalimentaire qui était
exceptionnelle, on était les premiers en
Europe, vas-y que je te pousse. Et à la
fin, au final, on est au même niveau que
1978. C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est fait
passer devant par les Polonais, les
Italiens.
Tu commences ta grffe de la fin quand ?
Ah ben non, mais moi je suis entré en
résistance il y a longtemps parce que en
fait je sens cette dégradation qui est
une dégradation et et c'est la méthode
française en fait. C'est la
dévitalisation par la médiocrité de
notre économie qui fait que aujourd'hui
on a des chefs d'entreprise qui en
peuvent plus qui sont chaud patates. On
a des salariés qui en peuvent plus non
plus parce qu'ils ont l'impression
d'être trimballés. Et on a une économie
qui se fait dévitaliser par la dépense
publique parce qu'en fait que ça soit le
prix des poubelles, le prix de l'eau, on
te dévitalise par le dessous et à la fin
tu as plus de fric pour pour consommer
et pour réellement participer à quelque
chose de bien. Moi, j'ai ma petite Nièce
qui est à Paris qui a 1900 balles de de
salaire et qui se tape 1000 balles de
loyer et elle se dit "Vincent, j'ai quoi
comme avenir demain dans cette société ?
Elle a même pas 200 balles par mois pour
aller au théâtre, pour aller alors que
tu es à Paris et que tu es à 200 m de de
de d'une vraie vie. Arrive à manger.
Elle arrive à manger parce que parce que
je l'invite au resto et qu'on se
débrouille. Mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que une société qui configure euh
une histoire qui est pas une belle
histoire comme en ce moment, ça peut pas
marcher. C'est-à-dire que nos jeunes ont
des difficultés. J'ai ma fille qui a 21
ans, elle a du mal à trouver un
positionnement en fait. trouver un
positionnement dans sa dans sa vie de
jeune femme et trouver un positionnement
dans sa vie universitaire parce que
aujourd'hui on a quand même tout le
monde a le droit d'aller à l'université
alors que peut-être qu'elle aurait fallu
qu'elle aille plus sur un côté de
travailler directement peut-être
ou d'apprendre non parce qu'elle a elle
a eu le bac elle a eu tout ça elle est à
la fac mais la fac c'est un goulot
d'étranglement où tu dis par principe
tout le monde va aller aller à la fac on
file le bac à 97 % de de la corte et au
final c'est la fête à Neneux on on il Il
y a plus de de notation, c'est-à-dire on
leur met des couleurs. Tu as vu ça où
qu'il y avait des couleurs dans la vraie
vie, il y a surtout des sanctions si tu
te comportes mal et puis si tu es bon et
ben tu es récompensé. Donc on déconnecte
de la réalité nos enfants. Le Covid est
passé par là, on les renferme sur
eux-mêmes. Moi, je suis très défiant sur
des choses. Ma fille, par exemple, veut
pas faire d'enfant. Euh, elle considère
que elle considère que il faut pas faire
d'enfant parce que parce qu'il y a pas
de futur
le réarmement démographique voulu par
notre président solaire Emmanuel Macron.
Ben, il va falloir se bouger parce que
là,
il y a pas de médecin parce qu'il y a
pas de crèche parce qu'il y a 8h
d'attente aux urgences parce que quand
tu te balades dans Paris, tu as une
chance sur deux de te faire ennuyer.
Le réarmement
si si vous si vous n'avez pas votre
capacité à acheter votre maison par
exemple quand tu as 30 40 ans parce que
tu as plus les moyens parce que l'État
ne fonctionne de trop, si
parce que les banques prêtent pas
parce que les banques ne prêtent pas
parce que tout ça c'est très lié. Si euh
on te on t'explique que tu as pas de ta
place dans la société, comment ça se
fait que tu peux avoir une envie d'avoir
des enfants où tu vas te poser et puis
on a cérébralisé les choses. Il y a une
philosophe qui disait euh j'entendais la
semaine dernière qui disait "Arrêtez de
réfléchir, faites des gosses quoi. Euh
parce que si tu réfléchis au fait qu'
d'avoir l'appart, trouver une nounou,
trouver une nounou aujourd'hui en ville
ou même à la campagne, déjà ça coûte du
pognon mais en plus il faut la il faut
la trouver. Combien vous gagnez ?
Tu as dit
combien vous gagnez ?
Ah bah moi je suis s
combien tu gagnes ?
Ah bah moi combien je gagne ? C'est très
simple. Euh quand ma ferme marche
correctement, ce qui est plus du tout le
cas aujourd'hui, euh je gagnais 30 40000
€ par an. Euh à peu près net, à peu près
net.
Euh aujourd'hui, c'est beaucoup plus
raide. Et sénateur, en tant que
sénateur, je gagne 4500 € par mois,
quoi. Enfin, il y a pas de cash, tout
ça, c'est public. Et puis et puis
la retraite le fond de retraite des des
sénateurs.
Non mais la retraite des du fond est
confortable
là il est confortable. Vous inquiétez
pas pour moi. C'est pas le c'est c'est
pas le sujet. C'est pas mon sujet en
fait. Moi je suis pas venu au Sénat pour
pour ma retraite. Je suis venu au Sénat
pour changer les choses et puis dire
enfin moi je suis un paysan. J'ai fait
j'ai été simple élu local. J'ai fait
toutes les strates en fait du du cumul
de mandat et à la fin est-ce que je vais
à Paris ? Est-ce que je vais pas Paris ?
Bah oui, je viens à Paris parce que je
sens l'effervescence de toutes les
plaques économiques et de toutes les
plaques de société et je me dis le jour
où ça va péter, je vais en être.
On va revenir vers vous après pour le
mercourd. Le conseil pour le chef
d'entreprise en France, c'est barre-toi
ou reste ici.
Non, reste ici. Il faut qu'il croit il
faut qu'il ait l'espoir de se dire que
des mecs comme moi, on va on va se dire
on va se bouger le pistil pour changer
les choses, descendre notre dépenses et
notre drogue de la dépense publique et
commencer à écrire quelque chose qui a
un peu de sens. Avoir de l'énergie,
c'est le sujet à un prix accessible à 50
€ le MWh. Tout le reste, c'est de la
littérature. On se donne des objectifs,
on se tient une stratégie et on déplie
ces stratégies et on arrête les systèmes
complètement ubuesques où on va investir
des milliards d'euros dans une énergie
qu'on a déjà produite avec le nucléaire
et qui aujourd'hui nous nous satisfait
tout à fait. Fabien, le conseil pour le
chef d'entreprise en terme de
perspective énergétique, en terme de
coût, notre facture d'électricité, elle
va exploser, pas exploser ? Comment ça
se passe ? Est-ce qu'il y a déjà est-ce
qu'il y a déjà de l'investissement qui a
été fait ? Est-ce que quand j'entends
j'ai pas fini, est-ce que vous avez pris
de la cocaïne avant de venir [rires] ou
trop de café ? Comment ça se passe ? Je
prends je prends pas de de ce produit
là.
Très bien, laissez-moi terminer. Donc le
le quand on voit Agnès Panagère Runaché
du temps où elle était aux affaires sur
les côtés énergétiques, elle dit euh on
va recruter 100000 personnes dans le
nucléaire, on va relancer la filiale et
que voilà. Moi, j'ai envie de lui dire
Agnè tu crois dans un ami imaginaire,
comment ça se passe ? C'est des belles
paroles. Le le conseil pour le chef
d'entreprise en terme de perspective
énergétique, je vous laisse commencer.
Je vous laisse commencer. Je vais
revenir sur la question de l'Europe
parce que avant de parler euh des
questions de la facture, il faut
comprendre d'où on est parti et comment
on est arrivé là. Il faut rappeler qu'a
créée la Communauté européenne en 1957
avec deux traités, le traité de Rome et
la Communauté européenne de l'énergie
atomique. Et ça avait été mis en place.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a eu la
nationalisation du canal de Suèse par
NASER. Et l'Union européenne au travers
de la Communauté européenne a été
constituée par les créateurs de l'Union
européenne pour assurer la souveraineté
énergétique de l'Europe avec le
contrebalancement de la nationalisation
du canal de Suèze et à l'époque
parle moins fort il y a mon ingénieur
qui mon ingénieur [rires] qui fait
l'Union soviétique l'Union soviétique et
les États-Unis avaient contesté la
victoire la victoire de l'Europe qui
avait été une victoire militaire et donc
pour contrebalancer, on crée la
communauté de l'Europe. Et en fait le
problème c'est que les pays européens
ont oublié la raison pour laquelle on
avait créé la communauté européenne,
c'est la souveraineté énergétique. Et
aujourd'hui,
oublié ou c'est la supputation ou c'est
non ? Ils l'ont oublié. Ils l'ont
oublié. Pourquoi ? parce que on a eu
pendant 20 ans à partir des années 80 et
en particulier avec le plan MESM en
France, on a eu
un on va dire un paradis énergétique
avec un pays français en France qui
était vraiment très abondant en
électricité grâce à nos réacteurs
nucléaires. Donc ça c'est très
important. Ensuite, le deuxième constat
qui est fondamental, c'est que euh
l'Europe,
tu veux pas essayer de me chuchoter
parce [rires] que moi je suis comme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, c'estd que je suis
un peu sourd.
Alors, je t'entends très bien mais mon
ingénieur du son, il est en train de
condusser là. L'Europe
euh est à 58 % dépendant de ses
ressources énergétiques. C'est-à-dire
que pour pouvoir consommer, elle doit
importer 58 % de toutes ces ressources
énergétiques. Face à l'Union européenne,
les États-Unis sont autonomes
énergétiquement depuis le gaz de chiste
de 2019 et la Russie est autonome
autonome énergétiquement depuis le
début. Quand on a dit ça, ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que d'un point de
vue géopolitique,
c'est quoi vos sources ? Parce que le
principal fournisseur du
c'est le le
le principal fournisseur du royaume des
États-Unis, c'est la Russie.
Oui. Oui. Non, mais quand je dis
autonome énergétiquement, ça veut dire
que les États-Unis produisent sur leur
soloin
en importation
de d'énergie, toutes sortes toute source
d'énergie confondu.
Nicolas, tu es d'accord ? Sauf le
pétrole à l'exception.
Je pense que je pense que Fabien parle
du pétrole et du gaz.
Non non, tout confondu. L'électricité,
le pétrole, le gaz, sauf le pétrole où
il y a un déficit euh et le États-Unis
ne sont légèrement dépendants des
importations, mais totalement et
globalement, les États-Unis sont
autonomes énergétiquement depuis Donald
Trump. Bon, en Russie, c'est le cas
également. La Russie est autonome
énergétiquement toute source d'énergie
confondue. Donc évidemment ça met
l'Union européenne dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée de dépendance
politique et géopolitique et vis-à-vis
de la Russie, on l'a vu, avec le Gaz et
avec l'Allemagne et avec les États-Unis.
Dans ce contexte, évidemment que les
autres pays européens ont un poids
extrêmement important vis-à-vis de
l'Europe et peuvent imposer et
vassaliser l'Europe. Et en fait, le
problème en particulier avec ce qui
s'est passé avec la Russie et le
l'explosion du gaz auoduc Nordstreamin
est deux problème avec les États-Unis
qui veulent imposer leur vente de gaz de
chiste, on l'a vu avec la commande des
750, le fait d'imposer à l'Europe de
consommer 750 milliards en en source
d'énergie, et bien c'est que toute cette
politique de dépendance vont influer sur
la facture énergétique des Français, des
petites et moyennes entreprises et des
industries. Et
avec quel facteur ?
Comment
Vous voulez de de Ah bah c'est un
facteur important. C'est très difficile
à quantifier parce que vous allez avoir
l'impact du prix du gaz comme le marché
européen de l'électricité est indexé sur
l'unité de production la plus chère et
que en général c'est le gaz qui est le
plus cher, ça va jouer sur le le coût de
l'électricité. Mais c'est très difficile
de quantifier la part. Ce qui est clair,
c'est que et on va revenir sur le sujet
que vous avez évoqué dès le départ, la
facture d'électricité des Français puis
des petites et moyennes entreprises,
elle est découpée en trois. la part
d'électricité, la part de de taxe et de
l'assise. l'assise qui est la taxe qui
sert à financer les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes, les
subventions et la taxe de raccordement
et de réseau électrique, le turpe 1/3
1/3 1/3 le l'augmentation du coût de
l'électricité pendant le on va dire le
conflit en Ukraine et pendant la crise
du gaz de 2021 et 2022 était lié en
partie au coût du gaz et à la non
disponibilité des réacteurs nucléaires.
la moitié des réacteurs nucléaires
français étant à l'arrêt en raison des
corrosions sous contrainte. Donc
l'explosion du prix de l'électricité en
2022 et 2023 était liée à l'explosion du
besoin en importation d'électricité en
France, du prix du gaz et de la non
disponibilité des réacteurs nucléaires.
Puis progressivement, corrélativement
depuis 2014, vous avez ça sur les
chiffres puisque vous parlez de sources,
il y a eu un rapport qui a été rendu par
le SDES du ministère de l'écologie qui
est disponible sur internet, qui a été
publié en juillet 2025 et qui mentionne
bien que la facture d'électricité des
ménages et un petit peu dans une moindre
mesure des petites et moyennes
entreprises a augmenté de 100 % entre
2014 et 2024 et la facture des ménages a
augmenté de 18 % en tout et 14 % ces
deux dernières années, c'estàd peu près
35 % en 2 ans. On a eu une augmentation
de 35 % en 2 ans. Et ça évidemment cette
augmentation de 100 % depuis 2014 est en
grande partie d au financement des
énergies intermittentes, aux
subventions. On a à peu près selon les
chiffres de la commission de régulation
d'énergie une charge de service public
de sur ces factures, ces énergies
intermittente plus le biogaz et le le
tout ce qui est vert l'hydroélectricité
de l'ordre de 10 milliards d'euros avec
une augmentation de 2 milliards. Tout ça
c'est une incidence et il y a une autre
incidence, c'est que comme on a
multiplié par 3 le nombre d'éoliennes
depuis le mandat de François Hollande
hein, donc quand François Hollande est
arrivé et aujourd'hui on a multiplié par
trois les éoliennes, on a effectivement
également multiplié les panneaux
solaires et bien il a fallu raccorder,
créer des coûts de raccordement et tout
ça a un impact considérable sur la
facture d'électricité. À mimot, il y a
eu une augmentation de l'électricité
pendant la guerre liée au gaz et au coût
de l'électricité. Et il y a sur le long
terme augmentation de la facture
d'électricité qui est liée à la
transition énergétique qui nous a été
imposée par l'Allemagne avec l'énergie
VIN 2 et qui nous impose de déployer des
énergies intermittentes subventionnées.
Je rappelle et ça c'est très important
puisque pour être concret de marché il
est de l'ordre de 50 € le MWh le prix de
marché la subvention des éoliennes
terrestres de l'ordre de 90 à 100 € le
MWh. les éoliennes en mer en moyenne 200
€ le MWh et le solaire aux alentours de
200 également. Donc la différence,
vous allez voir les les sénateurs, les
députés, vous leur expliquez ça.
Quand je vais voir le sénateur Vincent
Louau, vous toucher trop, vous me
touférence
de presse en avril dernier euh au Sénat
avec 80 parlementaires que tu as réuni,
plus 20 experts dont Henry Progliot que
vous avez reçu et
Henri, on t'embrasse [rires]
et euh André Merlin, Bernardoyer
Exactement qui et tous ces experts, il y
avait une vingtaine d'experts, il y
avait eu il y avait 80 parlementaires de
tout groupe politique. confondu et on
avait publié un communiqué de presse sur
l'explosion de la facture d'électricité
et le rôle des énergies intermittentes.
Ils ont saisi que notre business, notre
PIB était en danger ou pas du tout ?
Oui, parce que la programmation,
ils ont saisi euh pour vous faire
plaisir ou ils ont pris des mesures
proactives pour défendre nos boîtes ?
Vous parlez des sénateurs ou vous parlez
du gouvernement ?
Les deux. Bah le gouvernement à l'issue
de cette alerte qui faisait qui était
précédée de l'alerte que nous avions
publié dans le point avec 10 autres
spécialistes don Henry Progliot dans le
point avec un jacuse énergétique on
avait publié Nous dénonçons. On
expliquait avec une dizaine de points
pourquoi notre politique énergétique
partait en live et posait d'énormes
difficultés et ont demandait au
gouvernement de ne pas promulguer la
programmation puréannuelle de l'énergie
qui multiproposait la multiplication par
de des éoliennes terrestres par 50 des
éoliennes à mer et par quatre des
panneaux solaires.
Et alors ? Et ben et alors ? Depuis
lors, le gouvernement n'a pas promulgué
par dégré la programmation pluréannuelle
de l'énergie. Elle devait faire en avril
et suite à notre conférence de presse,
le François Baou a décidé de ne pas
publier par décret cette programmation
pluréannuelle mortifère. En août, il a
été question qui passe en cachette en
lousd. le la Marc Feratci qui était à
l'époque ministre de l'énergie devait
passer le 1er août. Il y avait même le
communiqué de presse qui était sorti. On
a dévoilé de possibles conflits
d'intérêt dans la situation et le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité promulguer
la PPE3 en plein en plein en plein mois
d'août. Puis en septembre quand François
Baou euh a a annoncé son départ, les
exploitants éoliens et les lobistes de
l'éolien et des panneaux solaires ont
encore insisté pour que François Bairou
promugue la PPE3 avant son départ. Nous
avons réussi à empêcher par nos nos
réseaux auprès du gouvernement. Et
enfin, en décembre, Roland l'Escure qui
est ministre de l'économie et ministre
de l'énergie avait annoncé qu'ils
allaient promulguer la programmation
pluriéannuelle de l'énergie
au moment des fêtes de Noël et on a
réussi à nouveau à faire reporter la
PPE3 qui selon trou de vraissemblance
sortirait en janvier. Mais dernier
point, le syndicat euh CFE Energie vient
de lancer une alerte très importante
dans le magazine Transition et énergie
où il explique que il y a un gros
problème avec
qui lu par 230 personnes, c'est ça ?
Comment
qui par 230 personnes.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est ça. Par nos abonnés
et nos et nos lecteurs. Voilà. Et euh le
CFE Energie vient d'annoncer C'est ça,
c'est très sérieux. Ça c'est très
sérieux
parce que tout le reste ne l'était pas.
Si non, c'est ce que vous évoquez sur le
magazine, c'est pas sérieux mais ça
c'est sérieux ce que je vais vous dire
parce que ça a une influence sur notre
pays. C'est que le problème c'est que
nos réacteurs nucléaires, on doit les
moduler et ça c'est fondamental parce
que pour intégrer en priorité de réseau
l'électricité d'origine éolienne et
panneaux solaires, nos ingénieurs
nucléaires doivent ralentir les
réacteurs nucléaires, voir les arrêter,
ce qui suppose une autodestruction.
André Palu qui est secrétaire général de
de du syndicat CFE énergie qui est le
premier syndicat de DF alerte sur
l'autodestruction de notre système
énergétique si on continue dans cette
voie. Je le dis parce que c'est une
alerte grave qui est en train de se
passer. Monsieur l'Escure, monsieur le
cornu, vous ne pouvez pas promulguer une
programmation purée annuelle de
l'énergie qui prévoit plus d'énergie
intermittente au risque de détruire
notre système électrique. Donc il faut
arrêter la la l'affaire. Euh il faut
rebondir sur à la fois le sénateur et
Vincent et Fabien en tant
qu'entrepreneur, en tant que spécialiste
de l'énergie, en tant que spécialiste,
je dirais des transports.
Tout cette chies
conséquen
nos patrons, nos industries
et nos boîtes et le rayonnement de la
France ?
Je vais comme il y a déjà un expert en
énergie, je vais rester entrepreneur.
Quand on est entrepreneur, on est assez
pragmatique. Il y a quatre facteurs de
compétitivité.
Euh
quand vous êtes entrepreneur, vous avez
euh dans un pays euh les impôts et les
charges. Bon, en France, c'est plutôt
quelque chose qui va à la hausse. Vous
avez le coût du travail.
Bon, on fait partie en Europe
malheureusement
quand on se compare à nos petits
copains. Alors, il il y a pas besoin
d'aller en Chine he suffit d'aller en
Europe de l'Est. On est un rapport de 1
à 10 46 € de l'heure dans l'industrie.
Vous avez ensuite la monnaie. Bon, la
monnaie, ben on a perdu la dévaluation
depuis 1985, donc on a plus cet outil
là. Et puis le seul truc qui nous
restait, c'était le coût de l'énergie,
l'héritage du plan Mesmer. Au début
d'année 2000, on avait cristait deux
fois moins cher que tous les autres pays
européens. Donc on avait des syndicats
qui étaient un peu compliqués à gérer.
On avait un coût du travail un peu plus
élevé, on avait un impôt sur les
sociétés qui était plus important mais
on avait une électricité pour marcher.
Le problème c'est qu'on l'a plus. Et
donc là ben il va falloir s'atteler à
retrouver moi je le dis souvent, on nous
parle de neutralité carbone en 2050. Bon
ben la bonne nouvelle c'est que
neutralité carbone c'est déjà en 2025
pour notre électricité puisqu'elle est
déjà décarbonée. Donc maintenant on peut
penser à penser à autre chose. Et
l'autre chose c'est quoi ? Ben c'est de
se retrouver ce coût l'électricité. Euh
alors c'est intéressant parce que nos
réacteurs nucléaires, il se trouvent que
c'est pas nous qui les avons conçu.
Alors ce de demain la 4e génération on
les achètera peut-être au Chinois ou au
Russes. Il se trouve que ceux qu'on a
aujourd'hui on les a acheté aux
Américains avec la licence Westing
House. Combien ça coûte de produire de
l'électricité aux États-Unis avec ces
réacteurs ? Les mêmes que les nôtres. Ça
coûte 30 dollars. Combien est-ce que ça
coûte en France ? 60 €. Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ?
30 dollars 60 €. Pourquoi est-ce que nos
réacteurs coûtent deux fois plus cher
pour faire de l'électricité ? Nos
réacteurs jusqu'à combien ? Combien de
temps ils peuvent fonctionner ? Alors,
on a fait jusqu'à 40 ans et puis là, on
fait des grands carréages pour grand
carrénage pour prolonger 50 60. Combien
aux États-Unis ? 80
80 voire 100 pour certains réacteurs.
Donc il y a que un seul objectif et
c'est là où on vair besoin de de
signateur Vincent Lourd, c'est que on a
besoin ces réacteurs de retrouver un
coût à 30 € du MWh.
Si on le fait pas,
on a mais si on veut pas c'est c'est
term enfin de toute façon vous savez
malheureusement l'industrie c'est 10 %
du c'est moins de 10 % du PIB. On est au
niveau de la Grèce donc on peut finir en
parc d'attraction géant ça va être
sympa. Il nous reste du bon pinard, du
du fromage, la nourriture, mais ça va
pas suffire. Euh ça va pas suffire. Et
comme comment est-ce que font nos euh
quand on doit faire un budget euh qui
qui paye en plus ? C'est les seules
entreprises qui restent. Moi quand
j'étais euh euh 100 % médine France, les
aides elles sont pour qui ? Elles sont
pour ceux qui veulent venir en France.
Mais quand vous y êtes, il y a rien pour
vous. Il y a rien. Vous vous
débrouillez. Euh nous on s'est pris des
augmentations de coûts de de nos
ateliers de plus de 25 % avec le Covid.
Il y a personne euh il y a personne pour
nous aider. Enfin, les les coûts ont été
multiplie par deux. Euh c'est le le le
patron de Michelin qui l'a très bien
expliqué. Enfin, je veux dire, personne
n'est là pour vous aider. C'est c'est
vraiment un métier compliqué et on est
tout seul. Moi, j'en ai parlé beaucoup
avec mon ami euh Loï Lefloc à qui je
rends
paix à son âme
paix à son âme un un grand hommage,
c'est que c'est que c'est et et tous ces
et tous ces ces ces dirigeants,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Bah, ils ont pas
le choix. Ça leur brise le cœur, mais
ils sont obligés d'aller prendre un
atelier
ailleurs
au Maghreb, en Asie du Sud-Est ou je
sais pas où. Parce que sinon c'est la
mort assurée.
Nicolas, si tu avais une question à
poser à un sénateur, ça tombait en a un
sous la main et en plus c'est pas un
demi-sénateur.
Tu lui poserais quoi comme question ?
Bah moi, j'ai reçu une j'ai reçu une
trançonneuse à Noël, je sais pas m'en
servir. Donc comment est-ce qu'on fait
Vincent pour sur le nucléaire
typiquement pour comment est-ce qu'on
revient en arrière sur les normes ?
Comment est-ce qu'on enlève un facteur
10 dans la sûreté ?
on arrête la surtransposition française
qui fait que finalement si on ne faisait
que respecter les normes européennes ça
se passerait très bien mais qu'en plus
depuis 20 ans on fait du zel on
surtranspose. Comment est-ce qu'on
revient en arrière sachant si j'ai bien
compris qu'on a inscrit dans notre
constitution le principe de non retour
en arrière écologique ou je sais pas
quoi.
Non mais c'est toute la difficulté. On a
créé une série de normes, une série euh
d'abord on dit que les sénateurs et les
députés sont bavards dans la loi. On est
bavard dans la loi pourquoi ? Parce que
pour éviter que l'administration par les
décrets et les règlements, on écrive
trop de choses. Donc on en écrit plus
pour leur restreindre leur leur capacité
de d'analyse de l'esprit de la loi. En
fait, on en est là.
La grande difficulté, c'est que tu
penses à la à la non régression
environnementale. C'est la charte de
l'environnement qui est encore une en
fois une bonne idée sur le fait qu'on
veut protéger notre environnement. Le
problème, c'est qu'aujourd'hui euh les
certaines associations
environnementalistes attaquent les
parlementaires au Conseil
constitutionnel sur de la régression
environnementale. C'est-à-dire, ils
utilisent la charte en disant tout ce
que vous faites, c'est de la régression
environnementale et donc ça ça provoque
des projets de loi qui sont pas
constitutionnels et des et des articles
qui sont censurés. Non, la grande
difficulté dans ce pays, c'est que on a
une boîte de vitesse où il y a que des
marches avant. On jamais une marche
arrière, on sait pas faire.
Est-ce qu'il y a une direction ?
Alors euh, j'ai dit une boîte de
vitesse. Euh la direction, elle est à
l'avant de la voiture. Euh on a une
direction avec des roues folles et euh
on a une direction, je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure, euh avec des
gouvernements qui cherchent plus à durer
et à sauver le cul pendant qu'ils sont
là et à ne pas avoir de stratégie. Là où
de Gaul était bon, c'est quand il fait
la constitution, article 34 et 39 de la
Constitution. En fait, c'est le
périmètre de ce qu'on le droit de pour
les parlementaires de de statuer. Et le
gouvernement, l'énergie, il l'a pas mis
par les pour les parlementaires. De
Gaulle n'a jamais euh voulu donner au
parlementaires le choix de la politique
énergétique française. Il l'a gardé sous
sa présidence et bien sûr sous celle du
Premier ministre. Et c'est pour ça que
la PPE passe en décret et les
parlementaires ont fait moin on nous
occupe pas de on nous consulte pas donc
ouain il faut il faut qu'on fasse une
loi de programmation. Bon et on a
institué dans la loi je me souviens plus
il y a il y a 7 ou 8 ans l'obligation de
faire une loi de programmation
sur l'énergie qui a jamais été faite qui
a jamais été faite et
les parlementaires essaient de récupérer
la main. Mais j'ai envie de vous dire
quand on parle d'énergie, il faut une
stratégie à 60 ans. Pourquoi 60 ans
minimum ? C'est une centrale, c'est 60
ans vous êtes sur minimum. Oui. Alors
sur d'autant plus aujourd'hui, mais
c'est 60 ans. Même une éolienne, c'est
60 ans. Donc c'est on est Non, mais on
va pas chipoter.
20 ans.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que
les investissements et les CAPEC sont
tellement importants en fait qu'il faut
avoir une stratégie. Vous pouvez pas
faire du start and go en permanence avec
un coup un gouvernement qui change. Par
exemple les les socialistes avec les
écologistes qui arrivent et qui disent
stop et un autre qui dit go, ça marche
pas comme ça. C'est l'industrie lourde,
ça nécessite des investissements et ça
nécessite une vision. On avait le
nucléaire, la vision de Gaul l'a eu. OK,
on coche la case, on a notre industrie
nucléaire qui a arrêté de de construire.
Parce que je rappelle quand même que
l'histoire du nucléaire, c'est les mecs
faisaient des ont fait des barrages
après la guerre et comme ils étaient
très bons à construire des barrages, ils
sont mis à construire du nucléaire. On a
pris la la technologie américaine parce
que c'était la meilleure technologie du
moment en fait. Nous, on était sur une
autre technologie qui était qui avait
beaucoup moins d'avenir. Donc de Gaul,
je pense qu'il était pas content de
prendre la la techno américaine, mais il
l'a pris parce que le comité péon qui
s'appelait à l'époque le comité péon,
c'était que des experts, des industriels
et des vrais euh des vrais des vrais
experts. En fait, c'était pas des
experts politiques à deux balles ou des
mecs de Bercy ou des mecs de la DGE,
c'était des vrais poids lourds de de
l'industrie. C'était Bernard Zambert ?
Non,
vous devriez, c'est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire. Bon et ben je
regarderai. Et donc de Gaul a écouté les
experts. Lui il préférait faire une
solution franco-française mais il a pris
Westing House. Donc on a fait perdurer
tout ça et à la fin il y a la progliol
l'a très bien dit il y a les huiles
Berlus qui arrivent qui font des deals
par contre parfaitement. Enfin, ça c'est
les deals
les deals avec ses Golenes Royales,
Hollande, Voinet, Hullo. Bien sûr qu'on
a les deals, bien sûr qu'on a les deals.
Du mandat de Hollande, il fait un deal,
il veut fermer 15 centrales nucléaires
et après il se reprend, il dit "Quelle
est la plus vieille Festenheim ?" Et
malgré le fait qu'on a investi presque
un milliard d'euros dans Festenheim et
ben on ferme Festenim. Proglio le dit
parfaitement. Il nous l'a dit 10 fois.
Donc euh et tout ça c'est tombé euh euh
enfin je veux dire, on aurait pu décider
ça ce soir entre trois copains euh à
ramener des bières et euh on va fermer
euh 10 centrales nucléaires quoi. C'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé.
Donc
une fois qu'on a qu'on a des qu'on a
qu'on a dit ça, tout le système s'est
contracté. EDF s'est dit "Ah bah on
construira jamais plus de central." Donc
les ingénieurs qui sont fait qui sont
là, les jeunes qui pensent à à
construire, en fait, on leur dit euh "Oh
on a plus besoin d'ingénieur, on a juste
besoin de savoir d'un mec qui s'est
découpé de la ferraille pour démanteler
le bazar." C'est pas du tout la même la
même conception des choses. Donc pendant
10 15 ans en fait, on s'est dit "Comment
on va démonteler, tout va bien se
passer." On nous a écrit le narratif en
fait des ENR qui vont qui vont produire
de l'énergie décarbonée alors que le
nucléaire était déjà décarboné. Monsieur
le sénateur Vincent, quand tu vois ça,
quand tu vois que il y a pas de
molpinière, il y a pas de vision, il y a
pas de cap, il y a une pseudoécoute, ça
essaie de repasser en force tous les 36,
tu sens le pays comment toi qui est
agriculteur, qui connaît le cul des
vaches, qui s'est bagner une fourche
pour aller curer une étable en boxe, tu
sens le pays comment ? Le problème c'est
c'est la médiocrité du cheptel
politique. Euh parce que tu parles de
vaches donc voilà, j'ai utilisé des
termes un peu agricoles. Le cheptel
politique est pas à la hauteur. Donc euh
pourquoi il est pas à la hauteur ? parce
que on lui a euh on est dans une dans
une immédiateté où on fait des
séquences, où on fait des coûts des
coûts médiatiques, des choses qui sont
éphémères parce que euh tout ce qu'on
est en train de faire va être oublié au
bout de 15 jours, 3 semaines, 1 mois et
et les gars, ils font de la poloche
quoi. Donc la vraie stratégie, ça
emmerde tout le monde.
C'est quoi la poloche ? C'est de
l'événementiel politique.
Oui, voilà. C'est des c'est des
séquences. C'est on fait des séquences
quoi.
Ça fait combien de temps que tu es
sénateur ?
Moi, ça fait depuis 23. Depuis 23, ça
fait 2 ans. 2 ans. Ouais. 2 ans et demi
et je me plais.
Tu as peur de te faire poursuivre un
coup de fourche ou toi ça va parce que
tu es connecté avec le terrain ? Moi les
paysans même les plus chaud euh il y a
aucun problème. Moi je et pourtant ils
connaissent mes ils connaissent mes
convictions par rapport au à certains
traités où j'ai soutenu le CTA, j'ai
soutenu et oui j'ai soutenu le CTA, j'ai
sorti une partie du Mercosur et je
soutiens le Mercosur mais il est
inacceptable aujourd'hui avec des
paysans qui sont en train de crever.
C'est pas que j'ai peur de la
concurrence de 1,4 % de de vaches de de
viande bovine en plus, c'est que nos
exploitations sont en train de mourir.
Donc moi, je me déplace partout
tranquille. En fait, je leur parle comme
je vous parle ce soir. Je parle avec mes
collègues euh comme je parle à à tout le
monde. Tout le monde rigole un peu parce
que Vincent, il a du franc parler et
puis il fait marrer tout le monde parce
queil dit tout haut ce que tout le monde
pense tout bas. Euh d'accord,
mais moi j'ai envie de dire quand est-ce
qu'on passe la deuxième ? En fait le la
France
non alors la marche arrière pour ta
tronçonneuse je suis en partie je suis
en partie d'accord c'est que la boîte à
outil on nous a déjà fait le coup donc
de la simplification en fait ça ça
marche pas en fait ce qu'il faut y aller
c'est cheveux par cheveux avec le
scalpel et y aller dur c'est une volonté
politique aujourd'hui force de constater
qu'on a fait un écosystème étatique de
haut fonctionnaires et d'administration
qui sont tellement plétoriques que en
fait comme faut bien qu'elle s'occupe et
ben c'est elle qui gère le pays et que
le politique a un peu c'est un peu trop
vite déchargé. les ministres n'ont pas
la main sur toute leur administration ou
alors quand ils traînent des pieds, bah
tu as pas la machine à baffe parce que
faut pas fâcher les grands directeur
parce que c'est eux qui détiennent le
pouvoir des choses. Donc on est on est
en permanence en fait dans ce dans ce
dans cette difficulté où l'action
politique et moi il y a il y a quelque
chose qui me tue en fait, c'est de voir
que les politiques commencent à devenir
bons quand ils ont tout perdu. Alors là,
ils se mettent à parler
comme Mondbourg.
Voilà. Ou alors quand ils ont plus de 75
ans. Alors là, il se lâche. Borlot, le
louche. Ah bah les mecs, il balancent.
Et j'ai envie de leur dire, vous avez
fait quoi quand vous étiez dans le
système ? C'est ça, c'est ça le
problème, c'est que moi j'en ai un peu
marre de dire, de voir un écosystème
qui est politiquement correct et en fait
rien ne bouge et il y a plein de choses
qui s'améliorent mais il y a plein de
choses qui s'améliorent pas. Qu'est-ce
qui s'améliore ?
Et ben par exemple ce qui s'est amélioré
c'est quand on était descendu à 8 % du
PIB sur l'industrie.
Macron par exemple avait réussi à
relancer en début de mandat une
réindustrialisation et à remettre un peu
de gaz. Oui, on est remonté à 10 10 et
demi du PIB. C'est
parce que le PIB a baissé. Non.
[__] vous êtes dur les mecs.
Non mais que le début hein.
Non mais
moi je quand quand c'est bien quand
c'est bien Nicolas Nicolas vas-y ch 2014
le le prix de du pétrole baisse, le prix
du gaz baisse, le prix baisse, le prix
de l'énergie baisse, l'économie mondiale
repart. Emmanuel Macron, je crois qu'il
est pas pour grandchose mais après je
suis d'accord qu'il a essayé de faire
qualitative. Au moins il en a au moins
il en a parlé. Il a fait quelque chose
par exemple il a baissé il a baissé
l'IS. Donc
typiquement il a fait baisser la post
société de 3325. Donc quand tu es
entrepreneur et tu baises de 33 à 25 si
tu as la chance de gagner de l'argent tu
es content. Mais alors pour ceux qui
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas l'impôt
sur les sociétés à la fin de l'année, si
il vous reste un peu de trésorerie, tu
as gagné 100 € et bien si tu es imposé à
33 %
donc à la fin de l'année, à la fin de
l'année si tu veux ton petit matelas
pour voir l'avenir et protéger ta boîte,
non, il y a l'État qui fait bonjour,
c'est la fin de l'année. Non, c'est pas
les dividendes, c'est l'impôt sur les
sociétés,
c'est sur le bénéfice de sa société
avant distribution. Parce que ça c'est
33 % impôt sur les sociétés. Si tu
demandes une distribution là euh c'est
plus la c'est plus la même chanson. Là
tu montes
50 c'est ça ? C'est 30
30 + 20.
Oui. Bah oui. Et puis tu as les la
traitement social.
Bref. même donc non mais donc le
problème et ça c'est un peu le problème
de la France et de l'Europe c'est qu'on
a voulu cette désolé je vais je pense
que je vais ça va être mon fil rouge on
a voulu cette monnaie unique mais on a
fait aucune harmonisation fiscale donc
on est bloqué et avec la même monnaie
que des paradis fiscaux et entre
guillemets que des paradis sociaux
c'està-dire que avec des gens qui sont
beaucoup moins payés que nous. Donc
quand on donc on est obligé pour
regarder la compétitivité, je l'ai dit
la poeta c'est une des parts de
compétitivité donc on les baisse. Très
bien. Je suis entrepreneur, je le baisse
mais après l'argent qui manque qui paye
ben il passe ailleurs. Il passe sur des
charges, il passe sur des impôts de
production. Donc en fait, si vous voulez
et et notre déficit structurel, le
déficit structurel de l'État, il date du
début des années 90 euh à ce moment-là
parce que on est figé avec le taux euh
le taux du DCHMARCK avec les Allemands,
on n' plus aucune marge de manœuvre, on
a aucune harmonisation fiscale et donc
toutes ces ces baisses qu'on qu'on est
obligé de faire pour être euh pour
rester euh concurrent avec les autres et
bien c'est des charges qu'on rajoute en
plus et les entreprises payent des
charges. Les gens le savent peut-être
pas mais quand vous êtes payé 50, ce que
ça coûte à votre entreprise c'est 100
quand même. Et on est champion du monde
et donc on peut pas payer normalement
les salariés, on peut pas les les
intéresser et c'est c'est compliqué.
Mais Nicolas, je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable. Regarde nos belles autoroutes
avec des trous partout. Regarde nos
services d'urgence, regarde la qualité
de notre système éducatif. Alors pour le
coup les autoroutes, je suis pas
d'accord avec toi puisque je suis allé
aux États-Unis en novembre et je peux te
dire qu'ils mettent pas le même argent
dans le infrastructure.
Mais ils ont ils ont moins de taxe. Bon
bah ils ont moins de taxe et c'est un
choix qu'ils ont fait. Nous on refait
les ronds-points tous les 2 ans. Est-ce
que c'est nécessaire ou pas ? Je pose la
question.
Système éducatif il est pas
extraordinaire. Ah ça c'est un autre
problème. Oui hein.
Non
Fabience
Oui. Moi je je voudrais revenir sur le
rôle des parlementaires et des élus et
de leurs actions politiciennes qui leur
fait être complètement aveugle sur la
réelle politique européenne et en
particulier le rôle de l'Allemagne.
Parce que en matière énergétique on
oublie une chose essentielle, c'est
l'énergivin 2 allemand. l'idéologie de
l'énergivin 2. L'energin 2, ça veut dire
transition énergétique qui a fait que
l'Allemagne, pendant que nos élus
étaient en train de faire de la poloche,
comme tu vous avais dit tout à l'heure,
et bien l'Allemagne préparait une
véritable politique de destruction de
notre système énergétique. Et euh ce qui
est très intéressant, c'est qu'il y a eu
la commission d'enquête sur la
souveraineté énergétique qui a été euh
organisée en 2022 euh à l'initiative de
Antoine Armand. et Philippe
Schellenberger. Euh et euh dans cette
commission d'enquête, rien n'a été dit
sur le rôle de l'Allemagne à l'exception
d'Henry Progliot qui avait dit à un
moment clé "L'Allemagne a tout fait pour
détruire EDF." Trois petits points, ils
ont réussi. Et à ce moment-là, on a eu
les euh le rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête et le président qui ont baissé
la tête et qui n'ont pas abordé la
question essentielle. Parce que pendant
que Dominique Voinet était en train de
faire fermer Super Phenniix qui je le
rappelle est réacteur à neutron rapide
qui est l'avenir pour lequel nous avions
30 ans d'avance pendant que euh monsieur
Coch donnait et attribué des subventions
aux éoliennes en 2001 et bien
progressivement s'est inséré au cœur de
l'État parce que pendant que les
ministres font de la politique et bien
l'administration
devient progressivement infiltré par des
agents qui sont installés au sein des
cabinets ministériels.
Quoi vos sources ?
Ah bah c'est des source de l'école de
guerre économique qui a fait un rapport
sur le sujet de mes livres qui
contiennent des éléments sur les
fondations allemandes qui agissent en
France contre comment dire contre le
nucléaire français. Je pense à à la
fondation Henrich B par exemple.
C'est une interprétation pas une
interprétation. Non non non non non.
Làdus
vous avez des sources internes qui
disent on va euh tuer les Français.
La fondation Enrich B
c'est duing classique. La fondation
Enrich B dans le droit allemand tout
parti politique a une liaison avec une
fondation. La fondation Enrich Ball est
en liaison avec les Grunon. Les Grunon,
c'est Europe écologie les vert en
Allemagne. La fondation Enrich Ball est
en liaison euh politique et puisque par
exemple elle a fait l'introduction du
colloque antinucléaire organisé par
Europe écologie les verts.
Et ben, ils ont le droit.
Ils ont tout à fait le droit. Mais on a
des opérations de guerre
informationnelle, ils financent des
magazines. Ça c'est la guerre
informationnelle.
C'est votre interprétation ?
Non, c'est la guerre informationnelle.
C'est votre interprétation parce que moi
si je vois les Allemands, je me dis
voilà, ils aiment bien les verts
alors
je me fais l'avoquer du diable.
Vous avez alors puisque vous voulez une
source, vous avez l'OFATE, l'Office
franco-allemand de la transition
énergétique. Ce cet organisme a un site
internet, donc la source, elle est sur
internet. L'OFAT est constitué du lobby
éolien d'organisation antinucléaire et
du lobby du gaz. Ils ont le droit.
Ils ont tout à fait le droit. Ce lobby
est de droit allemand et à son siège à
Berlin, donc quand on regarde l'adresse
du siège, c'est au ministère de
l'industrie. Ah bah non, mais soyez pas
impatient. Impatient, je sais qu'ils ont
un email en point goû,
c'est pas un email, ils ont leur bureau
à la direction générale de l'énergie et
du climat au sein du ministère de
l'écologie et ils disposent d'email
ecologie.goof.fr
et donc ils ont leur entrée. Et
qu'est-ce que c'est que la DGEC ? La
direction générale de l'énergie et du
climat, c'est l'état profond de
c'est-à-dire l'organisme et
l'administration chargé de la politique
énergétique du pays sous le ministère de
l'écologie. Ça veut dire Ça veut dire
que l'on a
Pourquoi vous criz ?
Non, je crie pas, je suis enthousiaste
et c'est parce que c'est grave aussi.
Ils mutualisent les coûts d'hébergement
de leur bureau.
Alors donc vous considérez que c'est
tout à fait normal que un lobby allemand
dispose d'un bureau au sein du cœur
nucléaire de la politique énergétique de
notre pays.
Vorb.
Donc j'imagine que vous êtes vous
trouvez ça tout à fait normal. Donc
voilà mes sources. Les sources c'est le
site de l'ateux. Et après vous avez au
sein de RTE réseau de transport de
d'électricité monsieur Pier Chazic qui a
été nommé président, il a été le
conseiller énergie de François Hollande
chargé de la loi de la baisse de la part
du nucléaire à 50 % et chargé de la loi
d'accélération des renouvelables sous
François Brot. Et euh monsieur Pier
Chazic a pris comme collaboratrice la
déléguée générale de France énergie
éolienne, le syndicat des exploitants
éoliens. C'est-à-dire qu'au sein de nos
au sein de nos administrations très
performantes,
mais non, mais vous voulez ma source, il
y a un communiqué de presse de RTE avec
la nomination de madame comment dire
Pauline Lebertre qui était déléguée
général du syndicat des éoliennes et qui
se retrouve dans les entreprises
publiques. Donc on a plusieurs cas comme
ça et de cas important d'infiltration.
Je vais faire une petite synthèse de ce
que dit Fabien.
Les Allemands défendent leurs intérêts
et les Français s'abordent les leurs.
Exactement.
C'est ça la situation. Et donc moi
quelque part je suis pas complètement
d'accord sur pour taper sur les
Allemands parce que par contre je
préfère taper sur les Français.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait pas comme le général de
Gaulle qui a fait la politique de
Hésville pour défendre la pour défendre
le vote à l'unanimité et cetera en 65 ?
Donc le problème pour moi en France
c'est que au lieu d'avoir des gens qui
défendent nos intérêts, alors le mot est
peut-être un peu fort mais on a beaucoup
de collabo finalement.
Non je suis pas d'accord. Alors, on a
beaucoup de sabordeur.
En tout cas, je pense qu'on a un
problème de lucidité. C'est-à-dire que
quand vous n'avez pas la lucidité, le
sénateur, [rires]
quand j'entends Fabien me dire ce qui ce
qu'il me dit
au bénéfice du doute, on va lui dire que
on va on va croire qu'il est sourcé
suffisamment carré cubique pour
entendre. On a demandé à notre
communauté de le faire checker de A à Z.
On laisse le bénéfice du doute à Fabien.
Il y a pas des services de renseignement
censés protéger nos industries, notre
système énergétique et les intérêts de
notre beau pays. Censé voir si Fabien a
raison que il y a des Allemands qui
cherchent à nous faire des croques en
jantes, des crocheppes, nous savonner la
planche pour récupérer une compétitivité
et prendre le lead de l'Europe.
Est-ce que vous vous avez posé des
questions en tant que sénateur déjà ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez poser des
questions à nos services de
renseignement en leur disant "Écoutez
les gars, il faut peut-être vous sortir
un peu les doigts du cul parce qu'il y a
Fabien qui est en train de sonner la
cloche comme quoi on est en train de se
faire enfoncer à coup de bélier."
Comment ça se passe côté Sénat ? On on a
compris.
Si Fabien dit choses vraies, est-ce
qu'on a compris qu'on avait pas d'amis
mais des concurrents et des prédateurs
autour de nous ? Après, j'ai envie de
dire dans le monde économique
d'aujourd'hui, bienvenue dans le monde
réel parce que
la guerre économique date pas d'hier.
Euh Nicolas le dit très bien, les
Allemands défendent leur leur schéma,
c'est leur problème, ils défendent leurs
intérêts.
Nous notre les grands principes
parlementaires
c'est des commissions d'enquête, c'est
des missions d'information, tout ça
c'est filmé, c'est retranscrit où vous
avez certaines omerta qui se fait.
Pourquoi ? Parce que en fait vous en
dites le moins possible parce que vous
êtes pas dans une dans une cage de
phradé. En fait, vous allez pas dire la
vérité parce que ça va déranger
l'établissement et que on est dans un
mode pyramidal où quand le président de
la République décide quelque chose,
l'armée qui est en dessous se met en
ordre de marche pour être c'est on est
dans des régimes très présidentiels.
Quand le président Hollande décide de
fermer Fenheim, euh bah tous les tous
les premiers ministres et même le
président qui va suivre, mais Emmanuel
Macron va fermer Fenim parce que c'est
la règle une fois qu'il y en a un qui a
qui a dit "On est la courroie de
transmission
de de la chose et toujours pour une
grosse une grosse part de médiocrité.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a eu des
arrangements parce qu'on a peur de se
mettre un peu une partie de notre
électorat à dos parce que on se dit bah
oui mais les écolos, les bobos de Paris
écolo
qui adore les ENR normal on voit pas une
éolienne dans Paris donc ça les dérange
pas beaucoup sauf quand ils vont en
vacances au bord de la mer là ils se
disent "Ah oui ça fait dégueulasse."
Mais en fait on est dans un narratif de
bisounours et la politique c'est ça la
difficulté. Quand est-ce qu'on sort du
narrative des bisounours ? Les Allemands
ont fait des choix pour eux de passer
dans beaucoup de NR. Pourquoi ? Parce
que quand tu fais de l'éolien et du
photovoltaïque, tu fermes des centrale à
charbon et des centrales à gaz. C'est
tout bf. Quand nous on fait des ENR à
toutva, on ferme quoi ? Du nucléaire.
C'est quoi qu'on a pas compris là ?
C'est déjà décarboné. Tu vas pas
décarboner. Alors col disais il y a le
plus blanc que blanc. Vous vous souvenez
avait plus blanc que blanc. Quand c'est
décarboné ça peut pas être décarboné une
deuxième fois. Donc là il y a un
copiercollé de schéma allemand. qui a
été repris par certains politiques par
facilité parce que en fait fallait
décarboner l'énergie et il continue
aujourd'hui même il y a encore quelques
jours où on nous dit il faut faire des
ENR pour avoir de l'énergie décarbonée.
Non le seul enjeu que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'est notre consommation électrique
continue à baisser. Pourquoi ? Parce que
on fait en récession.
Non pas du tout parce que
trop cher
Non pas du tout ferme trop d'industrie.
Non pas du tout
non pas du tout. Les industriels font
des modifications de process qui font
que on passe de télémécanique au
numérique qui fait que ça fait des
économies. On est des variateurs, on
fait des amélioration qui qui économise
de l'énergie parce que euh quand ça
monte haut bah vaut mieux l'économiser.
Donc euh en partie, on a la
désindustrialisation qui est là, c'est
un fait. Les usines qui ferment
consomment plus d'énergie. Donc vous
avez tous mis des ampoules à LED dans
votre maison. Donc euh ça consomme
moins, on consomme tous moins. Donc la
consommation d'énergie baisse malgré le
fait qu'on on achète quelques voitures
électriques, malgré le fait qu'on ait
mis plein pla de pack clim euh chez les
gens pour qu'ils se chauffent et qu'il
se fassent de la clim euh l'été, on
narrive pas à consommer plus d'énergie
électrique. Donc quand on se on se met à
produire
à ce tarif là, c'est sûr que ça va être
difficile.
Non non enfin euh Ah bah c'est évident
que quand vous mettez
copal
Oui oui oui. Durale Alex. Oui. Bah bien
ils sont chez moi. Duralex. Duralex.
Duralex. Quand le prix du gaz il paye
300 € de gaz par mois, il passe à 350000
€. Ça fait tilt. C'est simple, un
industriel il peut pas gérer ça. Même
moi quand je sèche du maïs, quand ça me
coûte 10 € la tonne et que ça se met ça
me met à me coûter 35 € la tonne, je la
sens bien passé la douloureuse. Donc
vous savez, un industriel, il est il est
connecté à la réalité de la hausse de
l'énergie. Au passage, ça nous a coûté
un billet de 50 milliards de protection
des prix dans le budget de l'État. On
oublie un peu trop parce que oui, ça
coûte cher aujourd'hui mais on a payé
euh 40 50 milliards. On
n pas payé, on s'est endetté.
Ouais. Enfin, n'empêche que on s'est
endetté, ça vous avez tout à fait raison
de me prendre parce que en France mais
n'empêche que n'empêche que on a quand
même payé et que toutes les entreprises
ont touché des actes de protection
d'électricité qui avait flambé à cause
du gaz et notamment sur le gaz pour
réussir à à garder nos entreprises à peu
près en état. Aujourd'hui, la seule
difficulté que l'on a sur l'énergie,
c'est euh avoir deux outils de
production pour faire la même chose.
Donc aujourd'hui, si on continue de
mettre la gomme sur les ENR comme c'est
voulu dans la PPE3, on va dans le mur,
on a les couparties. Scadag a été signé
par les gouvernements successifs, signé
par la Creux en cours de raccordement,
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
en cours de raccordement en cours enfin
tout est prêt administrativement, il
manque des fois le permis de construire,
on en a à peu près 30 GW de puissance
prêt à être installé qui vont
30 réacteurs nucléaires.
C'est c'est la moitié de notre parc
nucléaire. Ça produit pas autant parce
que c'est intermittent. Mais n'empêche
que vous imaginez surtout sur le
photovoltaïque, vous n'arrivez plus à
gérer l'électri du diable.
Ouais, allez-y.
Moi, je me dis par exemple, il y a un
goulot d'étranglement sur l'uranium.
Tout le monde veut se raccorder.
Vous me dites les gars si on vous
dérange, tout le monde tout le monde
veut de l'uranium, tout le monde veut
des centrales nucléaires. C'est bien de
diversifier nos sources.
Ouais. Sauf que l'uranium, quand tu
parles avec Orano et moi j'ai auditionné
Orano aujourd'hui on a des tensions
géopolitiques pour certains pays. On a
perdu le Niger, on a d'autres pays qui
posent problèmes. Aujourd'hui, il y a
pas de tension sur l'uranium. Il y en a
contrairement à ce qu'on dit Orano nous
disent après peut-être que Orano c'est
les menteurs mais n'empêche qu'il nous
disent que on n pas
euh je me trompe peut-être
c'est pas le terrain qu'ils ont acheté
en Afrique qui était super riche mais en
fait en en densité d'uranium mais en
fait non.
Oui. Alors après
ça c'est encore autre chose.
C'est c'est encore autre chose. Mais ce
que je ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'uranium
on parle des mêmes là. Oui oui oui oui.
L'uranium est quelque chose qui est
stratégique
peut-être. Je parle sous votre contrôle.
Non non non vous vous trompez pas. Mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que euh
stratégiquement l'uranium n'est pas en
pénurie dans le monde. Euh non non non.
Il y a des difficultés. Attends attends.
On va rigoler. On a combien de stocks
stratégiques pour vous proposer une
colle ?
Ah non
30 ans.
D'accord. Elle sort d'où ta source ?
Mais c'est c'est Dorano. Non non non
non non non. Je l'ai cité dans mes
livres sur le nucléaire qui n'ont jamais
été remis en cause.
Combien il coût les livres ?
Comment
combien il coûtent les livres ?
17 €
18 €.
Donc sur l'approvisionnement d'uranium,
tu es sûr de ton coût ?
Oui.
Tu es sûr à 100 %.
Ah bah moi Orano, c'est ce qu'il nous
disent en audition. Et d'abord, vous
savez, c'est compliqué parce que
on a le nucléaire existant qui marche
sur un process existant et après on a
aussi la potentialité de boucler le
cycle, c'est-à-dire reprendre le vieux
combustible pour le réutiliser. Chose
qui est faite et actée aujourd'hui à 25
%. On fait du mox en fait, on reprend du
vieux combustible qu'on inclut dans le
nouveau combustible
et du plutonium.
Voilà, à hauteur de 25 %. Ça on sait
faire aujourd'hui, on sait faire
parfaitement. On pourrait peut-être
monter demain mais technologiquement
mais ça déjà on sait faire. Après le
bouclage du cycle c'est Astrid en fait
c'est le fait qu'on reprenne les déchets
et là on a un stock assez pour pour
durer plusieurs dizaines d'années.
L'opérabilité de tout ça à strid on le
déploie en combien de temps en France ?
Non mais justement un des problèmes pour
nous les politiques de prendre une
décision c'est aussi la difficulté
d'avoir de l'uranium. S'il y a une
tension sur l'uranium, il faut boucler
le cycle beaucoup plus vite. Vous me
suivez ?
Combien de temps il faut ?
Ah pour bouc pour Ah bah là on parle de
40 50 60 ans pour boucler. Oui, mais si
vous arrêtez
le temps de nos boîtes, elles auront le
temps de manger les par la racine.
Non, non, parce que non, parce que notre
géostratégie sur l'uranium aujourd'hui
n'est pas en difficulté d'après ce que
nous dit Orano. Après, Orano peuvent
nous mentir et dire
la série de prospective de du Sénat, ils
ont fait des auditions là-dessus ou
Alors, moi j'ai fait des auditions parce
que je suis dans un comité qui s'appelle
le comité France 2030 de l'innovation.
J'ai fait des J'ai auditionné Orano et
j'ai posé les questions à Orenau. Ils
m'ont répondu euh ils m'ont répondu
aujourd'hui.
Mais est-ce que vous avez auditionné
quelqu'un d'autre ?
Ah, on a auditionné euh les anciens PDG
de DF, tous les anciens PDG de DF parce
que euh eux, ils ont une une autre
version Corano et ils connaissent aussi,
ils ont besoin d'avoir des certitudes au
lieu d'avoir le haut commissariat
énergie atomique, il a dit quoi ?
Pareil, on n'est pas forcément en
tension.Il
Il y a une forme d'unanimité. Encore une
fois, ma parole politique aujourd'hui se
base sur un consensus d'experts. En
fait, moi je veux rien. Non mais moi je
veux rien. Je suis agriculteur. Moi les
gars, on se détend ou
il faut pas tomber dans le misérabisme
de la puissance. un agriculteur est
beaucoup plus connecté à la réalité que
Oui oui
oui oui oui oui oui. N'empêche que je
suis à un moment obligé d'écouter des
gens qui ont une expertise reconnue, des
universitaires qui ont une expertise
reconnue et à la fin je fais mon intime
conviction et mon expertise permettre de
faire un parallèle.
Ouais.
la veille de la crise financière de
2008. H
moi j'ai j'ai la meilleure experte du
monde qui s'appelle Christine Lagarde
qui m'a dit que tout allait bien. J'ai
un autre expert aux États-Unis, comment
il s'appelle ? Euh Paul Polo là, comment
il s'appelle ? Ça va dire comment ?
Ouais, peut-être. Non, un autre
qui me disait tout va bien, tout va
bien. J'ai les agences de notation
unanimement reconnu de tout le monde qui
disait que tout va bien. Triple A, no
stress prer.
Moi, j'attends d'un sénateur
qui soit un peu plus critique. Ouai.
Enfin ou enfin moi je fais euh moi je je
veux bien une critique mais après euh
parce que je suis pas quand même pas le
dernier à taper dans le tas à challenger
mes mes auditions à rentrer dans le lart
des mecs ou
tu es en train de prendre pour tous tes
collègues c'est pas de ta faute. Je suis
désolé.
Non non non non mais moi je comprends
parce que c'est des questions que tout
le monde se pose. Donc je suis là pour
répondre à tous ceux qui vont nous
regarder qui nous regardent et qui vont
nous regarder dans le futur. Moi je
challenge en fait je rentre dans le tas
je j'essaie d'avoir du off. C'est pour
ça que je préfère les auditions en mode
phé où les mecs quand tu as le numéro 2
de total, il va pas te dire la même
chose que quand il y a trois caméras qui
filment avec la retranscription au mot
près. Je suis désolé, la vraie
prospective se fait en chambre avec des
expertises, avec des gens que je
rencontre matin, midi et soir dans des
dans des restaurants en petit comité à
dans des cercles d'échange qui
deviennent où où ils deviennent des gens
avec qui j'ai des attaches en fait parce
que ils se lâchent pas comme ça sur un
petit sénateur comme moi ou sur un
sénateur comme moi les mecs. Il y a
besoin d'avoir quelque chose qui est qui
est qui est qui est ancré. Et tous les
experts que je rencontre, les vrais
hein, ceux qui qui qui sont pas des des
idéologues à deux balles, soit
pronucléaire ou soit pro, parce que il y
en a de tous les côtés, euh ils ont tous
en commun une chose, c'est qu'ils
veulent que la France réussisse et que
les mecs à un moment ils deviennent
nerveux parce queen fait personne veut
les écouter et qu'à un moment le le
sénateur que je suis, je peux être que
leur porte-parole et aujourd'hui je suis
le porte-parole
des experts qui me disent des choses et
dont je fais la synthèse sûrement pas
parfaite parce que oui, je pourrais
remettre en en caisse la la parole de
d'oro. D'abord, j'oublierai pas parce
que je vais charger changer un peu un
peu plus la prochaine fois où je vais
aller visiter l'agner des billes.
Ouais. Oui. Non mais c'est c'est le jeu.
Moi ma ma connaissance et là où j'ai un
peu de valeur, c'est quand je connais
des trucs que les mecs ils se disent "Ah
mais merde, l'autre il est déjà au
courant. Donc euh on comptait le
l'embourber avec trois éléments de
langage parce queon te fait ça hein. On
te met des beaux éléments de langage, on
te sort le PowerPoint qui est nickel et
tu repars, tu dis "Ah ouais, ils sont
vachement bien." Mais EDF est déjà
capable de faire ça. Ils nous ont déjà
embourbé sur toute une série de choses.
Donc il y a
parce que nous on a beaucoup de respect
pourf
mais moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pourf
seulement. Je l'ai demandé à Fontana
quand il est passé en audition pour être
confirmé par le Sénat. Est-ce que vous
êtes encore capable de construire
quelque chose, une centrale nucléaire ?
Parce que à un moment, on va tourner
autour du pot Flamville. Moi
politiquement à chaque fois qu'il y a
des qu'on repousse, que ça coûte 2
milliards de plus,
tu passes pour un con.
Bah un petit peu mon de veut. Donc à un
moment, moi j'ai envie de dire à EDF eh
oh Loulou euh moi j'adore les poules
mais quand un moment euh vous toute
votre armée mexicaine chez EDF parce que
c'est les services de l'État EDF hein,
c'était état avant donc euh là-dedans il
faut qu'ils arrêtent comme diraient mes
copains euh et mes cousins canadiens, de
se décroter le nez et on se met au
boulot. et EDF, on a besoin d'avoir EDF
qui est opérationnel, qui construit, qui
fait des ruptures technologiques, qui se
bouge le pistil encore une fois. Et
Fontana, je lui ai dit, je lui ai dit et
je lui ai redit à chaque fois que je le
vois, moi j'ai besoin d'avoir des bonnes
nouvelles, des bonnes nouvelles pour
prouver qu'on est capable de
réindustrialiser la le secteur
nucléaire, capable de construire quelque
chose. J'ai
peur de te donner les mauvaises
nouvelles.
Alors, l'habitude chez EDF, c'est cacher
les mauvaises nouvelles. C'est mais
c'est tout toute l'administration est
comme ça. C'est-à-dire que quand tu es
dans une administration, directeur
d'administration, quel qu'elle soit, si
tu es le porteur du de la mauvaise
nouvelle, tu deviens le problème. Donc
le problème c'est se dire le temps que
je suis là, il faut pas qu'il y a une
mauvaise nouvelle comme ça la patate
chaude elle sera pour le coup le copain
après. Ou alors on la met sous le siège
avant de se barrer. Comme ça l'autre qui
arrivera derrière il fera exploser la
tronche.
C'est un peu comme dans le ministère des
affaires étrangères ça non ?
Ouais. Moi, je connais bien le ministère
de l'agriculture quand quand il
s'appelait ? Bruno Lemer est parti du
ministère de l'agriculture et c'est
Stéphane Lefol qui est arrivé après. Il
avait laissé une pastille un pétard sous
le siège qui a coûté 1 milliard 5
d'amendees européenne pour la politique
agricole commune. Donc je peux vous dire
que les petits malins comme ça qui
laissent des gros pétards sous le siège
parce qu'ils veulent pas traiter
l'affaire ou ils sont sûrs de leur
certitude parce que on va expliquer à la
Commission européenne que le français a
raison alors que la Commission
européenne a dit depuis le début que
c'est comme ça qu' fallait répondre au
aux injonctions de l'Europe et qu'on a
dit non non mais nous on est français,
on va vous expliquer comment ça va se
passer parce qu'on était membre
fondateur de l'Europe. Bah à la fin
c'est 1 milliard 5 d'amende et c'est
bing tu la prends comme il faut. Donc le
fol, il a pris sa cartouche, il a dû
même demander un paiement en deux fois.
C'est quand même la honte parce qu'on
arrivait parce que l'Europe retient
l'argent sur la politique agricole
commune avant de faire ton chèque de 7
milliards au mois d'octobre, novembre,
décembre et ben tout de suite ils
retiennent le milliard. Donc euh merci à
dit fin de la plaisanterie.
Nicolas, tu voulais rebondir ?
Ouais, moi je voulais rebondir sur sur
trois choses rapidement. L'uranium déjà
donc nous, moi je fais partie de
l'association pour l'étude du pic
pétrolier. On regarde pas que le
pétrole, on regarde aussi le gaz, on
regarde aussi l'uranium. Le consensus
euh c'est que on peut effectivement au
rythme de développement des centrales
nucléaires partout dans le monde,
partout dans le monde à part
effectivement euh en Allemagne et en
France euh on peut avoir un risque
d'approvisionnement dans la seconde
partie du 21e siècle. Donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut l'anticiper et ce serait bien
qu'en 2050 on commence à avoir des
centrales, des surgénérateurs
effectivement qui nous permettent
d'avoir des je crois que c'est presque
1000 ans de réserves qu'on aurait chez
nous vraisemblablement vu notre pays de
saboteur comme je le disais tout à
l'heure que ce soit Dominique faut pas
oublier Corine le page parce que c'est
elle la première qui s'apporde
Super Phenix bah on l'achètera au russe.
J'espère que d'ici là on sera
après pour développer pour boucler le
cycle.
Ouais, c'est un peu plus long que 2050.
Oui. Oui. Non mais il faut commencer à y
aller. C'est sûr que là vu qu'on avait
coupé à 2019, il faut remettre de
l'argent. Il faut arrêter de faire la
startup nation du nucléaire et cetera
pour éparpiller les il faut un peu se
focaliser. Deuxième chose sur lequel je
voulais rebondir, on parlait d'Edf.
Alors EDF effectivement alors il y a
quand même un problème parce que je
reviens à mon histoire de tronçonneuse
qui est importante pour moi, c'est qu'en
fait EDF comme on a une opposition à peu
près stérile depuis le début des années
2000, on a assz des réacteurs
stérile ou impuissante ?
Non, stérile parce que ça aboutit à
rien. On a perdu notre temps entre les
pronuclires et les et les
prenouvelables. Et bien euh grosso modo
les les prenouvelables qui voulaient
tuer le nucléaire ont mis beaucoup de
contraintes sur le nucléaire, se sont
battu pour augmenter les niveaux de
sécurité. Et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Vous avez notamment l'autorisation de
sûreté nucléaire, la SN qui allait voir
les gens de DF et qui disent "Bon ODF,
est-ce que vous vous pourriez faire ça
par exemple ?" et EDF a toujours
systématiquement répondu oui oui, oui,
oui, oui. Donc en fait les normes en
plus en fait, c'est EDF qui se les cré
parce qu'il a jamais il a eu tellement
peur de l'opinion publique, tellement
peur des autres qu'en fait on s'est
empilé nos normes euh quit à couler sur
le truc. Et donc maintenant que EDF que
le vent a tourné qu'Emmanuel Macron
finalement est plus contre le nucléaire
mais pour le nucléaire maintenant qu'il
a fait ça et ben on se retrouve avec des
réacteurs qui sont inconstructibles
parce que on a accepté toutes les
normes. Et le tre point, c'est que je
voulais expliquer pourquoi ça posait un
problème cette PPE3. euh euh parce que
le haut commissaire l'énergie atomique
Vincent Berger l'a très bien dit et
c'est pour ça que euh la PPE3 a pas été
publiée en août parce qu'en fait la
modulation du nucléaire en France entre
guillemets, c'est pas un problème.
C'est-à-dire que
ça de d'affaiblir les réacteurs. Non,
attendez, attendez,
attendez 2 secondes, laissez-moi finir.
Euh c'est-à-dire que nos réacteurs sont
conçus parce que on a une part
importante de nucléaire, on est les
seuls qui avont autant de nucléaire dans
l'électricité, 70 %, ils sont conçus
pour faire du suivi de charge.
C'est-à-dire queon peut euh passer de la
puissance nucléaire de 100 à 20 % assez
rapidement et passer de 20 à 100 % assez
rapidement et ça pose pas trop de
problème. Le réel problème, c'est quand
on les arrête, quand on arrête un
réacteur là parce qu'on a des procédures
bien évidemment pour les redémarrer et
que là ça va avoir un impact sur les
pièces, sur la maintenance. et sur la
durée de vie. C'est ça qu'il a dit. Il a
dit le le le haut commissaire atomique,
c'est-à-dire que on peut baisser la
puissance du parc, on peut la moduler
jusqu'à 20 GW. Grosso modèle 20 19 GW.
Par contre, si on continue à rajouter
non seulement nous panneaux solaires
mais c'est pas que nous, c'est aussi les
Allemands, c'est aussi les espagnols
parce que on récupère quand il est mic
qui savent pas quoi en faire, ça vient
un chez nous leur leur électricité. Et
bien là, si on doit passer sous les 19
GW, là on a un problème parce qu'il faut
arrêter le réacteur et dans ce cas-là,
on n'est pas capable de le rallumer pour
avoir l'électricité le soir. Donc le
vrai problème de la modulation, c'est
quand on doit arrêter les réacteurs.
Pourquoi il y a modulation ? Oui, je
voudrais expliquer pourquoi il y a
modulation. Pour une raison extrêmement
simple. Dans le marché européen de
l'électricité, c'est le marché du mérite
order, l'ordre du mérite. Le souci,
c'est qu'on prend le coût marginal de
l'unité de production et pour une raison
artificielle, on va prendre un coût
marginal inférieur au l'éolien et
panneaux solaires inférieur au coût du
nucléaire sans prendre en considération
les subventions qu'on paye aux éoliennes
et panneaux solaires. Et donc ça crée de
facto une priorité de réseau.
C'est-à-dire que le l'éolien et le
solaire entre en priorité de réseau en
France mais également en Europe.
C'est-à-dire que le solaire et l'éolien
allemand est prioritaire sur le réseau
et dans le réseau français hein. Et de
ce fait, il y a des moments où il y a
des pics de solaires, des pics d'éoliens
qui créent un surcroix d'électricité et
qui font ce surcroix d'électricité
contraigne EDF à baisser la production
du nucléaire et le suivi de charge qui
était raisonnable pour faire face au pic
de consommation ou haut de consommation,
bas de consommation deviennent excessifs
et on est obligé de surmoduler les
réacteurs nucléaires et de les arrêter
Et le souci c'est que non seulement ça
crée un problème technique, c'est ce
qu'a souligné le syndicat CFE Éner
Energie, mais ça crée un problème
économique parce que ça nous crée des
prix négatifs, voire des prix proches de
zéro. Or, je vous rappelle que la
subvention est égale à la différence en
entre le prix de marché et le prix
garanti des énergies intermittentes. Et
donc de ce fait, quand vous avez une
baisse de la production nucléaire, non
seulement les réacteurs nucléaires ne
produisent pas et donc vous avez un coût
de non production du nucléaire qui, je
vous le rappelle, est amorti parce que
l'intégralité de nos réacteurs
nucléaires aujourd'hui sont amortis en
France et on intègre dans le réseau de
l'électricité intermittente, non
pilotable, aléatoire. Donc ça fout je
coupe je te coupe une seconde. Euh
monsieur le sénateur, quand quand Fabien
il dit que il est amorti, est-ce que il
le coût de déconstruction il est
provisionné ?
Normalement oui.
Oui.
C'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
en fait.
Non mais c'est
normalement c'est intégré et il y a une
somme de déconstruction.
Non non mais il y a il y a une somme de
somme dans les 60 €. Il y a une somme
qui est provisionnée. Mais tout ça c'est
on s'en fout envie de dire. nos
centrales, c'est quoi une centrale
nucléaire ? C'est une cuve avec plutôt
plein de tuyaux autour et plein de
systèmes fabines.
Oui. Oui. Oui. En fait, par rapport à
cette question, plus un réacteur
nucléaire est prolongé, plus il est
rentable puisque le coût de
déconstruction est retardé et donc tous
les calculs mathématiques sont établis.
Une centrale nucléaire qui peut durer 80
ans est extrêmement rentable et reporte
le coût de déconstruction. Mais le
des coûts de calcul littéraire,
comment
il y a des coûts de calcul littéraire ?
Oui, il y a des y a et ensuite par
rapport il y a bien un fond provisionné
puisque j'ai rencontré la personne qui
gère financièrement ce fond. Donc
là-dessus, tout ça c'est géré, c'est
provisionné dans les comptes. Donc ce
qui est très important parce que là vous
vous touchez du doigt la question
centrale du problème de
l'autodestruction de notre système
électrique en France, c'est que ce
surcroid d'énergie intermittente qui est
maintenant trop important, ça posait pas
trop de problème quand il était pas
important. Maintenant, c'est beaucoup
trop important depuis 20 ans puisque ça
a été développé depuis 2001 comme je
vous l'ai disais tout à l'heure et bien
crée un véritable déstabilisation
vers même des blackouts. On a eu le cas
en Espagne. Alors certains disent que ce
n'est pas vrai, que c'est dû aux
énergies intermittentes. Il y en a
d'autres qui disent comme André Merlin
qui est l'ancien patron de RTE que c'est
lié aux énergies intermittentes. Donc il
y a des somités sur le sujet qui sont
très claires là-dessus
qu'on a reçu ici
que vous avez reçu. Et puis il y a eu
RTE qui vient d'annoncer qu'il y avait
eu deux Blackout dont on avait échappé
auquels on avait échappé deux Blackout
du fait de ces énergies intermittentes.
Donc on a une véritable déstabilisation
du réseau électrique à cause de cette
priorité de réseau.
Vous avez des conflits d'intérêt ?
Moi j'ai aucun conflit d'intérêt. La
seule chose je suis directeur de
publication de transition. Ben non mais
c'est le seul. Je suis payé que par
transition et énergie. Voilà mon conf.
Je n'ai jamais été payé. Je n'ai jamais
reçu. Ça c'est très intéressant parce
que dans mon livre nucléaire les vérités
cachées, j'ai fait une déclaration
d'intérêt.
Combien ça coûte ?
Comment ?
18 € et vous avez 600 sources puisque
vous m'avez demandé des sources et tous
mes livres sont sourcés. Non mais c'est
très important ce que vous me dites.
Très important.
Nicolas,
tu voulais rebondir ?
Non non, moi j'ai pas de déclaration.
Je voudrais je voudrais je voudrais la
question de la modulation. Il y a
l'autre sujet qui est fondamental, il a
été abordé, c'est la question de super
phénix. C'est des réacteurs à neutrons
rapide. La France, il faut bien en avoir
conscience, disposit
d'avance technologique sur les réacteurs
à neutron rapide. Dominique Voinelet l'a
abandonné. On a repris avec Astrid, on a
réabandonné Astrid, on avait dépensé 700
millions d'euros. C'est la clé, c'est
pas 1000 ans de souveraineté
énergétique. On dispose sur le sol
français avec l'uranium appauvri, les
300000 tonnes d'uranium appauvri et le
plutonium de 2500 à 3000 ans de
souveraineté électrique par les
réacteurs à notre rapide. Ça veut dire à
quel point il a été extrêmement grave de
saboter politiquement et mécaniquement
parce que je vous rappelle que les fils
ont été entièrement coupés au sein de
Super Phenniix. De détruire et de
saboter Super Phenniix, c'est un
véritable péché républicain. Non non
mais c'est très important ce point. Moi,
je voulais je voulais juste rebondir sur
ce que disait Fabien parce que par
rapport à ce que je disais au début, on
a un problème, on veut retrouver une
électricité bon marché, on veut repasser
de 60 € à 30 dollars, on veut passer de
40 années à 100 années.
Si on arrête les réacteurs en fait que
le réacteur nucléaire il tourne ou il
tourne pas, il coûte le même prix.
Et oui.
Donc moins il tourne, plus ça coûte
cher. Donc on va pas aller à 30 dollars,
on va plutôt aller à 100 dollars ou 100
€. Et le deuxième point, ces problèmes
d'arrêt de réacteur là, ça crée beaucoup
de fatigue. Donc ça fait plus de pièces,
des coûts de maintenance plus élevé et
et un risque de pas pouvoir les emmener
jusqu'à 80 centés parce que les
réacteurs américains eux ils
fonctionnent en base. Donc ils font
toujours la même puissance sans bouger,
sans rien et c'est comme ça que ils
peuvent optimiser aussi les coûts les
coûts de maintenance et cetera. Mais
donc on fait exactement l'inverse de ce
qu'on veut faire. Et et quand je dis ça,
c'est que pour la France
évite l'effondrement parce que c'est de
ça qu'on parle. C'est pas juste pour se
faire plaisir et mettre du chauffage de
21 à 22°gr. Si on n pas d'électricité
bon marché, c'est terminé.
En fait, quand il y a eu la crise euh
des de l'énergie, tout le monde s'est
dit toute la grande prospective, ils
sont dit "C'est bon,
l'énergie électrique coûtera pas moins
de 100 € le MAWh."
En fait, il ils ont été aussi bêtes que
l'agriculteur quand le blé est à 200
balles la tonne ou 300 € la tonne, ils
se disent "Non mais c'est bon
maintenant, on est les roi du pétrole,
on a plus besoin de subvention, ça va
durer et puis disons 6 mois après tu te
le prends à l'envers et il descend plus
bas qu'il a jamais été." Et c'est ce
qu'on vit en ce moment. Résultat des
courses, ils ont fait un schéma et à 100
€ le MAWh, tout est rentable. En fait,
toutes les énergies
intermittentes deviennent rentables. Et
seulement, il y a une chose qu'ils
avaient pas pensé, c'est qu'à 100 € le
MWh,
toutes les entreprises sont mortes parce
que elles veulent du 4050.
Mais elles sont vertes.
Ah oui non non mais ça marche pas parce
que là non non non. Tu elles sont mortes
vert de rage sûrement. Mais elles sont
mortes. Pourquoi ? Parce que
contrairement au pétrole ou au gaz qui a
un cours mondial comme le cours du blé,
le prix de l'énergie s'applique sur la
plaque continental. Parce que pourquoi
on peut pas le transporter et on peut
pas le stocker. Donc bienvenue dans le
monde réel des électrons qui sont qui
est tout à fait basique. Moi mon blé je
peux le stocker, je peux retenir la
vente et je peux le remettre sur le
marché 1 an après, 2 ans après grand
maximum. Mais c'est le maximum.
L'électron, vous le produisez, il faut
le manger. Donc c'est un une autre
organisation.
On fait pas du Bitcoin du Bitcoin avec.
Non, mais on peut utiliser l'énergie
autant qu'on veut à miner du Bitcoin, à
faire de descendre des datas, ce qu'il
faut. Moi, j'ai envie de dire
"Démerdez-vous comme vous voulez,
bouffez-moi de l'énergie électrique.
J'ai besoin de consommation électrique.
Moi, j'ai besoin d'avoir un ministre de
l'industrie qui a 2 3 4 milliards à
distribuer pour donner des subventions,
pour changer les chaudières dans les
entreprises, pour faire de
l'électrification. J'ai besoin qu'on
donne des subventions aux gens pour
qu'ils fassent du chômage, du chauffage
électrique et qu'il se chauffe plus au
fioule ou au gaz. J'ai besoin d'avoir
une électrification et aujourd'hui forcé
de constater qu'on est en baisse de
consommation électrique.
Je pose une question ?
Oui.
Le cours du cuivre
Ça quoi ça sert le cuivre mis à part à
faire des balles ?
Oui.
Ça explose.
Euh
ben tu as vu la petite prospective de
l'PPAD là.
Ouais.
Sur le cours du cuivre, ils en sont où ?
Ah ben ils en sont
parce que les réseaux il va falloir les
entretenir, il va falloir en fait en
créer
parce que électrifier tout ça parce que
l'explos
moi je veux bien mais euh quand quand on
voit les voleurs de cuivre tranquillou à
te tirer du câble pendant la nuit, te
couper à te couper les chargeurs de
Tesla et ainsi de suite
parce que moi j'entends bien mais une
prospective qui est pas à 360°R
une prospective qui ne s'intéresse pas à
la chaîne logistique d'acheminement
Moi, j'appelle ça de la branlette des
pades.
Non, mais nous on fait pas de
prospective hein. C'est il y a des
institut d'état qui font de la
prospective. Après la prospective sur
les matières premières, tu
as pas l'impression que la prospective
des autres instituts d'État, ils sont un
petit peu genre le BRGM le BRGM est fait
un super BRGM le bureau de recherche
géologique et minière. Écoutez, si on
avait enfin dire on n'est pas des perdre
de l'année quand même, on se détend
parce que là moi vous vous êtes gentil
mais
si on avait une prospective digne de ce
nom
Ouais.
Tu imagines que tous les investisseurs
on aurait pas vendu notre en
faut arrêter les conneries quoi.
Puis on aurait fait du Bitcoin avec
voilà. Non mais si on avait une
prospective que
on aurait pas fermé Fonheim. Voilà. Et
on aurait vu les russes arriver, on
aurait vu les russes arriver et puis on
aurait du coton pour mettre dans la bour
de nos obus.
C'est ça. Non.
Voilà ce que je veux dire c'est que la
prospective sur les matières premières,
moi j'appelle ça des perdre chassés à la
grenaille.
Ouais. Tu peux tu peux enfin moi je suis
agriculteur, je peux dire que si
j'arrive à faire une prospective sur le
cours du blé euh à déjà euh 3 mois, 6
mois, 1 an euh je serai peut-être un peu
plus riche que maintenant parce que
la météo
euh non mais c'est pas la météo en
France qu'il faut regarder hein, c'est
la météo partout dans le monde hein.
Parce que quand tu as une mouche qui
pète euh en Australie, c'est là que le
blé le prix du blé il se fait. Quand tu
as une super récolte qui se passe en
Australie, tu te fais dzinguer sur le
cours mondial. Parce que euh un marché
en équilibre, en fait, c'est un
équilibre. C'est les quelques
pourcentages de surproduction qui font
basculer le marché avec des financiers
qui amplifient la baisse et quand c'est
la hausse, c'est amplifie la hausse.
Donc tout ça, c'est très touchy.
C'est peut-être un écrêtage spéculatif
aussi. Moi, toi tu es agriculteur,
tu as l'habitude de te faire désinguer.
Le cours du blé, l'abattage des vaches.
Ah non, mais moi je sais. Tu t'as tu
t'es déjà bien défit des tu t'es déjà
bien fait
Oui. sur le prix de l'engrais notamment.
Ah bah oui
oui, on peut en parler parce que quand
c'est gaz en granul.
Donc à force de te faire démonter
comme tu es obligé d'assumer parce que
c'est ton exploitation, c'est ta femme,
c'est tes bêtes, c'est ta bouffe, c'est
ton terrain,
c'est tes copains.
Tu as appris.
Et ben j'ai appris.
Mais j'ai une question à te poser qui
est vraiment toute bête.
Les mecs qui font la prospective pour
nous, notre état,
tu as l'impression qu'ils se font
desingués ? Moi je sais pas
de me en fait.
Si si vous voulez,
moi je voudrais parler des prospectives
de RTE.
Alors
est-ce que tu as pas l'impression que
celui qui fait la prospective et qui
mange sa prospective,
je te donne l'exemple d'un trader, pas
d'un économiste qui va te donner des
conseils, tu comprends ? C'est
l'économiste maison de la chaîne de
télé. Tu lui poses la question, tu fais
"Écoute mon petit grand, tuexposé
comment sur les marchés toi ?" Ah bah là
ça commence à biller. Toi tu es
agriculteur, tu es comme un trader, tu
es exposé.
Tu perds ton slip si tu te fais
démonter.
Ah bah oui, tu payes, tu payes quand tu
es posé sur les mar question toute bête.
Les grands intellectuel de la
prospective de l'anticipation,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils font une
synthèse bibliographique de toutes les
prospectives qui vont niffler au qu
points du monde. Est-ce qu'ils se font
desingués quand ils ont perdu ?
Bien sûr que non. Mais en fait, bien sûr
que non. Pourquoi ? Parce que parce que
parce que c'est le principe et c'est le
fonctionnement. Est-ce que tu as déjà vu
un ministre qui s'est fait désinguer
parce qu'il avait fait une grosse
connerie ? Ça existe pas en fait. On est
dans un système, je l'ai dit déjà,
peut-être Robert Boulin. Non, pardon.
Ouais, enfin ouais, c'était pour
d'autres raisons. Mais
quelle raison ?
Bah la raison que qui est indiquée par
les deux trois barbouses qui commencent
à parler et qui ont des remors.
Aujourd'hui, ma copine Catherine Gracier
avec son média
a touché un peu du doigt les choses et
ça finit par parler pour la raison que
certains ont
investigation aussi hein.
Ouais. Ouai. Oui. Oui. Bah c'est elle
bosse là-bas. Euh et euh bon, on revient
sur notre sujet. Euh si tu veux, les
grands principes de fonctionnement de
l'État, c'est euh de la prospective qui
sert de base pour faire une stratégie
d'État. Non mais non mais tu peux te
marrer mais euh c'est et et Fabien va
revenir sur RTE parce que après une fois
qu'on le branche, on le débranche plus.
Fabien
branché aussi.
Une fois que tu as cette prospective et
souvent on demande des cabinets
extérieurs de faire la synthèse
bibliographique, non mais bien sûr, mais
ça comme on a on ne fait plus confiance
aussi à nos fonctionnaires qui étaient
de grande qualité, c'està-dire il y a
une grande défiance du politique qui se
dit non vaut peut-être mieux qu'on
demande à des gros cabinets, ils sont
peut-être plus fiables, ils ont plus de
connaissance, moi j'y crois pas du tout
parce qu'on a des quand même des haut
fonctionnaires, il faut quand même être
fier des deux trois têtes qu'on a dans
notre hautre fonction publique qui font
une stratégie, une prospective mais en
fait comme elle vient de l'État, c'est
pas fun. Euh quand c'est emballé avec le
beau PowerPoint et que tu l'as payé
500000 balles, c'est plus fun parce que
tu l'as payé 500000 balles mais c'est
complètement con. Donc on a écouté ces
marchands de rêve sûrement influencé par
deux trois copains qu'ils avaient qui
traînaient dans le dans dans le machin
comme
de trois pays
ou de trois pays comme l'a dit Fabien et
il a très bien touché du doigt Fabien.
Mais j'ai envie de dire euh on a plutôt
pris euh en se disant en se disant mais
au bout du bout, moi je suis antip
antinucléaire primaire donc ça va très
bien de prendre le narratif allemand.
C'est juste ça en fait. On a des gens
qui se sont cachés
et qui sont antinucléries primaire et
que l'excellence de la filière nucléaire
française
emmerdait ceux qui étaient
antinucléaires et qu'ils ont et ils ont
trouvé
emmerdé ceux qui étaient pro
nucléairire.
Voilà. Et ils ont trouvé une chose à
mettre en place, c'est ils vont
dévitaliser la filière comme le dit très
bien Fabien et le dit très bien Nicolas.
C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On
la dévitalise comment ? On met trop
d'énergie, automatiquement tu modules,
tu diminues la consommation et à la fin,
c'est comme ta voiture qui était garée
dans Paris dont tu te sers jamais mais
donc il te coûte 100 balles de de
stationnement par jour. Et c'est ça une
centrale nucléaire. Demain, est-ce qu'on
veut des centrales nucléaires comme chez
Hidalgo où tu es garé dans le truc et tu
te sers jamais de ta bagnole ? On en est
rendu là. Donc si on se bouge pas pour
électrifier, on n pas besoin de faire
plus d'électricité. du cuivre qui va pas
coûter cher.
Ah mais le cuivre va coûter toujours
plus cher parce que les les Chinois qui
sont tous sauf des bines euh les Chinois
eux ils font de la géopolitique des
matières premières. Donc eux ils
investissent dans des mines, ils captent
le les mines et après ils distribuent à
qui à leurs amis les matières premières.
Les métau rares, ils ont clairement dit
que maintenant c'était à la tête du
client que ça allait se distribuer. Donc
on se retrouve nous industriel euh dans
une situation où on va être dépendant du
bon vouloir des mecs qui tiennent la
matière première. Et vous savez quand on
abandonne l'agriculture comme en ce
moment sur tout un tas de sujets la
bouffe ça sera pareil de
va revenir on va revenir sur tout ça je
te je te donne Non mais tu vas revenir
quand je te le dirai
pour terminer juste je suis magime
aujourd'hu
monsieur le sénateur quand tu me dis OK
je je grossis le trait en en en tapant
sur les gars qui font de la prospective
en tapant sur les gars qui sont censés
mettre en œuvre la stratégie pourquoi
moi je vois des gars gamins qui ne se
chauffent plus. Je vois des gamins qui
ne bouffent plus. Je vois des
industriels. Je vois des agriculteurs
qui se suicide et je vois mon pays, ma
France mourir.
Donc il faut que les gens soient
comptables. Un de ces quatre.
Tu penses qu'ils vont être comptables ?
Comment ? Ça va être le politique en
premier qui va être comptable ? Tu
penses que les politiques, ils vont dire
"Toi, ça fait 30 ans, tu crèches là, tu
me ponds des rapports qui ont jamais été
en phase avec la réalité, tu n'as jamais
été absus par l'histoire, maintenant tu
dégages."
Mais c'est ce qui se passe par les
élections. Enfin, je veux dire, à un
moment, tu te prends une balle, hein,
par tes électeurs. Ça va finir comment
tout ça ?
Pas une balle, pas une balle.
Enfin, une balle électorale.
Ah, merci. euh une balle, une sanction
quoi. Enfin, tu te prends une balle
quoi. Enfin, à la fin tu rentres chez
toi, tu as enfin nous mandats, il ils
sont enfin si les gens votent pas pour
nous euh c'est fini, on rentre chez nous
quoi. Alors moi je suis très zine hein
parce que j'ai une ferme et j'ai 50
vaches qui m'adorent. Dès que j'arrive
me reconnaissent. Donc euh j'ai un
métier moi.
T'appelle par ton petit nom.
Oui, moi me reconnaissent. Moi je me
souviens plus.
Au bruit du moteur. Voilà. Du de la
voiture. Mais
en diesel.
Oui. Bah en diesel, nous on vit à la
campagne. Donc je fais beaucoup de
kilomètres. Euh,
on va revenir sur les gu et tout ça
après.
Fabien, je vois que tu t'agites.
Non, non, je m'agite pas du tout. Je
voulais revenir sur la question de la
prospective et de ce qui s'est passé
avec RTE. Je précise juste ce qu'est
RTE, réseau de transport d'électricité
qui est une filiale de DFDF, produit
électricité. RTE, c'est le réseau
électrique. Et c'est RTE qui a été
chargé de la prospective. Ils ont fait
des rapports. Ils ont fait des rapports
qui doit conditionner ensuite la
prulation de la PPE3, programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie. Et dans ces
rapports qu'ils ont pendu il y a 2 ans,
monsieur Piic et monsieur Verinc, ils
ont anticipé une hausse de la
consommation alors que aujourd'hui il y
a une baisse et pour autant monsieur
Piic est récompensé en devenant patron
de de la RATP et il est question
c'est une suputation
non ? Ah ben non, il est en cours de
nomination en tant que patron de la
RATP. peut-être bon pour aller à la
RATP.
Il est peut-être bon pour aller à la
RATP. Le problème c'est que par rapport
aux prospectives aujourd'hui on a des
sociétés qui font des prospectives sur
l'énergie qui sont l'exact inverse de la
réalité des faits et qui vont
conditionner des euh politiques
publiques énergétiques qui sont
totalement abscons et qui ne vont pas
dans le sens de l'intérêt du pays. C'est
ça le problème. Donc c'est très
important ce que vous soulignez sur la
prospective. Moi je me pose la question,
c'est ça va pas dans le sens du pays où
ils sont cons à bouffer du foin ? Ils
sont con à bouff
Je pense je pense qu'ils sont
complètement inféodés au lobby des
énergies intermittentes. Que ce lobby
des énergies intermittentes influe
directement dans les cabinets
ministériels, dans les entreprises
énergétiques.
C'est ton interprétation.
Non mais non mais ça j'ai écrit ça avec
j'ai écrit ça dans mon livre éolienne la
face noire de la transition écologique.
J'ai écrit ça dans guerre de l'énergie
au cœur du nouveau conflit mondial. 7,90
sources et remise du prix par euh du
voilà. Donc non, je il faut faut être
sérieux. La politique énergétique c'est
on rigole pas avec ça puisque ça
pouréquence ce que vous venez de dire la
destruction de notre économie et
l'appauvrissement de notre pays.
L'appauvrissement des Français,
l'appauvrissement des PME, PMI et
l'appauvrissement des industries. Donc
derrière tout cela, derrière ces
personnes qui font des anticipations qui
ne sont pas exactes pour justifier le
déploiement d'énergie intermittente
éolienne et panneaux solaires, derrière
il y a des gens qui souffrent. Et
ensuite, il y a une chose qui est très
importante, c'est que cette modulation,
je reviens sur la question de la
modulation parce qu'elle est
fondamentale, elle a une autre
conséquence, c'est que nos réacteurs
nucléaires, à la différence de des
réacteurs nucléaires américains, ont un
facteur de charge, on va dire pour
résumer, c'est la rentabilité du du
réacteur nucléaire de 60 à 65 % pour la
globalité des réacteurs nucléaires, là
où aux États-Unis, elle est de 90 %.
Donc effectivement, le coût de
production du nucléaire aux États-Unis
est beaucoup plus bas puisque nos et
qu'en France puisque'en France on ne
produit pas assez avec nos réacteurs
nucléaires amortis. Donc c'est là où on
est dans une situation absolument clé.
On est au bord du ravin parce que on est
en train de mener une politique avec des
personnes qui sont pris comme
responsable des anticipations qui disent
l'exact inverse de ce qu'il faut faire
pour notre pays et dans l'intérêt de
notre pays. C'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer.
Moi je te rappelle d'un temps où il y a
tu bossais pour un truc qui s'appelait
France.
Ouais. Ben écoute, je vais t'en parler
mais je vais juste d'abord compléter sur
RTE parce que en fait RTE auparavant il
bossait il bossait bien et en 2015 ils
ont fait des prospectives où il disaient
"Bah écoutez en 2035 dans le meilleur
des mondes l'électricité reste stable
mais a priori ça devrait baisser et en
fait vu l'intelligence artificielle
arrivé
ben pour l'instant tout ce qui s'est
passé leur a donné raison et en fait ils
se sont fait taper dessus par tout le
monde. Tout le monde leur aur dit "Mais
vous êtes des Charlots, vous racontez
n'importe quoi avec le développement des
renoulables et cetera, ça va exploser."
Alors le rapport d'après, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ? Il s'était passé les
accords de Paris et là on passe sur un
truc qui s'appelle les agendas inversés.
Qu'on fait plus des choses réalistes. On
se dit "Alors, il faut qu'on soit neutre
en carbone en 2050. Si je veux être
neutre en carbone en 2050, il faut que
toute mon électricité soit et mon
énergie soit décarbonée. Donc tout doit
être électrique. Donc pour arriver là,
il faut que je passe par ce point, ce
point ce point, ce point, ce point, ce
point. Et donc ils disent et donc c'est
ça leur prospective, c'est de te faire
une une courbe avec quatre points aligné
et dis bah voilà c'est la prospective et
après qu'est-ce qui se passe ? on fait
ben on va faire une PPE3 pour passer
dans les quatre points ligés mais les
quatre points ligné ils n'ont aucun lien
avec la réalité on parle pas du coup de
l'énergie comment est-ce que les gens
vont chauver comment il et cetera donc
on est passé sur un truc complètement
lunaire et débile. just pour revenir à
RTE et effectivement ça a des impacts
parce que c'est de cette prospective de
RTE qui raconte n'importe quoi alors que
l'électricité baisse depuis 2010. C'est
ça le problème qui est dérivé toute la
suite et le fait que la PPE3 même si
elle elle est pas entre guillemets, elle
obbligera pas le pays, ça ne met quand
même pas dans la bonne direction.
Non, je veux juste quand même revenir
attends sur France stratégie après parce
que France stratégie s'il y a un
organisme de prospective dans l'État
c'est France stratégie ou c'est en tout
cas ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est le commissariat au plan
c'est ça qui nous avait permis sous le
général de Gaulle de reconstruire notre
pays de faire les trang glorieux et
cetera c'est quand même et et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que ce dont a priori les
Chinois se sont inspirés hein nos plans
quinquen c'est dire qu'on se projette
sur le long terme on lance des
investissements on change pas de
direction toutes les 3 minutes comme le
disait Vincent à chaque élection. Sauf
que ça ça a été abandonné à la fin des
années 90. Pourquoi ? Parce que
commissariat au plan en fait plan un peu
trop communiste c un peu trop pas tout
le monde fait des plans. Les entreprises
font des plans stratégiques. Par contre
l'état contat l'État pas le droit de
faire des plans. Donc on a appelé ça le
centre d'analyse stratégique je crois
CAS puis franc stratégie. Et ça avait un
intérêt franc stratégie. J'en ai
toujours un ailleurs. Moi quand j'y T
c'est que c'est quelque chose qui est
indépendant. Ça dépend des services du
premier ministre mais c'est indépendant.
C'estàd que moi quand je faisais un
rapport par exemple où je disais
attention les gars sur les Chinois sur
la voiture électrique peut-être qu'on
peut arrêter de leur donner des
subventions parce qu'à priori ils en ont
pas besoin. En fait ça va chez Bercis,
ça va chez Bruno Lemire, ça va à la DGE
et si je critique les politiques
françaises depuis 30 ans, il me disent
"Ah là vous y allez un peu fort monsieur
Millant." Ben c'est pas grave et je
publie ça, je suis indépendant. Donc ça
c'est quand même intéressant. Alors, le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui été repris
par euh par Clément Baude euh qui est un
européiste convaincu et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit le plus grand visionnaire
euh qui nous aide à C'est juste pour moi
un pion d'Emmanuel Macron qui va juste
qui va juste contrôler.
Une question pour rentrer dans le France
Stratégie, il faut venir avec euh ces
titres ou ces trophées ?
Euh bah pour le alors ça dépend à quel
endroit vous rentrez. Moi pour ma part,
je suis juste j'ai juste rencontré des
personnes
qu'on soit bien entendu et on a vu que
j'allais plus faire une contribution.
Clément Bone, je pense que je sais pas
comment s nommer le commissaire.
Effectivement, c'est une bonne question
mais je pense que c'est sur le je me
demande si c'est pas le premier ministre
qui nomme le commissaire France
logiquement puisque c'est un service du
premier ministre. Vincent,
on a des experts euh des experts
scientifiques euh qui sont en comité
scientifique et qui sont très qui sont
très robustes. En fait, le problème
c'est qu'à un moment il faut les écouter
et aujourd'hui euh on a une certaine
idéologie de dire "Ah non mais ce qui
est bien c'est arrêter tous les moteurs
thermiques en 2035 et on décrète un un
point objectif et après on on tu l'as
très bien dit toutes les politiques en
découlent à l'envers." Mais ça marche
pas comme ça la vraie vie parce que il y
a un moment où tu confrontes un objectif
qui peut être louable. Euh d'abord
est-ce que 35 c'est bien, c'est pas
plutôt 50 ou 70 ? Et et il y a une
confrontation avec la réalité. Et là
la réalité c'est quoi ? Et la la réalité
c'est la vraie vie économique.
La mère qui a pas beaucoup d'argent pour
emmener ses ses enfants à l'école avec
son son vieux diesel et que elle peut
plus traverser une ZFE et donc elle peut
plus aller bosser ou elle peut plus
aller chercher ses gamins à l'école et
puis comme elle a pas de tune comme elle
peut pas avoir de crédit parce qu'elle
est pas solvable une bagnole.
Elle a la vieille bagnole elle survit.
Oui.
Et toi tu as tu as fait quatre points et
que tu as pas pensé à la maman. Mais
c'est ça en fait quand tu le
parisianisme et et non mais le
parisianisme avec des haut
fonctionnaires qui se confrontent pas à
la réalité hormis quand ils vont en
vacances où ils ont la carte postale des
bisons, des paysans qui font chier avec
leur tracteur sur le bord de la route
parce que c'est l'heure de la moisson
bleu qui est voilà euh le problème c'est
cette confrontation avec la vraie vie et
la vraie vie qui a la vraie vie les
chefs d'entreprise les habitants.
Bienvenue dans le monde réel. Et à un
moment, tu ne décrètes pas de la
consommation électrique. RTE a décrété
de la consommation électrique en disant
ça va arriver,
en disant ça va bien se passer en disant
ça va finir par arriver. Et maintenant
ils nous disent ça. Ils nous disent
"Vous inquiétez pas, l'électrification
va finir par arriver." Non mais e les
gars euh essayer de soigner quelqu'un et
lui dire si si la rémission va finir par
arriver. C'est un peu moyen. Donc
aujourd'hui le le problème qui manque
dans tout ça, c'est l'agilité. de la
force de la puissance publique à adapter
une trajectoire. On peut se dire la
voiture en 2035 on arrêtait tout. La
connerie c'est pas de l'avoir déjà la
première connerie c'est de l'avoir dit
et la deuxième connerie c'est de ne pas
réviser la trajectoire. Là c'est
beaucoup plus grave parce que ça montre
que tu es un idéologue et tu es en
incapacité à te confronter à la à la
réalité de la vie du fait de la petite
dame qui peut pas changer de voiture. Et
ça pour moi c'est une faute.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Je me
fais l'avocat du diable.
Peut-être que tu es peut-être pas assez
cortiqué pour comprendre leur prisme de
lecture perforant dans l'avenir.
Ah non mais moi c'est ce qu'ils me
disent. Bah oui. Non merci. [rires]
Non mais merci de me rappeler de me de
me ramener sur la réalité et de dire que
euh non mais moi je côtoie tous les
jours des haut fonctionnaires ou des
conseillers de ministres parce que les
conseillers de ministres on pourrait en
parler. Alors là, c'est encore pire
parce que comme ça valce beaucoup en ce
moment, on a pris les seconds rangs,
c'est comme à l'armée quoi. À la fin,
les meilleurs sont partis et il reste
plus que
le le le bas de le fond de la cuve. Donc
non, il faut pas dire ça.
Si si si.
Non, il faut pas dire ça.
C'est un poste clé, hein. Ah oui ouioui.
Ah bah c'est un poste clé. Euh oui mais
je suis d'accord. Mais je suis d'accord
avec toi. Pour moi le plus grand
problème de notre soci les les les
cabinets ministériel. Oui
oui. Enfin attends moi je l'ai je les
côtois. Euh je les côtoi, je l'ai fait
croiser euh avec des très bons experts
et les experts, ils me disent "Non, mais
moi, je veux plus de tes réunion avec
ces gens-là qui comprennent rien." En
fait, c'est quoi ? C'est des chevaux
plein papier qu'on jamais fait de
sailli.
C'est ça la réalité, c'est "Alors,
potentiellement, il va y avoir des
bébés." Non mais non mais attends, moi
ça me fait pas rire.
Ça pourrait être des souffleurs, tu me
diras. M
non mais moi ça me fait pas rire parce
que là
est-ce que c'est un souffleur ?
Non. Oui. Bah oui. Ah bah si. les
moutons souffleurs qui font semblant
pour trouver la femelle qui était en
chaleur. Ah bah bien sûr, on a utilisé
ça à Linerra pour euh pour insiminer les
bêtes. Euh tu te sers d'un d'un animal
souffleur euh qui va rennifler et qui va
dire celle-là c'est le bon moment pour
l'insémination. Donc merci de me
rappeler de me rappeler mes cours de de
BTS production animale. Non
sérieusement, on a des têtes bien faites
qui ne se sont pas confronté à la
réalité. C'est pas parce que tu as 30
ans et des papiers longs comme ça que tu
as jamais rien vu de la vie que tu vas
expliquer à des experts qui ont plutôt
60 65 70 ans qui eux te disent
factuellement on est tous d'accord dans
un comité de 7 8 10 personnes où il y a
un consensus scientifique.
Un consensus scientifique. Faut pas
croire que c'est des égos sur pat ces
mecs ces experts. Faut pas croire que il
y en ait ils avalent l'avaldas une fois
qu'ils ont fait le consensus. S'il y en
a un qui est pas d'accord et qui dit ce
que vous êtes en train de faire à 9
contre un c'est totalement faux. il va
ça va atterrir. Donc aujourd'hui, on a
besoin d'écouter des vrais experts. Et
ils nous disent quoi les vrais experts ?
Ce qu'on fait sur la PPE, c'est une
grosse connerie. C'est une très grosse
connerie. Deux outils de production pour
la même quantité d'énergie. Il faut
électrifier. Moi, j'ai besoin de
récupérer 3 4 5 6 7 milliards par an
dans le dans ce que nous coûtent les ENR
pour avoir un ministre de l'industrie
qui fasse le Tour de France et qui
distribue des frais et subventions pour
l'électrification. Avant de te donner
par
je termine Vincent.
Tu as rien compris. Regarde
l'intelligence artificielle qui arrive
qui va consommer énormément. Comme on a
un chef de l'État solaire et ses
cabinets ministériels solaires, ils ont
compris que il fallait avoir une
souveraineté énergétique. Ils ont
relocalisé nos data centers, ils ont
relocalisé notre intelligence
artificielle maison, ils ont relocalisé
nos nos systèmes d'exploitation made in
France, nos moteurs de recherche Mine
France pour se défendre contre les
États-Unis et se défendre contre la
Russie. Ils ont compris tout ça. Toi, tu
as rien compris ?
Ah oui, moi j'ai rien compris. Moi,
peut-être qu'ils ont compris une partie
du du jeu, mais ils ont pas compris une
de une un morceau du Rubik Club du Rubik
Club. Donc moi, je veux bien qu'on pense
qu'on parle start-up nation, qu'on parle
des choses qui sont très loin. Euh
d'abord euh la consommation énergétique
de tous ces systèmes-là baisse de 10 %
par an au fur et à mesure que la
technologie évolue quand même hein parce
qu'on nous fait tout un cinéma sur le
l'expotentiel
exponentiel consommation électrique de
l'intelligence artificielle, des data
center et tout ça. Comme ça leur coûte
cher, je peux te dire qu'ils
réfléchissent à ce que ça consomme moins
cher. Ça c'est le premier point. Donc
faut aussi leur faire confiance pour que
ça coûte moins cher. Après moi j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui on a 100 TWh
exporté à peine 100 TWh exporté euh
d'électricité hein. On en produit euh
450 donc ça commence à être beaucoup
quoi. Nos clients aujourd'hui que sont
les Anglais, les Allemands, un peu les
Italiens, un peu les Espagnols, ils vont
avoir besoin moins d'énergie parce que
aussi se remettent à produire, se réarme
sur la production d'énergie. Ça veut
dire quoi ? on va dire à à EDF qui
produit 200 370 TW, demain tu vas en
produire que 300. Son schéma économique
qui tombe. Et c'est là où tu dévitalises
et c'est très intelligent dans l'attaque
des antinucléaires, c'est que tu
dévitalises EDF qui ne vendra pas assez
d'électricité et donc ne pourra pas se
payer les nouvelles machines et entretir
les anciennes. Et là la boucle est
bouclée où faudra qu'on dise "Ah bah le
mieux c'est qu'on enferme 10." Et quand
tu en fermes 10, le clou du spectacle,
c'est quand tu fermes des centrales
nucléaires ou tu fermeras des centrales
nucléaires, il faudra refaire 5 6 10 20
30 centrales à gaz. Parce que en ce
moment dans l'hiver, tu as besoin
d'électricité à 20h quand tout le monde
rentre à la maison et charge la bagnole.
Donc ça le pic de consommation qu'on
connaît avec le le temps froid depuis
depuis 15 jours, il te faudra 20 ou 30
centrales à gaz. une fois que tu auras
fermé les centrales nucléaires, moi je
vous dis en tant que politique, on
applaudit quand sur ce programme-là ?
Bah moi, j'applaudis pas du tout. Donc
je me bouge pour réussir à trouver des
solutions et faire comprendre des choses
simples parce que c'est som assez simple
euh aux décisions enfin aux décisions
qui doivent être prises dans les
prochains mois.
Alors juste une seconde Fabien euh
question il y a combien de zéos à 1
milliard ?
Bah c'est neuf.
La production totale de l'Europe
comparée à la Chine
sur quoi ? électrique.
Ah, en terra water, je sais plus combien
il produisent, mais euh ou là là, tu me
poses une colle là. Là, je peux pas te
répondre. Il faut pas dire startup
nation, il faut dire élevage de la
licorne sacrée.
Fabien,
euh je voudrais dire, il y a eu un
article tout récent dans la tribune euh
qui est d'avanti-hier sur une donnée
fondamentale. Il faut savoir que DF,
malheureusement, est endetté à hauteur
de 60 milliards à peu près hein d'euros.
Et euh ces 60 milliards sont d
exclusivement à la problématique des
corrosions sous contraintees qui en 2022
qui ont obligé la France d'importer
massivement de l'électricité au charbon
et la non disponibilité des réacteurs
nucléaires à peu près la moitié. Et il y
a eu un calcul qui a été fait qui
mentionne que si le coût est maintenu à
50 € le MAWh,
la dette de DF va passer à 100 milliards
d'euros. Donc on est dans une situation
critique. Le 2e point que je voulais la
question des sachants, des expert, du
président de l'é l'Académie des
Sciences, des anciens de la filière
énergétique qui sont bon pied, bon œil
et qui ont une valeur de de de
d'expérience absolument extraordinaire.
Moi, je les côtoie. Je les côtoie tous
les jours, je les ai au téléphone. C'est
eux qui me donnent énormément
d'informations, qui me transmettent leur
savoir. Et ce qui est assez hallucinant,
c'est que on a des personnes qui
connaissent extrêmement bien les réseaux
électriques, connaissent extrêmement
bien le fonctionnement du système
énergétique et vous avez en phase 2 des
personnes qui s'appellent quota climat
qui est une officine financée par
l'ARCOM, l'ADEM et la filière éolienne.
C'est c'est dire quoi ? Officine,
c'est une officine de guerre
informationnelle qui veut censurer les
propos, qui saisit l'arcom. Je connais
pas je connais pas c'est quoi. C'est un
signe tank. C'est quoi ?
C'est une une association qui s'appelle
quota climat. C'est très important ce
pointl qui s'appelle Cota Climat qui a
été créé il y a 2 3 ans qui est financé
par la Fondation de France par le
ministère de la culture par l'ADEM
l'agence de la transition énergétique.
Ils ont le droit.
L'ARCOM. Ils ont tout à fait le droit
mais ils demandent, ils saisissent
l'arcom lorsque des sachants, lorsque
des spécialistes disent le la facture
d'électricité augmente en raison de des
énergies intermittentes. Le système
français est décarboné et saisissent de
manière massive l'ARCOM, de manière
industrielle avec l'argent de leur
financeur en partie notamment éolien.
consensus
le Non mais eux ils censurent ils sont
des des sciences po des des des
personnes qui sont assistants
parlementaires sans sans experts
énergétique. Non non mais c'est très
important c'est très important c'est des
personnes qui décrètent que la parole de
spécialiste de sachant de notre système
énergétique
nécessite une censure. Ils le disent
clairement, remettre en cause les
énergies intermittentes, c'est être
climatosceptique et réacuser la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique. Et
vous avez l'ARCOM qui a donné plusieurs
décisions récentes sur l'intervention
dans les médias de ces sachants en
remettant en cause, en mettant en garde
ces news, sud radio, différents médias
du fait que des personnes ont créé de la
lucidité en terme d'information
d'élément factuel. Et donc on a ce yatus
actuellement qui est très très grave qui
est en train d'intervenir mais c'est
très important hein parce qu'ici on est
un espace de liberté
je vous pose une question.
Oui.
Je connais pas cette association. Je
sais pas pourquoi vous la qualifiez
d'officine.
Euh je me pose simplement la question.
L'Arcom, on connaît. Hm
hm.
Euh euh si ils ont un dossier, s'ils
vont aller chercher quelqu'un qui remet
en question euh le réchauffement
climatique.
Ah non, c'est pas ça. Là, on parle,
je comprends pas votre comp. Là, on
parle de personne
qui explique qu'il y a une explosion des
factures d'électricité en raison du
financement des énergies intermittentes.
Et ça c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen donne une liberté
d'expression totale et donc cette
structure sauf
que si vous racontez des conneries, non,
sauf sauf s'il y a des lois qui
interdisent de le dire.
Si vous racontez des conneries,
non non non. Vous avez le droit de
raconter des conneries dans les médias.
Non non, vous avez cette liberté. Sauf
si la loi interdit les propos
négationnistes, les propos racistes et
cetera et cetera. Parler du climat
aujourd'hui n'est pas interdit dans la
loi. Vous pouvez parler du climat dans
les médias. Vous pouvez remettre en
cause les énergies intermittentes. Alors
la question du réchauffement climatique
pose question. La question c'est
parler du climat et les énergies
intermittentes. Je comprends pas le
et bien c'est ce qu'essa côte climat,
c'est de euh pas criminaliser le terme
n'est pas bon, mais c'est d'associer
la remise en cause de la politique
énergétique basée sur les énergies
intermittentes en le plaçant au même
niveau que la remise en cause du
réchauffement climatique. Vous parliez
au départ de tarif de facture
et bien justement Quota Climat a réussi
à obtenir que l'ARCOM
remette en cause une émission par
exemple Pascal Pro vient de l'évoquer
dans une émission sur le fait qu'il
avait été interpellé par l'ERCOM par le
fait qu'il avait dans une émission eu il
y avait eu des propos qui remettaient en
cause la politique énergétique sur le
fondement que la facture d'électricité
augmentait du fait des énergies
intermittentes.
sur la plainte de quota climat. Donc
c'est ça qui est intéressant, c'est
qu'on a une structure qui essae
d'empêcher et de censurer le débat sur
les énergies intermittentes.
C'est votre interprétation.
Ah non, c'est en cours. C'est en cours.
C'est l'ARCOM a fait une mise en garde
contre André Berkov tout récemment sur
quatre intervenants qui sont intervenus
sur le sujet non pas du climat mais sur
le sujet des questions énergétiques.
Quatre intervenants, on a une
légitimité. Ah oui oui, c'est des tout à
fait c'est des des intervenants
classiques qui sont intervenus sur Sud
Radio.
Intervenant classique.
Ah ben je sais plus là moi j'en faisais
partie. Un intervenant classique chez
Syerview, c'est le commissaire à
l'énergie atomique, c'est le prix Nobel
d'économie,
c'est c'est un philosophe reconnu.
Tout à fait. On a
c'est un général 4 étoiles. Donc c'est
quoi intervenu ? Il y avait un il y
avait un haut fonctionnaire parmi le les
personnes qui étaient intervenues. Il y
avait un haut fonctionnaire. Il y avait
des personnes.
Il y a des tensions en terme de prix
énergétique. Il y a des opérations qui
visent à censurer l'intervention dans
les médias dit mainstream sur la
question de la lucidité énergétique et
la remise en cause du système
énergétique. C'est ça qui est
fondamental. Don on parle. Vous allez
essayer de discuter avec eux en leur
disant peut-être que vous vous trompez
messieurs, on ne remet pas en question
le réchauffement climatique. Par contre,
on est en train de remettre en question
le fait que l'injection
de NR à gogo, bah ça fatigue nos
réacteurs nucléaires, ça augmente le
coût parce que ça, il faut raccorder
tout ça, il faut des tonnes et des
tonnes de béton. Vous avez pas
provisionné le fait de recycler vos pes
d'éolienne et ainsi de suite.
Ils ont fait des rapports. Ils ont
publié des rapports.
Est-ce que vous avez discuté avec eu
? J'ai pas discuté avec eux pas moi je
veux bien invitez-les avec on va
discuter ensemble ici sur votre chaîne.
C'est très intéressant. La la présidente
de quota climat moi je veux bien
discuter avec elle. Ce serait vraiment
passionnant. Ils ont fait un rapport
pour dire que toutes les mesures qui
empêchaient la lutte et la remise en
cause des énergies intermittentes en
faisait partie de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique était
climatoceptique.
Je comprends pas le le le tarif le tarif
là-dedans parce que remettre en question
les ONR parce que ça nous coûte une
blinde et que et ça nous fatigue notre
deuxième source principale notre
première source principale d'énergie. Je
peux comprendre,
on est bien d'accord, mais en tout état
de cause, l'ARCOM juste avant décembre
semble, je dis bien semble parce que
c'est Pascal pro qui l'évoque et il dit
qu'il a été saisi par l'ARCOM qui l'a
interpellé du fait que dans une
émission, il avait évoqué que la facture
d'électricité des Français augmentait du
fait du déploiement des énergies
intermittentes. Je vous l'accorde, ça
n'a aucun rapport avec le climat, ça n'a
aucun rapport avec le réchauffement
climatique. Et c'est ça le danger, c'est
que le danger, c'est que ils veulent
placer sur le même stade et considé une
intention ou
ah non non. Il y a les syndicats
notamment le CER, syndicat des énergies
renouvelables, monsieur Jules Nissen,
qui est intervenu dans différents
communiqués et dans interventions
publiques en disant les personnes qui
remettent en cause le le système des
énergies intermittentes et qui
disent qu'elle coûte cher sont
climatosceptiques.
Monsieur le sénateur, est-ce que tu as
des effets de lobbing au Sénat autour de
ces sujets-là ?
Ah bah bien sûr, mais nous on rencontre
tout le monde en fait. Moi, je suis je
suis je rencontre toutes les toutes les
associations là. Je vais faire un
rapport sur la nécessité ou pas euh de
réautoriser l'exploration euh sur les
hydrocarbures, sur les outremères, par
exemple, à la demande des d'un sénateur
d'outre, je rencontre les associations
environnementalistes, les grosses ONG
totales, ceux qui ont fait un peu
d'exploration avant que ça soit arrêté.
Je vais rencontrer tout le monde euh en
fait. Euh après la la chose qui est
difficile, c'est que euh aujourd'hui euh
les arguments euh
qui sont donné par ceux qui se qui qui
qui s'opposent à à la à la revue en fait
de cette PPE et de cette trajectoire euh
n'ont pas beaucoup d'arguments euh à
part dire faut faire tout comme on a dit
quoi.
En fait, c'est comme si
la trajectoire et les objectifs définis
en amont deviennent une monalisa et que
on la regarde et que ça bouge pas quoi.
En fait, c'est tout sauf de l'agilité.
En fait, c'est la révision des
trajectoires doit être une agilité. Ce
que font toutes les entreprises dignes
de ce nom, ils s'adaptent, s'adapter en
permanence et nous on prouve qu'on n'est
pas capable de s'adapter.
Là où je commence à être un peu agacé,
c'est quand on m'explique que les
experts en fait sont partisans. Alors là
c'est en gros ils sont pronucléaires,
ils sont partisans, ils ont tous
travaillé pour le nucléaire. Bah oui,
c'est mieux parce que ils connaissent un
peu leur métier. Ceux qui ont travaillé
sur les réseaux électriques sont
partisans parce qu'ils ont travaillé sur
les réseaux électriques. Et en fait, on
nous explique que le gars qui est pas
partisan, c'est l'expert de LAADEM ou
c'est la ou c'est le haut fonctionnaire
qui a écrit trois papiers là-dessus. Et
lui, il a jamais il s'est jamais
confronté à la vraie vie. Donc euh euh
et là, je suis mal à l'aise parce qu'on
on m'explique justement "Ah oui, mais
Vincent euh tes experts, ils sont
partisans." Donc euh en fait ça annule
leur euh leur leur expertise. Donc ça ça
devient très très grave pour moi le
politique parce que euh je fais comment
moi après ? Je vais lire dans le mar de
café qui a raison, qui a tort. Je vais
aller voir les négationnismes du climat.
Justement,
les géo trouvent tout de tout ce qu'on
peut trouver n'importe où. En fait, pour
faire une politique, bah non, je suis
obligé de m'appuyer sur des experts qui
sont robustes et surtout on les regroupe
et et dans dans chez le haut
commissaire, on les regroupe pour qu'ils
se confrontent en eux. Qu'est-ce qui
fait que le docteur Raoul a 43
publications qui sont démontées par ses
pères ? et bien ses pères qui lui disent
"Non mais attends là, c'est pas du
travail, c'est pas la bonne la bonne
analyse et c'est comme ça que il
remballe ses publications. Tant que vous
confrontez pas en fait, tout le monde a
raison en fait. Tant que vous confrontez
pas une fois que vous avez confronté
avec 7 h autres experts sur le même
sujet, bah là c'est plus la même chanson
et surtout s'il y a un consensus. Donc
une fois qu'on arrive à un consensus où
on nous dit tous il faut revoir la
trajectoire, il faut garder les ENR, on
va en avoir besoin si réellement la
consommation électrique augmente, il y a
pas de problème. La technologie des
éoliennes marche beaucoup mieux
qu'avant. Les sur le photovoltaïque,
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué parce que
tu as une patate à midi et que il fait
jour que le en plein jour et il fait pas
jour en pleine nuit et malheureux qu'il
y ait une courbe qui nous pose un
problème technique, on le sait. L'éolien
est beaucoup plus soft à à incorporer,
on le sait aussi. Le problème qui est
pas un problème pour moi, qui est une
excellence, c'est qu'on a le nucléaire.
Donc Proglio l'a dit, tout le monde
alors Proglio, on peut se dire "Bah oui,
mais ils vieillissent, ils sont un peu
gâteux parce que c'est comment on nous
dit en offre dans les ministères, on
nous dit, il est loin d'être gâ tout."
Non mais attendez. Oui mais les gars,
bienvenue dans mon monde hein. On nous
dit en creux. Euh non mais vous me
parlez pas de Proglio parce que là on
est dans le paranormal. Vous me parlez
pas d'André Merlin parce que là ils sont
passés du côté obscur de la force. Vous
me parlez pas d'un tel d'un tel et tous
tes experts, on te les démontre comme ça
en disant "Non, non mais là c'est des
partisans, c'est pas c'est pas bien du
tout." Donc c'est là où je suis mal à
l'aise dans la technique en fait, dans
la dans le dans la méthode qu'on doit
appliquer pour avoir un atterrissage
politique et stratégique.
Nicolas.
Oui, mais je pense que moi je l'ai un
peu vécu l'intérieur quand j'étais à
France Stratégie parce que j'ai eu
affaire au conseiller ministériel. Je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment la pire
expérience de ma vie parce qu'en fait je
me rendais pas compte.
Tu as jamais vu du café en Angleterre
toi ?
Mais [rires] en fait c'est là que ça se
joue.
Oui. Et et Brchelvait très bien
expliqué. Quand vous êtes moi j'étais
conseiller scientifique quand vous êtes
au commissaire pour le le vous faites
des rapports et ça arrive au ministère,
ça arrive pas au ministre, ça arrive au
ministère, ça arrive à son cabinet, donc
c'est 15 personnes, 20 personnes s'il a
de la chance autour de lui. Le le
conseiller va prendre le rapport, il va
regarder le rapport, il va il va dire
"Est-ce que ce rapport a un intérêt pour
moi ?" Oui ou non ?
Non. s'il a un intérêt pour lui dire
est-ce que ce rapport a intérêt pour mon
ministre ? Oui ou non ? Si la réponse
est non, il monte pas au ministre.
Il se pose jamais la question est-ce que
ça rapporte un intérêt pour la France ?
C'est une question qui ne se pose pas
ça. Et je le dis et je vais insister
parce que c'est ça la réalité de la
France. C'est cette couche ultra fine de
15 à 20 personnes autour des ministres
qui fait la pluie et le beau temps. Et
la deuxième chose qui manque, c'est les
gens qui défonent notre intérêt. Donc le
jour et là on va être sur des
perspectives optimistes. Le jour on est
capable d'avoir des ministres ou voir un
président, on sait jamais qui défendent
l'intérêt du pays et qui soit bien
entouré, là on va être capable de faire
quelque chose. Mais moi, je préfère
largement un ministre stupide. Je sais
pas qui a pas fait les grandes écoles,
qui a pas fait les nations au machin
mais qui est qui a la France cheville au
cœur et qui va défendre son intérêt et
qui est capable de s'entourer des
meilleurs experts. Là, on va faire du
bon boulot. Mais avec les gens qu'on a
aujourd'hui et je suis désolé pour les
ministres, je veux pas dire couill mais
bon,
ça c'est interdit,
je l'ai pas dit mais ces gens qui
défendent pas notre intérêt. Et en plus
Emmanuel Macron est réputé pour ça. Il
ne supporte pas les gens plus
intelligents que lui. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ?
C'est quoi votre source ? Ben ça a été
ça c'est dit dans ça a été dit alors
effectivement alors je pas de source
j'ai pas de source
tu donc tu dis je te dirai tu ferme ta
gueule
ouais
pas de source tu fermes ta gueule
ouais bon en tout cas et ce qui est
connu c'est que alors je je vais quand
même te donner un exemple
prenons le conseiller industrie
d'Emmanuel Macron
comment il s'appelle
j'ai pas son nom j'ai plus son nom mais
je crois que son prénom c'est son petit
prénom c'est Mathie qu'est-ce qu' a fait
Mathieu ? Mathieu a fait il je crois
qu'il a été major de polytechnique.
C'est bien loin de con
après non après je crois qu'il est parti
à Harvard et Harvard il a travaillé sur
du séquençage génétique pour pouvoir
réutiliser de l'ADN de mammou.
Intéressant.
Ça paye.
C'est Landon.
C'est possible. Ouais. Mathieu Landon.
Euh et après qu'est-ce qu'il fait
Mathonsieur Landon ? Ben il finit
conseiller industrie. Pourquoi ? On sait
pas
s'il est capable de s'encer Loï le Flug
prent Loï le Flug Prian l'avait
rencontré et il m'avait dit mais c'est
complètement lunaire le floc prijent il
traîne dans l'industrie depuis depuis 50
ans 60 ans
il traînait et en fait c'est ça partout
h
et Vincent pourra mieux le dire que moi
parce que moi j'ai eu à faire deux fois
une autre fois je suis allé voir le le
cabinet
jearrête juste
conseil du ministre
qui sort majeur de de X euh qui va qui
va ensuite à Harvard, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
Et qui a décidé de se faire du blé à à
reproduire des bébés chiot et des bébés
à mammouth. Il est rappelé au pays le
mec il est loin d'être bête comme il est
loin d'être bête.
Non
mais je dirais que moi je suis très
content d'avoir quelqu'un comme ça dans
dans les pattes de mon ministre. Très
bien. Mais qu'il soit conseiller ADN de
Mahout mais pas conseiller industrie.
Moi je vais vous raconter une anecdote.
Pas tout de suite.
Non non j'avais un deuxième truc parce
que deuxième histoire je suis allé voir
le cabinet d'Agnè Panier Runaché parce
que j'ai demandé de rencontrer la milice
mais j'ai rencontré son je crois sa
directrice de cabinet. Après euh en donc
c'était en septembre 2022. D'accord.
Donc il y a eu l'invasion en Ukraine 6
mois auparavant. et je vais l'avoir avec
un des plus grands conseillers euh
pétrole et gaz mondial. D'accord ? Un
ancien analyste de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie. Et on va
aller voir, on va dire, dites-nous, vous
avez regardé
là quand on a un problème avec le gaz
là, le fait qu'on va plusir le gaz
russe, vous allez regarder les
alternatives, comment comment ça allait
se passer. Vous allez regarder si on
prend plus le pétrole et cetera. Ah bah
oui, il y a pas de problème. Ça être les
vastes communiquants. Donc bah les
Russes, ils vont vendre le pétrole au
Chinois et les Chinois, au lieu
d'acheter le pétrole Arabie Saoudite,
ben nous on va l'acheter à Saoudite. Et
pour le gaz, c'est pareil. Les Russes
ils vont vendre le gaz aux Chinois et
puis bah nous on va l'acheter aux
États-Unis et puis finalement les
Chinois, ils vont pas acheter aux
États-Unis.
C'est vrai ça.
Ouais. Et donc je dis mais vas médicant,
je veux bien mais le prix on l' sent
plus
parce que parce que les Russes ils vont
vendre Chinois mais à moins de 30 %. Ils
vont vendre le le gaz chinois à moins 30
% et nous on va le payer x 2 x 3 avec
les Américains. On va et et on va payer
et et qu'est-ce qui se passe depuis 2000
? Depuis ce qui se passe ? Notre déficit
commercial avec la Chine explose parce
qu'on leur a donné l'énergie bon marché
russe, le pétrole, le gaz et les mecs il
Ah mais non mais va se communiquant.
C'est ça la discussion qu'on a avec ces
gens-là. C'est ça l'interlocuteur en
face.
Hm.
Non mais on a faut pas il faut pas taper
trop sur
un joli petit pince. C'est quoi comme
petit pince ?
Bah ça c'est c'est nos c'est le Sénat
ça. C'est le
c'est made in France ou M in China ?
Ah non mad in France quand même.
Ils nous les vendent 100 balles donc ils
viennent de la la monnaie de Paris donc
tout va bien. Euh euh
faut pas te rapper trop sur les conseils
ministériels V. Euh non mais sur ils
viennent de de la haute fonction
publique. J'ai envie de dire quand la
quand la tête va mal, le corps va mal.
Euh
la tête pourrie.
Non mais oui.
Non mais s'ils avaient simplement
l'intérêt de leur pays cheviller au
corps, ça se passerait bien.
Non mais je pense qu'ils ont l'intérêt
du pays cheviller au corps. Je pense
qu'ils font assez facilement manipulés.
l'arrivée des cabinets extérieurs euh et
beaucoup la cause. On a quand même et on
met des milliards d'euros de conseils
extérieurs qui sont pas forcément
franco-français
euh euh sur tout un tas de sujets hein,
sur la médecine, euh sur même
l'armement, ce qui pose encore des
difficultés.
Il y en a vraiment dans toutes les
strates. On fait plus confiance à à
notre haute fonction publique. On fait
trop confiance à des petits jeunes qui
ont des beaux papiers mais qui ont pas
encore prouvé qu'ils étaient capables de
faire des processus opérationnels. Et
encore une fois, j'ai envie de dire, on
en a pour notre argent aussi avec des
ministres pas assez vertébrés et
cérébrés, quoi. Parce que quand le
ministre challenge son administration et
a un peu de pouvoir, qu'on lui laisse le
pouvoir, que le premier ministre lui
laisse le pouvoir, fait beaucoup de s
lui laisse le pouvoir et que le ministre
a a les coudé un peu franches sur son
administration, je pense qu'il peut
faire bouger des lignes. Moi chez moi,
j'ai j'ai Novellie qui a créé
l'auto-entreprise. Il m'a dit il a quand
même fallu dégager trois haut
fonctionnaires pour qu'il commence à
m'écouter quoi. C'est ça la réalité en
fait. Et il y a un autre ministre qui
m'a dit "Écoute Vincent, n'oublie pas
une chose, c'est quand tu es ministre,
tu es le train et eux les
administrations centrales sont les gares
et les trains passent mais les gares
restent. Donc en gros, les ministres y
passent et l'administration est le
gardien du temple de la stabilité de
l'État au long court. C'est très c'est
dans notre histoire en fait.
Tu imagines ça doit se passer à peu près
la même chose à l'Europe ? Non. Alors
l'Europe c'est différent mais
mais c'est très lié parce qu'en fait
notre médiocrité
aussi de management de notre haute
fonction publique n'impose pas un
passage au niveau européen. Comment
veux-tu connaître des choses qui sont un
peu plus macro au niveau européen ?
parce que déjà il y a le consensus sur
plusieurs pays qui sont un peu plus
ouverts sur le monde parce queils
cherchent aussi à trouver des solutions
à des problèmes complexes sur le
spatial, sur la guerre économique, sur
tout un tas de sujets. Ils sont
peut-être à la ramasse sur plein de
choses mais ils ont quand même d'autres
capteurs que les ministères français.
Tu as écouté la nana au début 2022 qui
était en charge de l'énergie là ? Tu as
pas écouté comment elle s'appelle
celle-là là qui dit tout le temps c'est
une guerre énergétique mais nous avons
un plan.
Ouais. En 2022, nous on on l'a écouté.
Euh
Ouais. Bon, la ministre Gunvar sur
l'agriculture a dit euh "Nous sommes sur
une guerre alimentaire. Bon bah, la
pauvre elle a pas de cartouche, aval la
guerre sans cartouche et elle nous
invite à Ringis pour faire la grande
messe et la séquence politique du
réarmement agricole blablabla bla bla
bla violon." Et là, on a encore 1000
tracteurs qui se pointent sur Paris et
tout le monde fait poette-poette. Donc
moi, j'en ai un peu marre de tous ces
éléments de langage et cette com que
l'on fait sur des séquences.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais j'ai vraiment
besoin d'avoir un état stratège. Et
quand nous les parlementaires, on veut
participer dans le projet de loi
d'orientation agricole à une stratégie,
on nous dit "Ah non, ça faut pas
l'écrire." Ah bah non, c'est pas
possible. Quand on dit euh sur la la loi
de programmation sur la loi énergétique,
euh la loi dit grémier, quand on dit "On
veut une prospective à 60 ans, ah ben
non, on peut pas écrire quelque chose à
60 ans parce que ça va être un critbre."
Bah oui, mais je suis désolé à un moment
euh d'abord le discours de Bfort Macron
quand il dit on va refaire PR il va pas
les faire il va pas planter la première
rangée de parpin et puis dire on arrête
combien de temps combien de temps il
faut pour construire une cathédrale ?
Ah bah une cathédrale ou un EPR
cathédrale.
Ah bah cathédrale ça allait vite. Ah
400 ans, c'est ça ?
Ah non ça ils allaient un peu plus vite
hein. Non parce que ils coupaient ils
avaient des problèmes de financement ils
avaient des problèmes de main d'œuvre,
il se faisait un peu la guerre. Ça ça a
duré au moins 150 ans. Oui.
Voilà.
Pour moi dans ma petite tête, mais je
mercour euh on est en train de se faire
Ouais. Mais le mercour c'est
on est en train de se faire parce que on
a discuté avec des des copains
agriculteurs, ils sont un peu remontés
là.
Ouais. Mais le mercour
c'est que ils ont des normes de
timbrilles.
Oui. Bah bienvenue en France.
Pesticide,
propreté des murs, la lumière, le
machin, les pisutières.
Tu
as pas vu les p sautières sur les
comment ça s'appelle les les
sur les les barques par
hein bon et puis
mais je sais pas si c'était vrai ça euh
moi j'avais vérifié c'était vrai
de du côté Amérique du Sud bah il y a
moins de norm c'est 10 fois plus grand
ils peuvent faire des des fermes avec
x000 vaches dessus tu sais pas trop ce
qu'ils mangent tu sais pas s'ils ont des
hormones ou s'ils ont des hormones avec
quoi ils sont vaccinés Et
tout à fait.
Est-ce que tu as pas l'impression qu'on
est en train tu connais tu connaissais
la la politique agricole du général de
Gaulle, non ? Notre souveraineté
alimentaire,
quand une nation perd un sa souveraineté
énergétique, de sa souveraineté
alimentaire, ce qui est sensiblement la
même chose, ça reste de la calorie
h
infin. Hm.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'on est en
train de mettre la France avec un
collier étrangleur et que la prochaine
fois qu'on va lui demander de se mettre
à genou, c'est pour notre dissuasion
nucléaire ? Donc un, le mercour, est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train d'éventrer nos
agriculteurs qui se suicident par
pelleté, par tombeau ? Est-ce que tu as
pas l'impression que la variable
d'ajustement c'est toujours les
agriculteurs ?
Et de est-ce que la France va continuer
à se mettre à genou avec les oreilles
rouges ?
Le problème de l'agriculture
c'est qu'il y a un certain temps qu'on a
abandonné
la vertu de la production agricole et de
la fierté de la production agricole. Et
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est donné des
objectifs qui étaient problématiques,
hein. C'est des objectifs
environnementaux. C'est à peu près les
mêmes dates que pour le l'énergie, hein.
Je dis ça au passage, je dis rien mais
c'est à peu près les mêmes dates où on
explique à juste titre parce que les
agriculteurs ont fait une connerie, ils
ont utilisé des pesticides, des modes de
production qui étaient bien au moment où
on le faisait mais ils ont un peu pollué
quand même les sols, l'environnement.
Donc on a on est revenu en arrière, on a
fait énormément d'efforts, on a perdu 80
qui va pas revenir en avant. Et puis sur
les pesticides, en terme de de tonnage,
ils ont juste changé la concentration
comme ça ça pèse
Oui, mais non non non non. Quand je te
dis qu'on a perdu 98 % des molécules
homologuées CMR, cancérigène, reprogène
qu'on les a enlevé perdu perdu les
molécules elles sont disparues.
C'est-à-dire on a plus le droit de les
utiliser en France. Par contre, on peut
les utiliser en Ukraine et dans les pays
du Mercur. Et c'est là et c'est là où la
logique était inacceptable pour les
agriculteurs. Moi, je suis plutôt
procord, tu vois. C'est oui oui, tu peux
me regarder comme ça. Moi j'ai été le
seul sénateur faisir dents.
Ouais. Ouais. J'ai été le seul sénateur
à défendre l'accord du CTA. Pourquoi
l'accord du CTA ? C'était 49 % de
pétrole et de gaz canadien. Je préfère
l'acheter à mes copains canadiens que de
l'acheter aux Russes ou aux Américains.
Tu m'excuses mais après l'accord, il
était déjà en place depuis 10 ans parce
qu'il était testé et on avait euh il
avait été gagnant parce qu'on a explosé
euh ce qu'on a vendu au Canada et les
Canadiens ont explosé ce qu'ils nous ont
vendu. C'est-à-dire ça a été vraiment un
accord gagnant gagnant. sur Mercossur,
j'étais d'accord sur le principe et les
agriculteurs n'ont pas peur de 100
tonnes. On produit 3 millions de mémoire
mais ma mémoire théoriquement est bonne.
On produit 3 millions de tonnes
équivalent carcasse
en Europe. 3 ou 6, il faudra débuger ça
mais 3 ou 6 millions de tonnes. On parle
de 100000 tonnes de bœuf euh du mercur
qui rentrerait. On en importe déjà
200000 tonnes à l'heure actuelle. À
l'heure actuelle. 100000 tonnes de plus.
Il y a pas un agriculteur de mes copains
agriculteurs et tous ceux que tu connais
que tu m'as cité tout à l'heure qui ont
peur de 100000 tonnes de viande pement
les mecs sont en train de crever. Donc
rajouter la petite goutte euh qui fait
déborder le vase sur une population
agricole qui est en train de crever
parce que la France, seulement la France
a abandonné sa production agricole pour
pendant ce temps-là en Europe. La
Pologne s'est développée, l'Italie s'est
développée. Et ben, comment veux-tu que
mes collègues agriculteurs et
l'agriculteur que je suis accepte ce
genre de plaisanterie ? Donc on est
chaud patate là-dessus et là c'est
l'agriculteur qui parle un peu trop
passionnément avec son petit cœur. On
est chaud patate là-dessus parce que
nous on nous punit, on nous interdit de
faire des poulaillers. On importe tous
les poulets d'Ukraine d'un manfieux
russe avec des poulets qui sont aux
antibiotiques, choses qui sont
interdites en France.
Ta source. Ah non mais la source elle
est complètement débunkée sur le le
propri parce que en fait la propriété
foncière agricole en Ukraine n'est pas
du tout dissipée avec comme nous en
France c'est les agriculteurs et des
propriétaires terriens ton père qui va
avoir 10 20 30 400 hectares en Ukraine
ça marche pas du tout comme ça. Ce sont
des grands fonds de pension. C'était un
pays russe. Donc c'est les les gens qui
ont mis à disposition de de petits de
petites sociétés en fait 1000 2000 3000
50 100000 jusqu'à 300000 hectares. La
plus grosse ferme doit faire 300000
hactares. Je sais pas si tu vois ce que
ça fait. Ça fait la taille d'un
département français. Et c'est des fonds
de pension de de tout le monde, beaucoup
américains qui sont propriétaires des
terres. Pour l'élevage, c'est pareil.
était un propriétaire, le spécialiste du
poulet russe, je vais retrouver son nom
mais je l'ai pas, il est sorti de ma
tête, je retiens aucun nom, qui est
propriétaire de je crois c'est 1000 ou
2000 poulaillers, il produit des
millions de tonnes de poulet. Et donc ce
gars-là en fait lui, il produit sur le
standard ukrainien et que l'Europe a
fait la bêtise du siècle. C'est-à-dire
que pour aider les Ukrainiens qui
étaient en effort de guerre à accepter
tous les produits qui venaient d'Ukraine
comme sous-produit de la guerre pour
dire "On va vous on pouvait pas leur
donner d'argent." Donc on s'est dit on
va leur prendre tous leur poulets, tous
leurs blé et puis tout ce qu'il y avait.
Seulement ça a provoqué quoi ? un
déséquilibre sur le marché européen du
cours des céréales, baisse des cours du
céréal. Les Polonais ont même vidé des
camions au bord des routes. Je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez de ça, ils ont ils
ont vidé des camions parce que plus
personne acheté de blé polonais parce
queil y en avait à deux fois moins cher
vu que c'est un blé de guerre en fait.
Donc c'est un sous-produit de la guerre.
Il faut tout de suite l'enlever du pays
pour éviter qu'il soit brûlé par les
Russes et puis et puis pris. Donc il y a
toute cette économie de guerre qui est
venue déséquilibrer l'Europe. Et les
agriculteurs, qu'est-ce qu'ils disent en
fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'ils nous disent ?
Mais l'Europe a été faite pour nous
protéger les gars. Elle était pas faite
pour nous dinguer. Donc les agriculteurs
sont pas d'accord. Ils sont d'accord
pour faire un effort temporaire pour la
guerre parce qu'on aime bien les
Ukrainiens. Mais ils sont pas d'accord
pour que cet effort dure toute leur vie.
Donc les agriculteurs, encore une fois,
ils sont chaud bouillants. Donc la seule
solution pour nous les agriculteurs,
c'est aujourd'hui c'est sortir dans la
rue, c'est se débattre. C'est oui, je
suis désolé, il y a 300 à 400 suicidés
par an. Et puis vous savez, un
agriculteur, il a un peu d'honneur, il
maquille son suicide en accident du
travail, en accident de la route. Ils
sont très ingénieux pour pas avoir la
honte de suicider parce que les banques
remboursent tous les tout le passif.
Donc comme on rembourse tout le passif,
quand vous devez 1 million d'euros à la
banque, vous prenez un platan en
bagnole, vous êtes endormi en bagnole et
vous avez sauvé votre famille parce que
votre famille au moins est sauvée. Donc
c'est ça la réalité de l'agriculture.
Moi j'ai des collègues qui arrêtent
d'être agriculteur à 40 ans parce que
ils en ont marre d'être montré du doigt,
de ne rien gagner. Quand vous brassez
300, 400, 500000 600000 € et qui vous
reste même pas 10000 balles par an, mais
vous rendez compte, c'est que dalle. Et
donc les gars prennent du risque. Il y a
le risque climatique, le changement
climatique, nous on le côtoit au vous ça
chauffe en ville mais nous c'est que ça
chauffe pas. C'est que le blé il se met
la tête à l'envers. Le maïs il pousse
plus. Quand il fait trop chaud comme
votre pelouse sur un pavillon, elle
pousse pas à 35°gr, elle devient toute
jaune. Bah nous nos cultures deviennent
toutes jaune. Donc le changement
climatique, on l'a pris dans la tronche.
Ça ça nous crée une instabilité. Les
cours mondiaux, bah qui aujourd'hui vend
quelque chose en France au cours mondial
? Est-ce qu'il y a un cours mondial du
fonctionnaire ? Est-ce qu'il y a un
cours mondial du journaliste ? Je l'ai
dit l'autre soir, est-ce qu'il y a un
cours mondial de du plombier ? Bah non,
pas du tout. C'est un cours français.
C'est un cours on vit en France et en
Europe. Il y a un cours européen de
l'électricité.
Il y a pas de de de cours européen de
blé. Il est connecté à Chicago dans un
lien direct. Quand ça monte à Chicago,
Euronex monte. C'est c'est totalement
lié. C'est totalement
carré.
La France La France, elle fait quoi pour
défendre ses agriculteurs ? Je prends un
exemple.
Les noisettes en Turquie euh qui sont
traitées. Nous nos noisettes elles sont
pas traitées. Il y a de la vermine en
plus avec le réchauffement climatique.
Euh nos agriculteurs de noisette, ils
l'ont dans l'os.
Ils vont mourir. Ils vont mourir.
Et vous savez ce que me disent au Sénat
les groupes écologistes ou socialistes
et me disent "Arrêtez de nous emmerder
avec 400 500 producteurs de noisettes en
France." C'est ce qu'ils me disent. Ils
me disent, ils ont réponse à tout en
fait. Ils disent "Non mais Vincent
500000 producteurs de noisette en France
maintenant on passe à autre chose. On
leur file leur chèque, le fond de machin
pour qu'il se rétame et c'est tout."
C'est comme le textile en fait. On est
rendu devant un mur où à la fin on va
sortir le chéquier et on va les derniers
emplois du textile, ils ont coûté très
cher parce qu'il a fallu payer parce que
ça faisait un peu tâche de fermer les
dernières usines. Bon, moi j'ai envie de
dire bah payez-nous rapidement que et et
on va s'arrêter quoi.
Tu peux arrêter de dire payez-nous
rapidement, endetttez-vous. endetter le
pays rapidement.
Moi ce que je veux
euh quand la ministre met 300 millions
de fonds d'aide d'urgence sur
l'agriculture, en même temps, moi j'ai
voté 3 milliards pour les ENR euh en
plus cette année. Alors tu vois, j'ai
plus envie de rire. Alors on me dit il
faut pas comparer. Bah si quand tu
gouvernes, tu as des ministres, tu as
des politiques et à la fin tu as un
budget. Le budget de l'agriculture, il
est il est européen, il est réduit à pot
de chagrin. Quand les Français mettent 4
500 millions pour justement les alléas
climatiques, les Italiens mettent 2
milliards dans la même année. Tu as
plein de moyens d'aider les
agriculteurs. Soit tu les aides tout le
temps, soit tu les aides quand ils ont
des pêtes, soit tu peux faire comme les
Italiens. Nous aujourd'hui, on a un
problème, c'est que on a besoin d'un
d'un coût de boost parce qu'on a perdu
30 % de notre chiffre d'affair d'un
coût. Et en même temps, on a eu une
augmentation sur nos engrais de 23 %.
C'est les derniers chiffres qui on qui
ont été établis. On a 27 % de diminution
de du prix de nos produits et 25 % du
prix de de nos engrais. Donc, tu as un
ciseau de prix qui est dramatique pour
les agriculteurs où aujourd'hui on a
plus aucune rentabilité. Moi, je produis
du blé ou des céréales aujourd'hui à 160
€ la tonne et mon coût de production est
à 200 220 € la tonne. Donc les mecs, ils
sont Pourquoi ? Pourquoi tu crois que
les mecs Noël premier de l'an et là ils
sont en train de faire les cons loin de
chez eux avec leur tracteur ? Pas les
cons ?
Non mais si parce que nous pour nous on
est
et c'est son exploitation toute seule.
Oui. Et puis attends, un tracteur ça
coûte enfin un tracteur tel que tu le
vois
200000 balles.
Non mais c'est pas ça. Il a un coût à
l'heure. C'est-à-dire à chaque fois
qu'il tourne, c'est 20 € de l'heure, 30
€ de l'heure, 40 € de l'heure. Et les
gars, ils ont fait enfin tu te rends
compte, moi les miens ce enfin les miens
ceux qui sont de mon département, ils
ont fait 2 jours de voyage, ils ont fait
24 heures de tracteur même à 20 € de
l'heure parce que il faut le rembourser
le tracteur. Quand tu vas le revendre,
plus il a de moins il vaut cher. Donc
quand tu fais tourner le compteur pour
aller manifester, tu crois que c'est
intelligent ? pas du tout intelligent.
C'est comme faire des bandes pour rien.
Quand tu revends ta voiture, bah si elle
a 100000 bornes de plus, ça vaut
beaucoup moins cher que 100000 100000
bornes de moins. Donc tout ça,
on est on est au bout. Et ce que j'ai
envie de dire et qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre, le mercur est inacceptable
en l'état, même si ça aurait pu être un
bon accord parce qu'on vend quand même
des médicaments, on vend enfin
quel médicament ?
Non, mais l'industrie pharmaceutique
vend Amérique du Sud si tu veux. On a
encore une industrie pharmaceutique qui
pèse encore un peu en France. Oui oui
oui oui. Je te donnerai les chiffres
mais elle pèse encore un peu. Il y a
encore un peu d'industrie
pharmaceutique. On a
Alcatel, Alstom, tout ça qui vend encore
deux trois trucs. Au Canada, ils ont
très bien vendu. Quand tu vas à
Montréal, tu es tu as le bah le le métro
est français. On a on avait moi je
pouvais entendre qu'on pouvait faire du
du deal. Le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui notre agriculture à meurt
d'une belle mort française en fait et
que ça on veut pas le voir. On trouve
des on trouve des excuses.
Quelle était ma question ?
Euh tu me la répètes ta question. Vas-y
répète làela parce que j'ai été trop
loin, trop vite.
Est-ce que tu as pas l'impression qu'on
est en train de mettre un colis
étrangleur autour de notre pays pour lui
faire fermer sa gueule et qu'on puisse
secouler tranquillou dans l'Europe avec
derrière les Allemands ?
Non. Notre agriculture est mis en laiss,
nos agriculteurs sont mis en bière.
Non,
notre système énergétique
et d'après Fabien en train de se prendre
des coups de lad des Allemands depuis
des années
et que notre souveraineté est tellement
attaquée que la prochaine truc qu'on va
nous demander, c'est nous mettre à genou
et de filer les M51 à l'Europe.
Oui.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'on est en
train de se mettre se faire mettre au
pas géopolitiquement parlant ?
Moi j'ai j'ai souvent pensé queil y
avait Maiavel derrière tout ça. J'y vois
beaucoup plus de la médiocriturité que
Maiavel. C'est-à-dire, je ne vois pas
une main,
enfin, c'est peut-être mon côté naïf.
Fabien est pas sur le même discours,
mais je suis peut-être mon côté naïf. Je
vois beaucoup de médiocrité si tu parce
que je connais bien l'agriculture. Tout
ce qu'on a mis c'est on a mis cran par
cran des petits des petites un petit peu
de plomb dans les chaussures
à petite dose tous les de mois et à
petite dose et à la fin tu as des
chaussures en plomb. Et et aujourd'hui,
il y a pas il y a pas une volonté euh
alors sauf s'il y a une volonté
décroissante que j'identifie peut-être
dans notre administration où il y a une
un mode de pensée un peu comme les
antinucléaires primaires en fait, une
volonté décroissante euh de dire mais
c'est une volonté des bisounours en fait
parce que si je te dis demain tu veux
pour tes enfants est-ce que tu veux
manger plus de pesticides ? Bah non, tu
veux manger bio. Tu te dis je vais pas
filer à manger quelque chose qui va
filer le cancer à mes gamins chose que
ça a jamais été établi si tu veux. On a
on s'est coupé des OGM, par exemple, euh
on a fait un moratoire européen sur les
OGM. Tu te rends compte que 25 ans après
la technologie OGM, on n' toujours pas
de preuve que çaaffilait euh une
atteinte à la population, quelle qu'elle
soit, pas le début du commencement d'une
preuve. Et et ça ça peut être débunké
parce que trouvez-moi les preuves. Et
les atteintes à la biodiversité directe
par les OGM, pareil, on les trouve pas.
On a des atteintes à la biodiversité à
cause des pesticides qui sont utilisés
sur les OGM parce que ils mettent plus
qu'un seul pesticide à part sur la
plante OGM. Donc ça a des effets induit.
Mais la la chute de biodiversité à cause
de l'OGM qui se transmettrait aux plans
de sauvage et tout ça, ça m'a ça a
jamais existé en fait. Donc on s'est
coupé d'une technologie, donc on n' fait
aucune recherche sur les OGM depuis 25
ans. Alors que cette technologie-là,
elle a permis aux Américains et à à
plein de pays dans le monde de se
développer de 15 20 à 30 % en plus. Donc
on s'est coupé du développ.
Oui, la question est fondamentale et je
vais faire une petite lecture
géopolitique de la situation.
Tu pars pas pour 10 minutes, hein.
Non non non non.
Il y a eu un événement extrêmement
important qui a eu lieu le 14 février
2025. Donald Trump a créé le Conseil
national de la domination énergétique.
Conseil national de la domination
énergétique. Événement qui est passé
totalement inaperçu. Sur le sujet qui
est plus le mien sur le sujet de
l'énergie. Il est incontestable que les
Allemands qui étaient en liaison avec
les Russes avec le Pack Schreuder
Poutine pendant 20 ans, se sont
retrouvés démunis et ont dû s'allier
avec les Américains. Et on a une
alliance de fait entre l'Allemagne et
les États-Unis et que incontestablement
l'Allemagne qui n'a pas fait le pari du
nucléaire et qui s'est retrouvé
complètement démuni pour son économie
parce qu'elle a fermé toutes ses
réacteurs nucléaires il y a un an, et
bien oui, elle a suite à la loi de
Gerard Schreuder,
l'Allemagne vient d'éteindre a éteint
son dernier récteur nucléaire il y a il
y a un an à peu près.
Et de ce fait, l'Allemagne voit d'un
très mauvais œil la relance du nucléaire
qu'a relancer Emmanuel Macron à partir
de 2021 au moment de la crise du gaz
parce qu'effectivement la question du
leadership
énergétique
crée un leadership politique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle Emmanuel Macron a
créé l'alliance du nucléaire avec 14
pays dont l'Union la Grande-Bretagne
face à l'alliance des renouvelables
allemande. Et donc incontestablement,
il y a et ça c'est documenté une liaison
entre les États-Unis
et l'Allemagne pour éviter que la France
ne développe son nucléaire en Europe. Et
d'ailleurs, il y a eu un ancien candidat
à l'élection présidentielle qui est venu
en Roumanie en 2023 pour déployer le
nucléaire américain en Europe.
D'ailleurs, ce plan d'action des
États-Unis s'appelait le projet Phenniix
qui consistait à remplacer les centrales
au charbon d'Europe de l'Est selon la
doctrine Brezenski qui dit que quand les
États-Unis tiennent les pays d'Europe de
l'Est, ils tiennent l'Europe
occidentale. Et de ce fait, les
États-Unis ont un vrai projet pour
rénucléariser
l'Europe, pour empêcher que la France ne
redéploie le nucléaire en Europe.
Pourquoi ? parce que
le combustible d'ailleurs dans le pacte
et dans le l'accord qui avait été rendu
avec Van Derleyen, Donald Trump a imposé
l'achat de gaz, gaz naturel liqufié et
du combustible nucléaire parce que le
combustible nucléaire crée une
vassalisation pendant 80 ans. Et de ce
fait, effectivement, en tout cas moi sur
les questions énergétiques, je sens
incontestablement et ça c'est avec des
éléments sourcé, tout le monde peut
vérifier ce que je dis, qu'il y a une
alliance entre l'Allemagne et les
États-Unis pour éviter que la France et
ça explique les actions de guerre
informationnelle contre le nucléaire
français venant de l'Allemagne a
vraiment pas intérêt à ce que le le se
développe le nucléaire de DF d'origine
française.
au niveau européen et fait tout pour
empêcher que la France récupère un
leadership en matière nucléaire là où
elle a abandonné le nucléaire avec les
conséquences désastreuses pour son
économie, une explosion du coût et une
terrible baisse de sa compétitivité. Et
les États-Unis ont bien compris qu'avec
un gaz vendu très cher cinq fois le prix
euh que dans le marché domestique, il
plantaient la compétitivité industrielle
de l'Europe. Donc le gros avantage dans
cette guerre de l'énergie mondiale,
c'est que les États-Unis non seulement
créent bah du déficit commercial nous en
nous vendant de l'électricité de de pas
de l'électricité de l'énergie chère mais
en même temps elle plante notre
compétitivité industrielle. Donc oui,
incontestablement l'Allemagne en liaison
avec les États-Unis crée un système pour
empêcher la France de sortir la tête de
l'eau dans en matière énergétique. Et ça
explique d'ailleurs pourquoi le marché
européen de l'électricité n'est pas
réformé dans les intérêts de la France.
Nicolas,
moi j'avais envie de rebondir sur
peut-être un peu sur Vincent, le merur,
les lieux échange. Il y a un truc qui me
gêne et peut-être que je vais poser la
question à Vincent après, mais moi je ne
comprends pas pourquoi dans ma lecture
des choses, dans ce que j'ai essayé de
faire à France stratégie, les
recommandations que j'avais, ce que j'ai
encore comme recommandation aujourd'hui,
en fait l'obstacle sur lequel je bute
toujours infiné à chaque fois, c'est la
Commission européenne, c'est l'Union
européenne, c'est le reocher et en fait
je regrette que en France alors que le
Oui à Masri est passé de justesse suite
à plusieurs mensonges de François
Mitteran et que les Français ont dit non
en 2005 l'Europe, il y a aucun grand
parti et aucun parti à part peut-être
François Aslin c'est ça en gros qui
remettent en question la construction de
ce truc là c'est un truc c'est une
donnée d'entrée ah ben non mais l'Europe
c'est là on va faire avec machin non en
fait c'est en train de nous tuer à petit
feu depuis 1986 en fait si en 1997
Jacques Chir IAC euh a a euh a a fait la
stadie solution qu'on a récupéré la
gauche ployelle, qu'ils ont tué Super
Phenniix, qui nous ont mis les 35 heur
dans les pattes. C'est parce qu'en fait
il était bloqué par le serpent monétaire
européen quand il était en 95 qu'il a eu
aucune marge de manœuvre et qu'il a dû
en octobre 95 dire en fait tout mon
programme c'était du pipo et je vous
fais un plan d'autité pendant 3 ans
sinon on sera pas dans l'euro. En fait
c'est quand même des conséquences ce
truclà. On perd Super Phenniix, on prend
les 35 heur à que les Allemands
d'évaluent et en fait en France, tu n'as
pas le droit de parler de l'Europe. Tu
alors je sais pas d'illeurs, je poserai
la question à Vincent qui est chez
Horizon, est-ce que chez Horizon on a le
droit de dire tiens l'Europe est-ce que
les gars on se réveillerait pas, on se
poserait pas la question ? Moi ça me
pose un vrai problème. Et la deuxième
chose maintenant c'est pour parler des
solutions, c'est comment est-ce qu'on
fait ? Moi quand j'étais à France
stratégie, j'ai dit j'ai plusieurs fois
on a des brainstorm tous les ans pour
dire voilà enfin des des remu ménages
intellectuels, je sais pas comment on
dit en français pour dire qu'est-ce
qu'on va publier ? Et moi je dis
écoutez, j'ai toujours dit il faut que
enf les ré du commerce mondial ça marche
pas pour nous là à chaque fois l'Europe
qui est qui en fait la mondialisation
c'est que un truc européen c'est juste
nous qui avons baissé notre froc devant
tout le monde pendant que eux se
protégeaient et donc il a un moment
donné en fait ça marche pas quand les
gens ils produisent à 10 fois moins cher
que nous on peut pas être compétitif ça
n'existe nulle part et donc dire voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
veut voilà qu'est-ce qu' on est fr
stratégie on est au commissariat au
plans qu'est-ce que il y a plusieurs
secteurs qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire chez
chez nous, qu'est-ce qu'on veut produire
chez nous ? Est-ce qu'on veut
relocaliser les brosses à dents ?
Peut-être pas, on va les laisser aux
chinois.
Peut-être le paracet vol,
mais j'ai dit voilà, il faut qu'on se
fasse secteur par secteur. Qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire chez nous ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on laisse tomber ? Peut-être que les
téléphones portables, on va peut-être
pas les refaire chez nous. Euh et il est
et dans ce cas-là secteur par secteur,
il faut qu'on fasse et ça c'est une note
que j'ai euh développé avec France
Stratégie mais que j'ai jamais pu
publier malheureusement euh c'est de
dire qu'est-ce que euh qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de dire comme les Américains. C'est
ce qu'a fait Trump, Biden Trump, ils ont
identifié un certain nombre de secteurs,
les semiconducteurs,
les énergies, les batteries. Donc c'est
le chip act et le inflation reduction
act. Il dit "Ben nous, on met le paquet
sur ces secteurs mais on se protège
aussi. On met les taxes de 25, 50 % sur
les voitures électriques, sur les
panneaux solaires, sur les machins. Et
tant qu'on fait pas ce travail, nous en
France, on dit voilà
quels sont les secteurs ? Qu'est-ce que
je vais faire chez moi ? Comment je me
protège ? Et comment aussi je comment
j'encourage ? Parce que les Américains,
ils mettent 2000 milliards de dollars de
crédit d'impôt sur la table. C'est pas
juste ils ont le bazooka derrière et
après derrière ils nous ont planté sur
l'énergie, ce qui permet de récupérer et
cetera. Mais il faut faire ce travail.
Alors, j'aimerais bien poser la question
à Vincent. Qu'est-ce que vous faites
vous chez Horizon ? pour faire ce
travail et quelle est la position de
Horizon sur l'Europe ? Est-ce qu'on fait
juste
Horizon ? C'est quoi ? C'est Édouard
Philippe, c'est ça ?
J'ai rencontré Delor euh 2 ans avant son
décès et euh il m'a dit qu'il a un seul
regret en fait, c'est d'avoir fait cette
grande Europe euh du commerce du
commerce un peu complètement débridé
parce qu'en fait ils avaient une peur
bleue qui est la guerre. Donc le fait de
faire du commerce en enfin ça a quand
même été ça la genèse, le traumatisme de
de la sortie de la guerre en se disant
on fait l'Europe, le meurtre du commerce
et que entre commerçants, on se fait
pas, on sera plus jamais.
Et ça marchait très bien là ce
Oui oui, ça marchait très bien.
Après on a eu on a quand même fait là où
une vraie limite et une vraie cassure
surtout aujourd'hui avec Trump, les
Chinois qui font qui ont une stratégie,
c'est que on peut pas être les idiots
utiles du commerce où tout arrive chez
nous duty free quoi.
Euh ça ça marche pas. Et et je rappelle
une chose, les petits colis, ceux que
maintenant il y en a 4 milliards et demi
qui vont rentrer en Europe alors qu'il y
en avait ça double tous les ans. Donc il
y a 5 ans, il y avait quasiment rien et
maintenant c'est 4 milliards et demi.
Jusqu'il y a 1 an il y avait pas de TVA,
c'est-à-dire que le Chinois nous
envoyaient les choses, il payait même
pas de TVA. Il y a un nouveau service
TVA qui est fait qui est mis en place
par les Chinois, mais c'est sur la
déclaration, la simple déclaration des
Chinois. C'est-à-dire, c'est un service
où tu déclares ce qu'il y a dans le
colis. Euh, même si ça vaut 10 fois plus
cher, en fait, personne ira regarder. Et
après, il y a aucune taxe. C'est-à-dire
c'est dédouané totalement. C'est comme
si tu étais dans un avion en cliquant
sur Shine, TMU et tout ça. Et l'Europe,
c'est la compétence qui est depuis 1970.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont foutu depuis 50 ans
? Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont foutu ? Alors que
moi, agriculteur, j'ai un satellite qui
contrôle mes champs tous les 3 jours et
qui passe au-dessus et qui va me
sanctionner si j'ai pas met en temps et
en heure un couvert et les trucs.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont foutu sur ce
commerce des idiots utiles où tout
rentre et on contrôle jamais rien ?
C'est pas possible. C'est pas possible.
Donc oui, notre société et les paysans
le montent très bien sont en train de se
rebifer, mais demain, ça va être les
commerçants parce que vous avez pu avoir
une boutique qui va tenir face à à ces
schémas en fait ou euh une caméra que
vous achetez euh euh chez votre vendeur
en France euh bah si vous fraudez à
l'acheter euh de Chine, elle va coûter
euh quatre fois moins cher parce que il
y a aucune taxe, même pas de TVA. Donc
il y a il y a plus aucun schéma
économique qui marchera dans ce pays.
Donc une fois qu'on a dit ça, le la
construction européenne encore une fois
où on a de très grandes difficultés à
rectifier en fait euh ce qu'on a décidé.
Euh regardez les voitures 35 ans 35 2035
regardez bien techniquement la la
réduction.
Donc maintenant c'est 2040, on a gardé
la même ambition pour les Allemands. On
a fait un truc à la con. En fait, on va
on fait semblant de dire c'est plus 2035
mais ça sera quand même 2035 quand même.
Euh c'est c'est un enfin c'est c'est
ingérable. Il y a aucune lisibilité, il
y a aucune chose. L'agriculture c'est
pareil. Nous, on a des injonctions
contradictoires qui sont très poussées
par une un mode de pensée et un courant
de pensée qui sont idéologiquement très
décroissants. Une fois qu'on a dit ça,
le seul moyen de repartir, c'est faire
une construction européenne où on va
aller plus vite sur certains points à
certains à certaines personnes.
C'est-à-dire c'est comme la début de la
construction se faisait à 6 à 8 à 9 et
maintenant bah à 28 ça va beaucoup moins
vite. Donc il faut reprendre des
partenariats avec certains qui
pourraient aller plus vite sur certaines
choses. Réellement contrôler ce qui
rentre dans les frontières parce que
comment voulez-vous qu'un paysan accepte
tout ce qui est interdit chez lui et
vous importez toute la bouffe de de
l'extérieur c'est pas possible. Donc ça
il y a personne qui veut croire à cette
fable là mais ça forcé de constater que
les paysans n'y croient pas du tout et
le restant pour les industriels, il croi
pas non plus hein. Demain sur les
voitures, regardez, on va se prendre la
vague des voitures chinoises, on va
s'apprendre. Non mais elle est déjà là.
Mais la vague est pas encore retombée.
Quand la vague va retomber, moi j'ai
quelqu'un très haut placé qui m'a dit à
la DGE. Non mais Vincent, faut arrêter
les industriels de l'automobile, c'est
fini la bagnole. Euh
non, c'est pas fini, ils seront jug
chinois. C'est
Non mais seront Oui, mais enfin tu as un
peu 400000 emplois qui sont liés à la
filière les aux filières automobiles en
France. Moi, je veux bien qu'on plante
des des bébés chômeurs et puis des mecs
au RSA dans ce pays pour encore faire
péter la banque du du de la dépense
publique. Mais à un moment euh la vertu
de travailler et d'avoir des filières où
on emploie des gens euh si tu enlèves
400000 emplois euh quelque part, il faut
recréer 400000 euh emplois quelque part.
Et
tu parlais tu parlais de la guerre que
l'Europe a été créée pour nous protéger,
de la guerre et nous protéger et ainsi
de suite.
Tu penses quoi toi en tant que sénateur
quand tu as le chef d'état-major des
armées françaises qui dit au maire
parce que comme on a plus de casernes,
on les a vendu comme des demeurés. Il
dit au maire, "Bon alors les gars, vous
allez nous trouver des solutions
alternatives pour aller loger nos
soldats et puis préparez-vous
à perdre des enfants."
Toi, en tant que sénateur,
bon déjà, je suis pas sur les questions
défense et c'est vraiment pas mon canal
de nage. Donc par contre, en tant que
sénateur,
je te pose juste une question.
Ouais.
Emmanuel Macron, il a le droit d'aller
faire la guerre pendant 48 he tout seul
sans demander la vie à personne. Après,
il est censé vous demander. Non.
Oui.
Il vous a demandé quelque chose là ?
Parce que j'ai entendu Emmanuel Macron
qu'il fallait continuer l'effort de
guerre.
On a on a on a passé des articles, je me
souviens plus l'article de constitution
pour lui permettre de faire non. 50
c'est les débats mais c'est 34-1 ou je
sais plus lequel pour justement par
exemple quand on fait une frappe en
Syrie, il est couvert parce qu'on a ce
qu'on a voté parce qu'on a fait des
frappes en Syrie il y a il y a moins de
10 jours
avec les anglais. euh avec les Anglais,
on est sous statut au temp, on a on a un
cadre qui a été autorisé par les
parlements euh conforme à la
Constitution.
Question
et la la question est-ce que tu crois
est-ce que tu crois euh
il y a Emmanuel Macron qui dit qu'il
fallait continuer les frances de guerre.
Oui, mais oui, mais j'entends euh ta
question, tu es partie sur le général à
la base qui a fait son intervention
devant les maires. J'ai envie de dire ça
peut être choquant mais à un moment
est-ce qu'on dit les choses ? On dit pas
les choses ? Est-ce que on s'interdit ?
Euh enfin moi j'ai été élevé par
l'époque le Luron Coluche et puis il y
avait il y avait le Colaro
à 20h30.
Maintenant on s'autocensure. Est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'on se censure
soi-même ? Est-ce que le général il a
pas le droit de dire une potentialité
qui pourrait arriver un jour sur quelque
chose que moi tu dis ça à ma fille qui a
21 ans, potentiellement il y aura une
guerre ou là
c'est quoi ta fille dans la vie ?
Ah bah là elle est la fac elle se
cherche beaucoup. fait v faag de droit,
ça lui plaît pas. Donc elle est fac de
langue. Euh si tu veux euh pour euh pour
quelqu'un qui a mon mon monu qui est un
gars euh conceptuellement euh dire euh
nous dans la famille, on a on a perdu
notre arrière-gr-père une semaine avant
la la fin de la guerre 1418. qui s'est
tapé toute la guerre de la plus crasse
141 et il meurt alors bien sûr avec une
balle dans le cœur parce que tu meurs
toujours avec une balle dans le cœur
pour que ça soit fun sur la carte
postale mais il meurt 5 jours avant la
avant le le 11 novembre c'est
complètement trash mais c'est comme ça
on a été élevé dans cette dans cette
culture. Ma grand-mère elle est a
planqué des résistants. Elle est juste
parmi les nations parce que elle a
planqué des des elle a planqué des juifs
pendant la guerre. pasé que des
résistants. Euh, on a cette culture où
la guerre, on en a beaucoup parlé dans
la famille.
Des juifs qui étaient résistants aussi,
hein.
Oui. Oui. Bah, bien sûr. Mais ce que je
veux dire, c'est que on est on est
encore un on a fait la passation du
témoin de génération en génération,
chose qui est pas forcément évident dans
toutes les familles. Donc, on arrive
avec nos jeunes qui ont 14, 15, 16, 16,
17, 18, 20 ans, 25 ans qui sont beaucoup
moins imprégnés de cette culture de la
mémoire de la guerre en fait. Et
aujourd'hui, quand il y a ce général qui
dit de façon trasche quelque chose qui
est un peu
il a il a peut-être un peu dépassé euh
je sais pas qui dit qui dit ce qu'il a
dit, tout le monde gueule. Euh bah je
dis non à un moment la guerre c'est pas
propre les gars. La guerre qui a imaginé
qu'on allait faire une guerre qui allait
imaginer qu'on allait faire une guerre
en Ukraine avec des mecs dans des
tranchées comme en 141. Sauf que là
c'est pas un obu qui te tombe sur la
gueule, c'est un drone qui te regarde et
qui se fonce dessus. Qui aurait imaginé
ça au début de cette guerre ? Personne.
Personne. Le
quoi ? Le coût des tranchées ou des
drones ?
Non, le coût des tranchées des drones.
Le coup des deux. Parce qu'on était
habitué à la guerre en Irak, tu sais, on
fait ça en avion, c'est hyper moderne.
Parle de la Libye pour nous.
Ouais. Ou la Libye ou par exemple, très
bon exemple. Euh donc ça reste des
guerres où après c'est le désert des
Tartares et après il se reconstitue
quelque chose qui est encore pire que la
bête immonde qui était à l'origine mais
et puis après il traverse la mer parce
que ça a des ça a des conséquences. euh
géopolitique majeur. Euh et quand on
vend pas de blé euh aux avec en Algérie
ou au Maroc, il traversent la guerre, il
traverse la mer. Et quand on se fâche
avec les pays du Maghreb, parce que les
Français, on se fâche avec un peu tout
le monde parce qu'on est un peu crâneur,
c'est surtout Emmanuel Macron.
Oui. Non, mais le problème c'est que euh
ils achètent du blé aux Ukrainiens, aux
Russes ou ailleurs et tout ce qui leur
vendent, tout ce qui nous vendait avant,
ils vendent ailleurs. Et
je te répète la fin de ma question. Moi,
j'ai entendu il y a pas longtemps que
Emmanuel Macron, il nous a dit qu'il
fallait continuer l'effort de guerre. H
toi, tu es sénateur.
H
Emmanuel Macron, s'il dit qu'il faut
continuer l'effort de guerre pour
soutenir l'Ukraine,
ça veut dire qu'on est en guerre.
Ça veut dire qu'on est cobelligérant.
Est-ce que toi sénateur tu as été au
courant d'ici 48
si tu es pas au courant, qu'est-ce que
tu vas faire ? Je suis pas encore dans
la commission défense.
Non, mais tu as pas besoin d'être dans
la commission défense nous on
tu as pas besoin d'être dans la
commission de défense.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Mais quand on
fait en fait, on fait des débats des
débats au Sénat, comment ça marche ? On
fait des débats, il s'appelle les débats
50-1 je crois où tu as le premier
ministre qui vient qui fait un discours.
Tu as chaque président de groupe qui
fait un discours, c'est 6 minutes par
personne. Ceux de Maluré sont assez bons
parce que il prend de la hauteur quand
même. C'est un des seuls qui
parle justement de toute cette
géopolitique
euh importante et puis après il fait il
donne ses réponses. Voilà. Euh voilà. Et
euh ça fait un débat. Euh moi je trouve
que c'est pas la hauteur mais en fait
euh nos fonctionnements euh aujourd'hui
euh la force enfin c'est le président de
la République qui a la force des armées
quoi. Qui qui a c'est c'est encore une
fois on a un principe des principes
constitutionnels qui sont assez
pyramidaux quoi. Euh c'est euh c'est
c'est
Tu veux pas répondre à ma question ?
Non, c'est parce que j'ai moi j'ai pas
la réponse. C'est pas que je veux pas
répondre, c'est qu'aujourd'hui moi au
Sénat, je n'ai pas vu, je n'ai pas
senti, je n'ai pas senti qu'on me
reposait une question de savoir si on
l'effort de guerre, on devait le
continuer ou pas le continuer. Moi, on
m'a pas posé cette questionlà. J'ai pas
été à une séance où à un moment on
devait répondre à ce genre de question.
Ça ça marche pas comme ça au Sénat.
Nicou Fabien Fabien Nicou
Moi, je voudrais continuer sur le thème
de l'énergie et lancer une alerte sur un
grave danger qui nous menace qui est
intervenu en décembre.
On a parlé tout à l'heure du traité de
Lisbonne. Il faut savoir que l'Union
dans l'Union européenne, tous les pays
européens sont souverains
énergétiquement et choisissent leur mode
d'énergie et d'électricité.
Le traité de Lisbonne a mis une petite
nuance en disant que les grandes lignes
étaient fixées par la Commission
européenne et c'est en utilisant ces
grandes lignes que la Commission
européenne a progressivement imposé au
pays de développer des énergies
décarbonées renouvelables.
Le problème qui est en train
d'intervenir et qui vraiment très grave,
c'est le fait que la Commission
européenne est en train de vouloir
imposer de récupérer le leadership et la
souveraineté des réseaux électriques
européens. Et ça c'est fondamental parce
que en fait
c'est encore un petit collier
étrangleur, c'est vachement bien ça.
C'est c'est un nouveau collier
étrangleur mais c'est intervenu un petit
peu en Catini en décembre mais c'est
absolument déterminant parce que la
Commission européenne veut s'arroger le
pouvoir de dicter et de fixer et
d'assurer et d'avoir une souveraineté
sur le réseau électrique européen.
pour comparer avec le réseau électrique,
avec le réseau sanguin, c'est en fait
récupérer la souveraineté politique
parce que la souveraineté énergétique
conduit à la souveraineté politique. Si
l'Europe peut décider de la façon dont
on va distribuer l'électricité en Europe
et de la manière dont les réseaux
électriques vont être alimentés, et bien
en fait on devient dans un système de
réseau électrique fédéral et on a une
Union européenne fédérale et au travers
de l'énergie c'est un élément
fondamental qui deine
c'est un élément fondamental parce que
en fait au travers de ce réseau
électrique
et de la main mise de la Commission
européenne, c'est un véritable coût
d'état énergétique est en train de se
faire par la Commission européenne.
Donc, j'alerte les personnes qui
écoutent Syerview, j'alerte tous les
compatriotes et tous les citoyens sur le
fait qu'il est absolument impératif que
la France lutte d'une manière euh forte
et déterminée.
C'est quoi la France ? La France, c'est
le gouvernement, c'est les
parlementaires. Non, non, c'est les
partementaires, c'est les autorités
énergétiques, c'est l'ensemble des
acteurs qui agissent pour éviter que la
Commission européenne ne prenne notre
leadership en matière de réseau.
La France, la France, c'est quoi ? C'est
pas rien sur l'énergie électrique parce
que nous sommes la le pôle de stabilité
de tout le réseau électrique européen.
Pourquoi on est le ce pôle de stabilité
?
l'inertie des machines tournantes qui
crée une stabilité de deux sujets, les
l'intensité l'intensité électrique et la
fréquence.
Ça ça vaut de l'or. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui, moi je vois pas comment
tu calcules la fréquence.
Ah comment je calcule la fréquence ?
C'est le nombre de tours
F = 1/ sur T. Oui. Bah oui, enfin là moi
j'ai fait lice agricole he j'ai pas fait
ma bon
monde mais
tu sais que tu peux faire ta déclaration
d'impôt sans avoir fait comptabilité
hein
oui oui oui oui.
Parfois [rires] je parfois j'ai mets des
doutes sur ça. Ce que je veux dire c'est
que cette cette ça ça vaut toi fait le
ça vaut quand même ça vaut quand même ça
vaut quand même cher dans un dans un
réseau et c'est ça qui nous envie les
autres cette stabilité de l'intensité ce
qui fait sauter le réseau
en en Espagne c'est un problème de
d'intensité he c'est pas qu'un problème
de fréquence he c'est une surtension
donc oui de tension pardon et donc ça ça
vaut un peu de fric et et et la France
est pas prêt à le lâcher est pas prêt à
le lâcher à une Commission européenne
qui a dit qu'elle voulait mettre les
curseurs différemment.
La France a déjà dit que elle était pas
du tout d'accord sur les D'accord. Bah,
elle a dit qu'elle était pas d'accord
avec le Mercosour, mais le Mercosour, il
passe.
Bah oui.
Ouais. Enfin, sauf que là, c'est Alors,
Mercosur, on est sur une compétence
plein entière sur le commerce. 1970, je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure, délégation
complète, on applique que des
directives. Euh, c'est pour ça que les
comment s'appelle les les par contre sur
le sur l'énergie, on n pas du tout àend.
J'ouvre une parenthèse avant de donner
la parole à Nicolas. Euh j'ouvre une
parenthèse. Si l'Europe dit écoute Coco
française là
non
tuavales et tu fais pas chier.
Non
toi si tu veux pas avaler tu vas faire
quoi ? Tu vas faire dans avec la tête ?
Tu vas faire tu vas montrer ton visage ?
Non tu peux pas c'est du droit. Tu peux
pas.
C'est du droit.
Tuas pas l'impression qu'on s'est assis
un peu sur le droit depuis le début de
la guerre là ? Non.
Peut-être. Mais
moi je je te dis que là clairement sur
l'énergie on est dans dans notre bon
droit. OK. Et donc si elle te dit
tuavales
l'aval d'art, toi tu veux pas avaler, tu
vas faire quoi chez Horizon ?
Tu vas prendre les sourcils d'Edouard
Philippe et tu vas dire "Nous, on sort
de l'Europe".
E non mais attends, on en est pas là
moi.
Alors et s'il faut aller là, est-ce que
tu es prêt à aller jusque là ? Moi je
suis prêt
moi je suis prêt à faire beaucoup de
choses sachant que mes limites de mon
action publique si tu veux faut faut
comprendre ça pour comprendre comment je
je suis vertébré c'est que moi
aujourd'hui Philippe me demande des
propositions déjà il m'écoute il me
laisse faire ce que je veux au Sénat et
il me il me regarde un peu comme un un
poisson dans son bocal mais il est un
bienveillant de je peux lui donner faire
remonter toutes les notes que je veux et
il les lit et il les écoute il dit des
fois tu vas un peu fort des fois je suis
pas d'accord Qu des fois faut faut faire
attention à qui on parle parce que
Vincent tu vas trop trash notamment sur
l'agriculture parce que je suis un peu
remonté.
Tu connais le sujet ?
Ben je connais le sujet mais ouais enfin
lui il a pas les mêmes objectifs. Lui il
veut être président de la République
donc lui il est obligé de de manœuvrer
bien du courage
et voilà mais peut-être non mais
peut-être si tu veux mais donc moi il il
me permet de de réfléchir sur l'énergie
je dis ce que je pense et quand ça va
pas mais je me barrais enfin je veux
dire à un moment vous
mais la France elle va faire quoi ? Non,
mais la France à un moment la France de
à un moment on vote les choses. Donc à
un moment le gouvernement il décide et à
un moment il y a des choses où on est en
rupture. Moi il y a un moment je me
barre quand ça va plus. Je vote.
Qui gouverner c'est prévoir. Tu as
l'impression qu'il gouvernent ou tu as
l'impression qu'ils ont une capacité à
prévoir quelque chose ?
Alors euh
moi j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit ni
l'autre.
Oui. Alors c'est un peu plus complexe.
C'est pas binaire en fait hein. Mais non
mais de on a l'impression qu'il prévoit
pas. Il y a certaines choses qui sont
prévues, il y a d'autres qui sont moins
prévues.
Fabien, tu veux terminer ?
Non, mais moi je dis de manière vraiment
fondamentale, attention à la main mise
de la Commission européenne sur nos
réseaux électriques. Il en va pas
simplement de la souveraineté
énergétique, il en va de notre
souveraineté politique. C'est-à-dire que
c'est corrélatif. Il y a à la fois une
perte du pouvoir de notre contrôle de
notre réseau sanguin électrique et la
perte de notre pouvoir politique sur ce
réseau électrique,
système vasculaire. Mais non, mais si le
réseau électrique est sous contrôle de
la Commission européenne et qu'on a en
gros euh une machine centrale qui dit
"Bah, on va mettre de l'électricité là,
on va mettre et puis vous allez devoir
de mettre des énergies intermittentes et
de l'éolienne et cetera et cetera, et
ben on en retrouve à la déstabilisation
de nos réacteurs nucléaires. on en on se
retrouve à une déstabilisation alors
qu'il y a une chose fondamentale, c'est
que nous offrons à l'Allemagne et à nos
pays voisins nos molécules de la
liberté, nos molécules nucléaires de la
liberté puisque nous sommes le pays le
plus exportateur d'électricité. On a
exporté 90 TWh et si l'Allemagne qui
fait sa politique antinucléaire contre
la France et bien se voyait privé de nos
de nos électrons nucléaires puisqu'ils
sont contre le nucléaire et bien ils
seraient bien en peine. Donc je trouve
que la France n'est pas assez ferme dans
le trésor qu'elle a de pouvoir
la France assez ferme.
Et ben, c'est la France de
l'électricité,
la France d'Emmanuel Macron. Ah bah je
vous laisse votre responsabilité de vos
propos.
Bah c'est la France d'Emmanuel Macron.
C'est la France d'Emmanuel Macron.
Président de la République. Bien sûr
bien sûr. On est bien d'accord.
Macron est pas assez ferme.
En tout cas sur l'énergie pas du tout
assez ferme. Bien sûr.
Je pense que on va on va être sympa avec
Emmanuel Macron parce que ça a pas
commencé avec lui puisque la première
directive sur l'énergie elle date de
1996. Donc peut-être commencer par faire
la liste déjà de toutes les couleuvres
qu'on a qu'on a avalé suit cette
directive de l'énergie. qui nous a
demandé de démanteler EDF hein, donc de
découper EDF qui était optimisé entre
EDF la production,
RTE le transport et Enedis anciennement
ERDF la distribution, on a dû les couper
en TR pour leur faire plaisir et puis
ensuite on a dû créer des compétences
des concurrents Fantoches euh pour que
EDF n'est pas monopole. Donc F les
concurrents fantoches, c'est la reine.
Non. Oui.
Non, c'est c'est pas que c'est juste de
que
c'est que effectivement EDF doit vendre
un/art de son électricité à des
fournisseur alternatif donc qui
produisent des factures mais qui
concrètement produisent pas
d'électricité puisque DF continue de
faire 90 % de l'électricité en France.
Donc on a fait c'est ça c'est plus
c'était c'est plutôt un manque à gagner
pour EDF puisqueen fait bah tout le coût
de commercialisation il va plus aller
dans ses poches. Euh on a euh la
Commission européenne nous a obligé à
supprimer les tarifs jaunes et tarifs
verts. Donc ça c'est pour les
entreprises les PME et c'est pour cette
raison d'ailleurs qu'elles se sont fait
dégommer entre 2021 et 2023 et avec des
factures x 3 x 4 voire x 10. Ça c'est
toutes les choses qu'on a qu'on a qu'on
a signé. un truc qu'on avait pas signé,
c'est ce qu'ils nous ont demandé en 2008
et on nous ont dit mise en concurrence
des concessions des barrages
hydrauliques et ça au DF a dit non. Donc
on peut dire non.
Bah c'est l'État qui a dit non
ou l'État a dit non mais on peut dire
mais c'était aussi le combat de c'était
le combat de de c'était le combat de
Proglio et donc et donc on a tenu sur ce
trucl et d'ailleurs mais pour l'instant
on est bloqué. Non non c'est pas fini là
qu'est-ce qu'on nous demande ? La France
c'est la plaque tournante de l'Europe.
D'accord.
Les interconnexions, l'électricité,
l'interconnexion, elle date de des
années 70, hein, ça fait depuis toujours
parce que l'électricité elle a un
défaut, elle se stock pas, elle a une
qualité, elle se transporte.
En fait, ce dont parle Fabien,
c'est une attaque qui vise
spécifiquement la France. Et
oui.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'en fait nous on a on
a notre nucléaire, on est la base de
production et crist en base de l'Europe
et et tout le monde est bien content
d'avoir ça. Mais ces pays comme
l'Espagne et l'Allemagne, on se rend pas
compte, mais l'Espagne elle a doublé sa
production d'énergie renouvelable de en
moins de 5 ans, hein. Et donc il se
retrouve avec ce surplus qui est en
partie à l'origine de de leur blackout
le 28 de leur le 28. Et donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent ? Ça fait longtemps
qu'ils se battent pour installer des
autoroutes de l'électricité avec la
France. Mais les Français heureusement
ne sont pas trop cons et donc on bloque
on bloque l'Espagne, on bloque avec tous
les autres pays parce qu'on sait très
bien que si on installe ces autoroutes,
ils vont nous arroser avec leur
renouvelable et donc on va se on va
faire baisser notre production. Tout ce
qu'on a dit depuis
l'interconnexion d'Andaille est prévue
pour 28 he elle est presque finie. Elle
était déjà prévue. Oui. Mais qui va
doubler les interconnexions avec
l'Espagne. Donc ce qui veut dire contre
nous. Donc si on maintient la priorité
elle été accepté déjà si on maintient la
priorité de réseau dans ce contexte ça
va être l'autodestruction de notre
système nucléaire et c'est très très
grave. Ils sont ils sont
ça va finir par mettre la France à genou
des
ils sont tellement remontés les
Espagnols qu'ils sont prêts à faire une
connexion si je dis pas de bêtises entre
l'Espagne et l'Irlande.
Donc c'est le Nordstream électrique
quoi. Espagne Irlande. Donc en fait là
qu'est-ce que c'est la Commission
européenne ? Elle veut nous forcer la
main, nous la France finalement à nous
coucher et à sacrifier ce qui nous
reste. Et cette directive, ce paquet
réseau, il vise directement la France.
On est le seul pays qui est autant
interconnecté avec tous les autres.
Alors, la bonne nouvelle, c'est que a
priori sur ce à mon avis sur ce combat
et enfin je l'espère bien évidemment, je
ne pense pas qu'on va lâcher parce que
je pense qu'on a compris les enjeux.
Euh, il y a une commission d'enquête au
Sénat avec Vincent De qui est d'ailleurs
intervenu ici aussi. Euh lui il avait sa
vision des choses euh les nouvelles
interconnexions dans l'état actuel des
choses alors qu'on doit encore rajouter
pendant 3 ans des surcapacité euh
partout en Europe. C'est vraiment la
dernière chose dont on a besoin.
Question internet laine euh on arrête ça
pourinterrogation. s arrêté.
Fini 31 décembre.
Magnifique.
Euh commentaire que je demande
directement au sénateur parce que ça
parle du sénateur. Bonsoir monsieur
Louau.
Louo est aussi conseiller départemental
avec une indemnité de 22000 € nette. En
2023, le montant pour 2025 n'est pas
mentionné sur la déclaration d'intérêt
et l'activité
disponible sur internet.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. 1400.
Tout à fait. Non mais ça se fait ça se
fait un an après quoi. Ça va être
automatiquement incrémenté. Laisser le
temps à l'administration de mettre ce
que je touche mais je touche la même
chose en 25 qu'en 24. En fait c'est le
seul truc de cumul que j'ai encore
d'autorisé. Je vous rappelle que je peux
plus être maire de ma petite commune euh
et que ça m'emmerde quand même assez
parce que j'adorais être maire de ma
petite commune. Je peux rester
conseiller départemental où j'ai encore
une connexion sur la vraie vie de de mes
habitants. Je vous rappelle une chose,
60 % du budget d'un conseil
départemental, c'est le social, c'est
l'action sociale, c'est le RSA, c'est
toute la misère, c'est le handicap,
toute la misère. Alors, je veux bien
qu'on soit dans un monde où chacun
dénigre ceux qui touchent de l'argent
facilement, mais on a aussi certains
besoins sur ceux qui sont qui ont
réellement besoin de d'aide dans ce
pays. Donc ça me reste connecté un peu
aux choses.
Question internet, est-ce qu'on peut
forer en France ? Pour interrogation, il
me semble qu'il y a du pétrole de chiste
dans le bassin parisien et le sud-est.
Peut-on exploiter les ressources
minières des DomTom ? Point
d'interrogation. La nouvelle Konie a
beaucoup de nickel et la Guyane semble
avoir de l'or et un peu de pétrole.
Agnès Panier Unaché vient d'annoncer que
il y avait eu une autorisation
d'exploitation du gaz de mine qui est
une forme de gaz de chiste et donc il
commence à y avoir des autorisations
pour l'exploitation.
Pas de forêt,
pas un forage, c'est du gaz de mine, on
est d'accord mais c'est un début. Mais
ce qui est clair, c'est que la question,
elle est intéressante, c'est que le gaz
naturel liquéfié américain, il est
beaucoup plus polluant que le gaz
naturel liquéfié ou le gaz naturel que
l'on que l'on que l'on extrairait en
France si on faisait du gaz de chiste.
Question internet pour monsieur Bouglet.
Pouvez-vous demander à monsieur Bouglet
s'il sait ce qu'est le curtailment
du curtainellement pratiqué par ODF ?
Ça s'écrit c U r t a i l e l ttel c'est
quand on arrête typiquement si on a on a
trop d'électricité et qu'on doit arrêter
des moyens intermittents
et qu'on envoie l'électricité des
éoliennes dans le dans le sol. C'est ce
qui se passe. C'est ce qu'ils font en
Espagne ou ce qu'il faut font dans les
autres pays. Même en Allemagne, quand
vous avez trop d'électricité sur le
réseau et qu'on peut pas les absorber,
bah ils déconnectent, ils envoient
l'électricité dans le
dans la terre
dans la terre. Donc je crois que peut
poser les problèmes d'ailleurs dans des
expations agricoles. Pourcentage qui qui
augmente, on parlait de 3 4 % je pense
qu'on est entre 5 entre 5 et 10. Il y a
quelque chose dont on a pas parlé mais
c'est l'explosion en fait du nombre
d'heures à prix négatif en Europe cette
année. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait vous avez
ce qu'on appelle la cloche solaire et en
fait entre 10 et 16h grosso modo de mars
de mars à octobre les prix sont nuls ou
négatifs. Et donc là, on a on a on a un
vrai on un véritable vasic. Il y a un
autre scandale qui est le fait que on
doit payer la non production éolienne et
panneau solaire des exploitants éoliens
dans le à qui on demande d'arrêter de
mettre l'électricité au réseau à cause
des prix négatifs. Et de ce fait, ce
qu'il faut comprendre, c'est qu'il y a
une indemnisation des exploitants
d'énergie intermittente éolienne et
panneaux solaires, alors qu'il n'y a pas
d'indemnisation
de la non production du nucléaire
français. Donc c'est une autre
discrimination. En Grande-Bretagne,
cette bagatelle a coûté 1,3 milliards.
Je demanderai à Dbunk, je ne sais plus
si c'est 1,3 milliards ou 1,7 1,7
milliards de livres, pardon.
Juste expliquer un un cas concret de
configuration. qu'on peut voir dans
Ecomic, c'est moi que j'aiapelé ça
Batman. Souvent, qu'est-ce qui se
passait cet été en juin ? Vous avez la
production solaire qui commence à
augmenter et là vers l'heure une ou 2
heures avant le déjeuner là il y a le
solaire allemand qui commence à arriver.
Le solaire allemand arrive chez nous.
Alors le soleil allemand parce que prix
est négatif et donc il y a un delta.
Nous les prix parce que les marchés sont
intercontés, le prix français est pas le
même que le prix allemand. Donc prix
négatif donc on absorbe le solaire. Qui
gagne l'argent entre les deux ? C'est
pas les français hein, c'est juste les
les réseaux de transport. Donc du côté
RTE qui quand même intéressé finalement
à ce que se développe renouvelable
puisquil va gagner plus d'argent. Donc
un petit conf d'intérêt. Et donc
le producteur français, on lui dit tu
coupes il coupe sa production
mais il est indemnisé.
Mais il est payé par ex
il est indemnisé de la non production.
Il est payé donc en fait on va payer et
et donc ça c'est quand même juste
incroyable. Il y a monsieur le sénateur
qui dire un truc. Il est payé avec nos
impôts. Bah oui oui c'est pas le même
budget en fait. sur votre facture, vous
payez certaines taxes, vous payez vos
réseaux et euh via le budget de l'État,
vous payez euh par vos impôts en fait.
Et donc on peut être dans une propet 345
du ministère de l'environnement.
On peut être dans une prop à 13
milliards, il va finir à 13 milliards
cette année.
1 milliard 13 milliards.
Donc euh attention là, on on enfin moi
par moment je me dis plus personne se
rend compte que coûte un milliard quoi.
Euh c'est 13 milliards. C'est c'est là
on est sur les gros chiffres. ces deux
réacteurs nucléaires par an
qui sont ces deux réacteurs nucléaires
par an
qui sont dilapidés auprès des
exploitants éoliens et panneaux
solaires. C'est ça la réalité, deux
réacteurs nucléaires par an. La
politique agricole commune dont on
parlait tout à l'heure pour les paysans
euh c'est 7 à 8 milliards. Euh donc
c'est bientôt deux fois la politique
agricole commune. On n jamais voté une
politique agricole commune de l'énergie
et moi j'ai mes pays j'ai les paysans
qui sont en train de mourir et nous on
crame le gazoile avec des ENR dont on a
pas besoin en ce moment pourraisser en
plus des fonds de pension parce que
Black Rock a a investi un milliard pour
chez EDF directement parce que grâce à
tout ce système subventionnés en fait
ils peuvent avoir un traitement
capitalistique à minimum 8 10 12 % et
donc ils viennent manger dans le pot de
miel parce queil y a les subventions. En
fait, on est typiquement dans le enfin
dans le dans le droit commun d'économie.
Plus vous subventionnez pour vous plus
vous perturbez un un facteur économique.
C'est connu, c'est référencé, c'est
enfin je veux dire là c'est niveau CAP
du du petit manuel de l'économie. Donc
bon là et les Allemands eux ils ont
trouvé le Graal en fait c'est vous
subventionnez les productions des ENR
euh vous augmentez la facture des
clients et à la fin vous subventionnez
les clients parce que les factures ont
trop augmenté. Alors là euh là, moi je
veux dire, c'est le Graal en fait. Donc
nous euh c'est le chien qui se mort la
queue. Euh donc euh euh nous ce qu'on
essaie de faire au Sénat et avec euh
avec beaucoup de monde, on essaie en
fait de trouver un point d'équilibre euh
pour garder la compétitivité avec de
l'électricité à 50 € le MWh pour nos
industriels, les boulangers, après pour
nos habitants aussi parce que vous si
vous payez 150 200 € c'est normal mais
il y a une une échelle de prix en
fonction si vous êtes harceleur mital ou
le simple paysan que je suis. Donc il
faut garder un prix de base à 50 € le
MWh. Et à partir de là euh il faut pas
que ça il faut que ça coûte le moins
cher possible au contribuable entre les
réseaux parce que le coût des réseaux
estimé est estimé euh RTE a a calibré à
100 milliards le coût des réseaux euh
jusqu'en 2040 et Néis à 97 milliards.
Pour eux c'était la chasse aux œufs. Eux
ils ont gagné au loto parce que alors
ils m'ont avoué quand même qu'il
pourrait peut-être faire avec un peu
moins. Merci. Vu c'est eux qui ont fait
les scénarios. C'est facile quand tu
fais les scénarios à la fin de toucher
100 milliards. Euh et puis demain, ils
vont demander des interconnexions parce
queils gardent 50 % de la différence du
prix euh qu'il y a entre la France et et
le pays exportateur. Quand l'électricité
vaut 150 € le MWh en Allemagne, s'il est
à 80 € la différence entre les deux se
sépare entre les deux réseaux de
transport français et allemand. Donc
c'est bingo en fait. Donc vous voyez
tout ça c'est à la fois simple et
complexe. On n'ose pas expliquer les
choses aux gens mais nos habitants ils
commencent à comprendre que il y a quand
même un peu de flou et beaucoup de loup
et que là à la fin les factures, elles
montent, elles montent, elles montent
malgré un prix d'électricité qui baisse
toujours. Alors là compr on a une
communauté sur YouTube qui doit être 1,3
million d'abonnés, 172 ou 1700 sur
Twitter. On a un service de
renseignement en direct, c'est-à-dire
qu'on a le don d'ubuité. On peut se
projeter à peu près n'importe où,
n'importe quand, n'importe quelle heure.
Les gens nous font remonter leur facture
d'électricité, l'évolution de du prix
des abonnements, l'évolution de tout ça.
Et là, on se retrouve avec des gens qui
payent pour chauffer les parents 500
balles par mois. H
500 balles au cours du franc à 6,64 6
combien ? 3300
6 6 3300 euh euh ça fait 4000 balles par
mois non ?
Oui.
Et puis quand vous allez
si pareil 4000 balles par mois avant de
et quand vous allez dans les logements
sociaux qui sont chauffés électriques,
qu'est-ce que découvre le conseil
départemental que je suis ? Des bidons
d'essence et de d'alcool parce queils
ont des chauffages à l'alcool parce
qu'ils peuvent plus se payer
l'électricité. Non mais attendez les
gars, c'est ça la réalité de la vie de
d'une partie des Français, c'est que les
gars ils achètent, vous savez, les trucs
chez Lidl là et puis ils remplissent ça
de pétrole et puis ils mettent en route
parce que ils ne peuvent plus payer
l'électricité. Alors l'intérêt d'avoir
de l'électricité pas cher dans la vie de
nos habitants, tout ça on l'a mis de
côté. En fait, on s'est comporté comme
des gosses de riches parce que c'est
normal, nous, moi je suis sénateur, euh
les gens à Paris qui travaillent sur
toute la prospective et tout ça ont pas
les mêmes revenus que le français de
base qui touche 1400 1500 € par mois.
Donc moins
ou même non, mais quand je dis 1500,
c'est euh avec les aides et puis euh le
les arrangements enfin avec tout ce
qu'on ce qu'on peut avoir. Mais vous
vous imaginez la déconnexion ? Moi si
j'entends à Paris en fait, il faut
manger bio, rien à faire de faire de la
bouffe de merde. Mais oui, mais le
pauvre gars, il a le droit de manger lui
aussi et il va pas payer 30 40 50 % plus
cher son bio parce que
qu'on fait le mercour pour pouvoir
donner à bouffer à nos pauvres.
Non non non, on fait le mercur pour
vendre des des bagnoles, on en a un
petit peu besoin, un peu de pharma, on
pour vendre plein d'autres choses. Mais
en fait, le Mercossur, c'est 10 % du
volume financier de Mercosur, c'est de
l'agriculture. 80 Ouais. 10 12 % 90 %
c'est tout le reste c'est les biens les
services et
regarde la facture énergétique de des
gens qui gagnent moins de 2000 balles
par mois
h
ah non mais attends c'est une tuerie
c'est mais mais on se rend pas compte on
se rend pas compte que les gens ils
coupent le chauffage les gars
et oui
et ça ça le dans dans notre grande tête
pensante
attends attends en haut de l'état ils
sont pas dit bon alors les français vont
arrêter de se chauffer donc ils vont
tomber malade plus souvent va y avoir
plus d'hum donc ça va peser sur
Ça va poser sur la sécurité sociale.
Comme ils vont plus chauffer chez eux,
il va y avoir la merle, va y avoir des
moisissure,
les bâtiments vont vieillir plus vite et
puis ça va continuer en fait à peser sur
notre société, donc sur notre finance.
Ils sont pas dit ça les gars un peu
là-haut ou pas du tout ?
Moi je sais pas ce que je pense.
C'est quoi la merle ? La merrule, c'est
un une bestiole euh qui qui mange euh
toutes les lèpre lèpre mais qui mange
les bah qui se finit pas quand c'est pas
chauffé euh quand euh
non mais tu as tous les problèmes
pulmonaires. Après euh le problème de
tout ça, c'est que on a on a nous on se
fait traiter de dès qu'on parle de ces
sujets-là, on se fait un peu traiter de
populiste
parce que
par qui par qui ? par nos autres
collègues, par euh les administrations.
Euh c'est-à-dire que euh quand on on
parle
les mecs qui mangent bio euh
tranquillou.
Ouais. Oui. Oui. Voilà. On se fait
partout de
vélo électrique assou. Voilà. Voilà. Il
y a ceux-là et puis même il y a ceux qui
sont en dessous mais qui ont cru à ces à
ces à cette à ce à ce truc de
bienpensante. Ils ont tous cru et nous
on se fait traiter de populiste. Alors
c'est un peu blessant quand tu connais
mon parcours. Quand ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure, je vais pas revenir
là-dessus. quand tu connais quand tu
sais d'où je viens parce que moi je suis
un agriculteur, j'ai pas un CV de cheval
de course euh quand tu sais tout ça que
moi ma capacité en fait c'est faire
comprendre les choses assez simplement
aux habitants parce que je suis assez
pédagogue et surtout d'aller voir tous
les spécialistes et et les vrais
chercheurs et tous ceux qui bossent sur
ces sujets-là et faire une synthèse et
dire au ministre écoute Roland là faut
arrêter les conneries il faut mettre fin
à certaines choses et que il me regarde
et qu' veut pas en bout du compte et que
ses conseillers me disent "Ah ben non ce
discours là il est populiste.
Euh non mais moi j'en peux plus quoi. Si
tu t'intéresses aux vrais gens en fait
tu es un gros populiste. Bon ben c'est
bon. Après, faut pas s'étonner que ça
avit ça vrille politiquement vers les
extrêmes de tous les côtés, hein. Si
moi, un mec normal, j'ai envie de dire,
je parle même pas de bloc central ou de
quoi un mec normal, je peux pas avoir un
discours de vérité parce que je me fais
cornéiser en disant vous êtes un
aprepopuliste, moi je sais plus faire de
politique les gars.
Alors, attends, je te donne la parole
tout de suite après. Fabien,
tu as pas remarqué un truc avec
l'énergie ? Hm.
C'est que plus le coût de l'énergie
augmente et que les taux de les taux
d'emprunt augmentent,
hm
plus le vote extrême augmente. Bah
oui.
Et plus le vote centriste, c'est-à-dire
toi et tes copains du Parti socialiste,
euh se font éclater la gueule.
H
Donc là, les perspectives énergétiques,
si j'écoute Fabien, si j'écoute Nicolas,
tu te prépares toi et ton groupe et les
socialistes, à te faire éradiquer de la
vie la vie publique.
Enfin, les socialistes, c'est déjà fait.
Euh non, fallait bien la faire. Tu m'as
attendu la perche, fallait que je tire
dessus, quoi. Euh non, mais moi j'assume
de me faire éradiquer. Enfin, je veux
dire euh moi, j'essaie de réfléchir.
J'essaie de
Là, là, on a parlé d'énergie.
On attend, on fait un peu de prospective
énergétique. Nous aussi.
Oui,
on sait que vous êtes
on va réussir à endiguer la hausse du
prix parce que ça a déjà doublé
avec de la dette.
Non, non, non, non. parce que et ben non
parce que le prix le prix de
l'électricité primaire qui est passé de
60 70 € il y a encore 1 an, il est passé
à 48 € aujourd'hui. Il va peut-être
descendre à 45 ou 40. Donc dans c'est
comme un peu les
Pourquoi mes abonnés ils ont toujours
des factures à 500 ?
Et ben parce que il y a un effet retard.
Parce que tu as un effet retard des
contrats de la contractualisation et que
toi tu as un abonnement, tu as un effet
retard. Il a l'air de dire Ah oui non
mais le prix de l'électricité que tu
payes à ta facture Fabien je suis désolé
c'est pas le cours du jour qui a indexé
c'est quoi c'est tax mais là je suis pas
d'accord avec Vincent mais c'est pas
grave
faut pas réoublier et j'ai deux choses à
dire faut pas oublier que la facture
c'est un tiers la facture d'électricité
1/3 les taxes 1/ers le raccordement si
tu as une baisse du tiers correspondant
à la production d'électricité ça
n'enlève pas l'augmentation
oué
et avoir à côté l'augmentation des taxes
et des raccordements pas ce qui fait que
ça monte moins vite. Donc on a cette
chance là
ça monte moins vite.
Bah oui parce que quand
c'est la hausse qui baisse.
C'est la rê desê
vous êtes des pirates. Vous êtes des
pirates. C'est ce qu' dit rolesc ça. Là
là, on vient de me dire qu' on avait
fait baisser ma facture électricité des
80 centimes par jour.
Je sais moi
j'ai été boire mon café la semaine
dernière et ils me connaissent tous et
ils me disaient "Vincent, on le donne à
qui le chèque de 8 € par an dans la
gueule de qui on la met la le chèque là
parce que je suis encore capable de me
payer la tournée de café qu'on va te
payer maintenant." Et tout le monde a
rigolé là-dessus. Euh c'est évident.
C'est la technique politique est tout le
temps la même. On fait un chèque, c'est
la politique du chèque. On te fait les
poches et après on fait un chèque et
après il faut applaudir. Non mais ça on
a compris.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les politiques ils
sentent le coup de boule arriver là ?
Oui. Ah bah je sais pas à Paris
par que là là on les a vu on les a vu
chier. Je vais je vais être un peu
français avec un langage fleurri puis on
va parler on va parler cutéreux. Là ils
se sont chiés dessus avec 15000 flics
parce que 300 tracteurs qui montaient.
Les mecs étaient polis.
Ils ont pas fait cramer les ponts. Tu
fous quatre ballot de paille sous un
pont. Le béton, il aime pas trop. Ils
étaient poli.
15000 fix, ça fait beaucoup quand même.
Est-ce que tu sens une petite tension
qui tressaille dans leur petite moelle
épinière qui s'appelle la peur ?
Euh, je pense que le ministre de
l'intérieur, on a senti un peu de peur
de son côté. Première chose, euh on n
pas vu beaucoup de personnel politiques
aller au contact des agriculteurs avec
vu ?
Ouais, enfin d'accord. Bon, mais je veux
dire, on n pas ça pas été non plus le
truc où tu allais faire une photo parce
que
piv qui s'est pris une boule de neige.
Ouais, mais bon, au moins elle est
descendue, elle serait pas descendue, on
aurait dit il nous méprise. Bon, elle va
au contact, elle se prend une boule de
neige. Bon euh courage.
Ouais. Bon après voilà, on fait de la
com, encore des trucs. Moi j'ai pas
franchement j'ai même pas fait de photo
pour moi. Il y avait pas de presse et
eux qui ont pris une photo parce que
pour leur pour leur paysan parce que en
fait moi ils me reprochent de pas assez
d'être à leur contact sur mon territoire
mais je suis fouré à Paris la moitié du
temps où il manifeste et que on m'a élu
sénateur pour que je fasse bouger les
lignes à Paris. Donc si je fais les
marchés euh toute la semaine sur mon sur
ma circo, c'est pas pour ça que je suis
élu. Donc ils l'ont compris, ils
comprennent bien, ils savent que je
donne tout. Enfin, je veux dire, j'ai
fait plein de pate au télé. Je je donne
tout ce que je peux pour la la cause
agricole et la cause de l'énergie parce
que c'est très lié. Et aussi sur
l'innovation sur France 2030 parce que
c'est des lié,
c'est très lié. Euh oui, on va se
prendre un coup de boule. Mais qu'est-ce
que tu veux que je te dise ? Moi c'est
c'est je suis pas le comptable. Moi je
suis pas le je suis je ne suis pas euh
comptable de 20 ans de d'escrequerie
politique. Donc oui, on va se prendre un
coup de boule. On va se prendre un coup
de boule. Bah bienvenue dans le monde
réel. Enfin, je veux dire, moi j'ai pris
des pêtes dans ma vie. Euh, je suis pas
là pour en parler, mais j'ai pris des
chetards. Euh, j'ai vu des gens qui ont
pris des chetars. J'ai des potes qui
sont morts. Euh, parce que des collègues
qui suicident, moi j'en ai hein, à Bel
Château, petit village du sud Touren,
j'ai un papa qui a perdu ses deux fils
qui se sont pendus. Euh, ça c'est pas
une c'est pas de la littérature. Non,
mais
don un qui était à l'école avec moi et
l'autre était en BTS un an en avant, les
deux pendus. Euh alors, il y a toujours
une excuse. Ah bah oui, il y en a un qui
éit un peu dépressif. à l'autre, ben il
a pas supporté de de perdre son frère.
Non, on arrête les conneries. Ils
étaient en difficulté financière.
C'était dur pour eux. Il y a un marasme
économique agricole qui est sous-jacent
depuis très longtemps, depuis trop
longtemps. Donc, on arrête de tourner
autour du pot. Et on a une classe
politique qui font les idiots utiles
avec deux trois petites cacahuètes qui
traînent par-ci par là, avec une
ambition qui est pas là et une stratégie
qui est pas là. Ben, ça va leur péter à
la tronche. Moi, qu'est-ce que que vous
voulez que je vous dise ? Je ne serai
pas le comptable de ça, pas pour me
sauver. J'ai pas peur. J'ai pas besoin
d'être sauvé. Moi si demain je suis pas
élu, je vous l'ai déjà dit, je rentre
sur ma ferme. Mais parce que apporter sa
caution et et la ministre de
l'agriculture m'a dit "Vincent, pourquoi
tu viens pas à Ringis
pour ma grande messe sur la réarmement
de la de de l'agriculture ?" Je lui dis
écoute moi, les effets de manche très
peu pour moi donc je viens pas et je
veux même plus m'occuper des questions
agricoles. J'ai un peu menti. Pourquoi ?
parce que je lui ai dit, je ne sais même
pas ce que je vais dire au paysan au
salon de l'agriculture au mois de
février. J'ai eu quoi comme victoire
depuis un an et demi pour les
agriculteurs ? Que de balles, zéro.
Alors oui, là on déplie des petits
accessoires, des choses. Est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on a des adoucissements
sur tout un tas de normes qui ont été
mises ? Zéro. On a fait une loi cet été,
la loi du plomb 2 millions de personnes
ont voté contre pour de la
surtransposition basique à de balles. 2
millions de personnes ont voté contre.
Donc on le Conseil constitutionnel pour
arranger le gouvernement a dit "On rend
pas crédible les articles." Don on a
débranché. Tous les paysans ont vu ça.
Bah en fait, on peut rien changer dans
ce pays. Donc euh oui, on va avoir un
retour de flamme. Et j'ai envie de dire
bah moi les gars, j'aurais pas participé
à mettre de l'essence sur le feu, mais
euh je je dirais bah il faut qu'on se
bouge pour être créatif, pour écouter
les vrais experts et puis se sortir les
doigts pour écrire une partition qui est
autre chose que des mensonges politiques
pour être élu président de la
République. Parce que maintenant est-ce
que la la retraite c'est 45 ans, 50 ans,
60 ans par pure idéologie ? Alors que
vous savez, moi j'ai vu des maçons
continuer à bosser à 67 ans, ils étaient
cassés de tous les côtés ou un
charpentier, tu peux pas prendre et puis
un journaliste peut pas prendre sa
retraite à taper et puis à avoir un truc
dans un fauteuil
au même âge. On n jamais traité ça en
fait. On n jamais parlé aux gens en
fonction de la pénibilité. Donc à force
de pas parler au français, de rien
trouver comme solution, et ben ça va mal
finir les gars. Bienvenue dans le monde
réel, on le sait. Et et je veux vous
dire, moi je je suis très inquiet mais
ça m'empêche pas que je me lève tous les
matins pour aller au fight.
Les Français les Français sont quand
même vachement cool.
Ouais bah bien sûr qu'ils sont cool
parce que ils sont ils sont pas encore
montés. J'ai pas vu de politiciens
encore pendu au lampadaire. Ah non, mais
ils vont voter les Français, c'est comme
ça qu'ils vont nous faire la peau. Ils
vont voter.
Bah, ils vont voter. Le grand Oui, le
grand drame. Moi, je voudrais parler du
drame politicien euh et je voudrais
parler de messemmer. Me permettez 2
secondes, en 1974. Non, non, mais juste
non mais c'est très intéressant. Je je
veux jeux c'est Mesmer, il met en place
le plan Mesmer en 1974. Ça a 50 ans et
si on a de l'électricité dans ce studio,
c'est grâce à mes
et il décide il y a 50 ans et et un
petit merde de comme toi là à
méfie-toi, je fais 120 kg si tu me redis
ça je me lève, je te mets un coup de
bénéficier.
Donc je pense qu'on peut avoir un peu de
respect pour le premier ministre. Donc
le problème c'est que la politique
énergétique elle est sur des longues
périodes alors que les politiciens
prennent des décisions au coin de table
d'accord politicien et ça crée des
drames personnels et humains. C'est ça
le problème auquel on est concerné. Il y
a de la politique politicienne dans
l'énergie au détriment du long terme.
Nicolas Nicolas,
moi j'ai un deal pour pour Vincent
les
Non non non
les 14 milliards pour les énergies
renouvelables. Moi je te propose Vincent
on sort de l'Union européenne les 14
milliards j'en donne neuf aux
agriculteurs et j'en garde cinq pour ton
plan d'électrification. Tuen penses ?
Mais oui, mais moi je veux bien mais euh
le problème c'est qu'en agriculteur, je
vends 40 % de toutes les productions de
la France euh enfin 35 % exactement aux
autres pays européens. Donc je veux bien
qu'on construise des murs autour de nous
mais euh j'ai un premier problème de
faire un mur. Euh les anglais ils
continuent de faire du business avec je
veux dire euh la première des réactions
quand tu sors, c'est quand même qu'on te
fait pas des bisous à l'arrivée. Ça
c'est le premier truc. 2e truc, euh on a
fait des accords de droit privés,
totalement privés, qui s'appelle des
contrats de droits privés avec les
prestataires éoliens qui s'impose dans
le budget de l'État. C'est-à-dire moi,
je veux bien qu'on invente le truc et
qu'on dise "Eh les gars, c'est fini,
allez tous vous faire mettre."
Le problème c'est que là on sera on sera
condamné sur une dépense publique parce
que le droit privé à ce qui est de vrai
mais c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un
contrat avec des gens qui ont rien
demandé parce qu'ils ont cru en la
parole de l'État et qui demandent que
l'État honore son contrat pendant 15 ans
et on a quand même signé pour 15 20
annet. La France dispose de ressources
significatives à l'échelle européenne.
Environ 700 millions de barils de
chistes source ANRT,
500 tonnes de lithium, 20 à 25 % de
ressources mondiales de nickel, beaucoup
de ressources en or significatives la
plupart de ces exploitations semblent
être bloquées.
Norme environnementale lobbing des
multinationales car plus rentable à
l'étranger. Pourquoi n'exploite pas
n'exploitons pas ces richettes ces
richesses ? Ne se ne serait-ce pas moins
impactant en CO2 que de l'importer du
Qatar ?
Et ben pour courage pour ouvrir une
carrière en France alors que dès que tu
veux planter un boulon ou un autoroute,
tu as 200 associations qui te tombent
sur le poil. Donc quand faut bouger 200
300 400 tonnes pour avoir 1 g de de de
truc enfin de de métau rare. Ça coûte
aussi un peu de pognon. Le poids des
normes en France fait que on sera pas du
tout compétitif si on veut demain ouvrir
une carrière. Le gaz de chiste, on en a
déjà parlé, c'est quand même une
porcherie intégrale de de de faire du
gaz de chiste à juste titre, on l'a
interdit en France. Donc récupérer le
gaz des des de la des mines, ça semble
le bon sens paysan de récupérer du gaz
qui est dans des dans des couloirs. Le
gaz de chis, la technologie est en train
d'évoluer. Peut-être qu'on évoluera dans
15 20 30 ans. Par contre, se couper de
la recherche de pétrole et de gaz aux
outresem, moi je peux vous dire le
projet de loi qui a été lancé par un
sénateur, le sénateur patient, il
s'appelle des outresemères et ben je
vais le soutenir, je vais être
rapporteur parce que autrement on
importe, on a on a on utilise je crois 1
% de notre consommation provient de de
France sur sur le pétrole. 1 % vous
imaginez ? Donc demain, si on peut être
un peu autosuffisant grâce, on a quand
même Total qui a un peu de savoir-faire.
Donc on peut reprendre la recherche sur
le pétrole dans les territoires de notre
mer, notamment en Guyane.
Alors commentaire internet. Bonjour,
votre invité raconte n'importe quoi sur
les petits colis venant de Chine. La TVA
s'applique au-delà de 150 € d'achat. Et
à partir du 1er euro depuis le 2024,
depuis le 1er janvier, la France
applique 2 € de taxe par article envoyé
acheté par un particulier auquel
s'ajoute 3 € par l'Union européenne. En
juillet, la TVA ne peut pas être
fraudée. Les achats sur les plateformes
chinoises sont automatiquement collectés
sur le montant payé au fournisseur et
pas basé sur une simple déclaration. Les
caméras acheté quatre fois plus chères
en France chez les revendeurs
proviennent elles aussi de Chine mais
elles sont achetées en lot par des
entreprises. Donc donc sans la taxe sur
les particuliers, les 75 % de marge
justifie pas tout le temps les 3 ans de
garantie et le SAV européen ou là là le
commentaire il est long comme le bras.
Taxer les petits articles pas chers. Les
Chinois vont monter en gamme pour
devenir compétitif sur les articles fini
les plus chers créant de facto une
concurrence directe avec les produits
haut de gamme européens 6 taxés. Les
petits articles privés privent les
particuliers de la capacité à réparer
eux-mêmes leurs appareils et font
augmenter les prix des prototypes dont
les pièces ne sont pas produites en
Europe. Pour résumer, il faut arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi sur une simple
coup de mer pour chercher un coupable
silencieux.
Attendez. Taxe sur les petits colis.
Mise en place dans le budget voté il y a
un an par l'excellent sénateur
Rochette de Saint-Étienne qui a proposé
ça dans je sais plus quelle loi sur la
face la face fashion.
Donc mis en place dans le budget, il y a
pas de budget, je vous signe. Donc la
taxe des petits colis n'est pas
opérationnelle. L'Europe a dit qu'ils
allaient en mettre une de 3 €. Ils ont
juste dit qu'ils allaient la mettre. Il
y a rien qui est opérationnel
aujourd'hui. Et oui, il a raison. J'ai
pas été assez précis. C'est c'est la
taxe par principe des petits colis,
c'est en dessous de 150 €. C'est duty
free en dessous de 150 €. Et pour la
TVA, on a de la fraude massive en TVA.
C'est référencé euh par la la les
douanes dans plusieurs rapports. Donc,
il peut dire que je raconte n'importe
quoi là-dessus. Je raconte pas tout à
fait n'importe quoi.
Question. Il y a Qu'est-ce qu' les
sénateur ? Il y a beaucoup de questions.
Monsieur le sénateur, grâce à cette
personne bienveillante, connaît-il
les détenteurs étrangers non nationaux
de la dette française ?
Réfléchis Nicolas trois livres.
Moi j'avais un truc à dire avant,
je suis désolé.
Vous y mettez là les gars.
Non mais il y a un truc pas parlé. Je
vais pas une boîte de pendant mais on n
pas du tout parlé de géopolitique et je
pense que on a une chance euh en Europe,
c'est l'élection de Donald Trump.
Peut-être pas une bonne chance he
bah moi je pense que c'est une chance
parce que ça va nous nous obliger à ça
va un petit peu changer les rapports du
monde. On va arrêter à se faire des
sourir les tapes dans le dos et cetera
et on va on va devoir un peu se
challenger
se challenger et puis et c'est quand
l'eau se retire qu'on voit qu'il y avait
un maillot de bain. Donc là on va
pouvoir c'est la chance pour l'Europe
d'exister. C'est sa chance. Euh c'est sa
chance de se réindustrialiser. On a les
États-Unis, la Russie, la Chine et
l'Europe. Ils nous ont coupé le
cordonical de la Russie. La Russie est
partie à à dériver vers la Chine. Ils
sont en train de la rattraper extrémiste
parce que en fait ils ont oublié que
leur ennemi principal c'était la Chine.
Et nous, on se retrouve là, on a plus
les Russes, on a les Chinois qui
arrivent et qui nous qui nous inondent
de tous leurs produits et on a les
Américains qui nous interdisent de
bosser avec les Chinois. Donc il y a un
moment donné, il va falloir se se
réveiller et moi je pense que ce qu'on
doit faire et c'est ce et il trouve
effectivement que c'est sur ce que c'est
sur ce sur quoi je travaille depuis 2
ans, c'est qu'il va falloir faire du
Trump. Faire du Trump, ça veut dire quoi
? Ça veut dire et je je vois qu' il y en
a qui en parlent de plus en plus, il va
falloir se protéger protéger. Et nous ce
qu'on propose et c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut faire d'ailleurs sans sortir
de l'Union européenne, c'est notamment
de se protéger des pays les plus
polluants. Nous, on a réfléchi une idée
qui consiste à imposer
le vert et faire des des voitures pas
lourdes. C'est ça
imposer Non non, ça c'était c'était
avant ça. Imposer une taxe à
l'importation sur tous les pays qui
utilisent plus de 200 TW d'électricité
au charbon. Donc ça vous fait la Chine,
l'Inde, les États-Unis, le Japon,
l'Afrique du Sud, l'Indonésie et la
Russie. Et ces pays-là, ils vont avoir
une taxe à l'importation équivalente à
la part du charbon dans leur
électricité. Infini, ça donne quoi ? Ça
donne 60 milliards d'euros qu'on
pourrait récupérer chaque année. 60
milliards, il me semble qu'il y avait
certains premier ministres, c'est à peu
près ce qui ce qu'il cherchaient. 60
milliards, c'est le déficit des
retraites pour le régime public. Euh 60
milliards, c'est une grande partie euh
du coup du travail qu'on pourrait euh
qu'on pourrait enlever des charges de
nos entreprises pour les mettre sur nos
importations. En gros, c'est quoi l'idée
? Financer euh notre modèle social par
les importations de de produits
polluants et ça au niveau européen, ce
qui est pas con,
il y aura pas de de mesures de rétorsion
des pays polluants ?
Non, parce qu'on a ils ont besoin de nos
nos 400 millions de consommateurs. En
fait,
on a une force en Europe. Ouais. et on
n'utilise pas nos 500 millions de
consommateurs et je rappelle ça mis au
niveau européen, c'est 450 milliards
d'euros hein.
Je rappelle que le budget de l'Union
européenne c'est 200 milliards par an.
Deux fois le budget de l'Union
européenne juste avec ça. Il y a des
pistes qui sont intéressantes.
Qui détient la dette ?
Alors qui détient la dette ? C'est assez
structuré déjà les Français un peu un
peu.
Non les les
la dette de la dette de la France.
Alors, je répète la question. Monsieur
le sénateur, grâce à cette personne
bienveillante,
connaît-il le les détenteurs étrangers
entre parenthèses non nationaux de la
dette française ?
Alors euh les étrangers euh elle est un
peu complexe la question parce que c'est
des c'est des trucs un peu structurés,
un peu ils ont un peu trétisé la bête
titri enfin je sais plus comment on dit
titrisé. Ouais. Euh euh la proportion
euh la proportion j'arriverai pas à vous
la dire.
Moi j'aurais bien aimé que le sénateur
réagisse sur ma proposition.
J'ai dit que c'était bon. C'est tout.
Vous allez trop vite parce que Non mais
non mais parce qu'il a switché.
Euh attendez, je réfléchis sur la dette.
Donc pendant qu'il réfléchit trois
livres.
Non non non, je vais pas trouver.
Trois livres.
Trois livres. Bah moi écoute trois
livres.
un classique, j'aime beaucoup qui a un
peu ma bible mais il faudrait que je le
relise à l'heure l'âge des lotèches de
Philippe Biwix.
Ouais, il est pas mal. Ça vaut le coup
de le lire parce que c'est à peu près
dans un monde contrat en énergie, en
ressources, c'est à peu près à ça que ça
va ressembler. D'ailleurs, il parle un
peu de mettre en place du
productionnisme et de produire
localement, ce qui me semble pas
complètement déconnant. Et après deux
autres livres un peu
bah de copain euh Loï le Floc Prégent
écrit un livre qui s'appelle 1980 1997,
je crois que c'est l'année du début du
déclin de la France, un truc comme ça.
Euh bon 97 hein, 35 super phenx et
cetera. Et le deuxième la fin du
macronisme.
Donc Fabien c'est pas en place même pas
un de ces trois bouquins de machin.
Non mais Fabien je peux lui en parler.
Non mais mes copains défunt
Fabien [rires] Fabien est encore là
parmi nous
encore vivant je vais peut-être pas
sortir vivant d'ici studio l prent et
Olivier Marlex la fin du macronus
alors
paix à son âme.
H
Olivier tu nous manques
Fabien. Moi, je vais lire un classique
ravage de Barjavel que j'ai lu tout
petit qui est essentiel parce que il
parle d'un Blackout et je l'ai relu cet
été et vraiment j'ai éprouvé beaucoup de
plaisir parce que je pense que mon
combat aujourd'hui sur l'énergie, je le
dois à la lecture de ce livre quand
j'étais gamin. Ravage de Bargevel. Euh
je fais pas voilà deux autres livres,
les illusionnistes alors plus récents de
Gérald Nin Vosner et de Erwan Sesneek
qui explique l'infiltration des réseaux
d'écologistes
antinucléaires au cœur du système. Et
puis pour citer une personne qu'on a
évoqué aujourd'hui, bah le livre de
d'Henry Progliot qui avait publié il y a
un an, je crois, un an ou deux qu'il
avait sorti sur les enjeux énergétiques
de la France.
Penson petit traité et grande vertu de
Consponville parce que ça c'est un grand
classique. J'aime bien celui-là et je
l'ai revu sur un bureau il y a pas
longtemps. 1000 milliards en en fumée de
de Lomé sur Kerviel, j'is bien aimé. Et
puis un petit dernier, le voyage
d'Hector de Le Lor euh sur un inuite qui
devient qui raconte sa vie d'inouite en
parallèle d'un copain millionnaire et
sur le sens de la vie.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
qui restera impérissable.
Ouh là ! Et commencez les gars, un
bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations. Le travail, travaillez,
faites-vous plaisir.
Faites-vous plaisir. Le plaisir dans la
vie et le travail par le plaisir.
Moi, je dirais aux jeunes générations
que l'histoire n'est jamais écrite et
que ce sont les hommes qui font
l'histoire par leurs actes et par
l'évolution et par ce qu'ils vont faire
et qui a pas de sens de l'histoire.
Chaque homme peut intervenir et avoir
son petit rôle, un rôle d'élu. par un
rôle de lanceur d'alette, un spécialiste
dans le débat public. C'est pas
forcément la politique qui peut
permettre de faire évoluer des choses.
C'est parfois des interventions humaines
et ça c'est essentiel. Euh ce qu'il faut
aux jeunes générations, moi j'ai un
certain nombre d'enfants, c'est de leur
dire que j'en ai huit. On va
bien. Voilà.
démographique, j'ai j'ai le réarbement
démographique et j'ai deux petits
enfants
et euh et donc euh ce que je diraiis à
mes enfants, c'est
J'ai 52 ans.
Et ton premier, il a quel âge ?
26.
Magnifique.
Voilà. Et euh je leur dis euh que c'est
par leur acte qu'ils feront bouger les
choses. Voilà.
Il faut pas attendre. Faut pas attendre.
Ce que vous faites dans votre vie
raisonne dans l'éternité. C'est ça
ce que j'essaie de donner comme exemple
à mes enfants de ténacité, de faire
évoluer les choses, j'essaie de leur
propager, mais c'est valable pour tous
les enfants de France, hein.
Nicolas,
moi je vais te donner un conse
Nicolas Toba, il a 12 enfants. [rires]
Un conseil de
avec la même femme, hein.
Oui. Oui. un conseil de vote pour voter
parce que c'est pas facile quand on est
quand on est jeune de savoir pour qui on
va voter. On va c'est difficile d'avoir
accès aux informations, de se faire une
idée. On est influencé par ses parents,
par ses copains. Et moi j'ai eu du mal
et je crois que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui pour qui je vais voter en
2027.
Non mais non mais non
si je vais voter pour le candidat qui je
pense sera le mieux défendre l'intérêt
de notre pays notamment à Bruxelles
[rires] premièrement et deuxièmement le
candidat qui sera capable de s'entourer
de gens de bons conseillers et si on
réunit ces deux trucs là je pense qu'on
on a encore des des motifs d'espérer et
que la France fasse ce qu'elle a
toujours fait c'estàdire qu'elle soit
toujours relevée après être tombé
On a tout abordé messieurs. Merci.
Merci merci beaucoup. Merci à vous les
gars.
[musique]